[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
for the last seven years and counting
the best Blitz and bullet players in the
world have flocked to chess.com to prove
their worth at this format
wow and Hikaru wins the game
in seven years dozens have tried but
only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy he wins the
speed Chess Championship fifth in a row
who will be this year's Blitz King
Magnus isn't human
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
foreign
[Music]
my God what an intro that was well it's
time for me to introduce you to the
long-awaited finals of the 2023 speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
where Magnus Carlson will be taking on
Hikaru Nakamura just about 15 minutes
from now I can't wait we're gonna have
to wait another couple of minutes I'm
your host Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky
and alongside me to cover the finals
Grand Master Amman Hamilton I'm on what
do we even say in this situation
what do we say Daniel I actually am so
like nervous anxious excited in a good
way I can't wait for this I mean I don't
think anyone had a more picturesque
final at the beginning of the SEC right
than seeing these two guys meet at the
end of the road this is a rematch from
last year it's a rematch from 2016 and
2017 and it is the next entry in an
incredible series of matches that has
defined Magnus vs Hikaru as one of if
not the premier rivalry in modern online
chess history and they will be duking it
out yet again to determine the SEC Crown
now their path to the topam on it hasn't
been all that easy but largely they've
taken care of business they've defeated
players in good form Hikaru defeating
mvl in the bullet that was a tough match
Magnus Carlson 22 7 speaks for itself
it really does 22-7 against Wesley and
if I had to pick a player in the entire
SCC who would not get blown out maybe in
a match ever but not by Magnus it would
be Wesley so it's crazy that he was able
to do that and as you mentioned Nakamura
beating mvl who's the most on-form nvl
that I think I'd seen I'm just so
impressed by both of these guys
deserving finalists
absolutely they are deserving that's the
right word to use and they also have a
storied history not just overall over
the board in Rapid but also specifically
in the speech has Championship where
both Magnus and Hikaru have competed uh
through several several eras it's weird
to even think about what happened in
2016. I don't remember what I was doing
in 2016. I don't remember anything about
that year the one thing I do remember is
that Magnus Carlsen defeated Hikaru
Nakamura back in the times when the SEC
was five plus two and three plus two
with a final score of 14 and a half to
ten and a half and Amanda's was the sort
of first entry in what would become an
epic rivalry do you remember that match
as we were looking at some clips there
oh my God Memory Lane anybody with the
dinosaur I am I I seem to remember this
uh Daniel I've been around so I can
actually say that I was there at the
beginning of the Rivalry as it was just
budding I mean we have one quarter of
Magnus Carlson's face there and you know
Hikaru has got his classic or orange
background that has a few more
decorations now
yeah you know there's that silver
YouTube button and there's that shelf
that there's the LED pineapple 2016 man
I'm surprised these players even had
internet them on I know like this this
goes back that far is what we're trying
to say it does indeed and it went back
also to 2017 because these same two
players faced off the following year as
well and it was a similar story it was a
convincing even more convincing victory
for Magnus Carlson who went wire to wire
if you never trailed in the match he led
six to three after the five minute
portion added added on a point with a
three minute portion and then ran
through the bullet tacking on five more
now hikaru's gotten better since then
and we're gonna talk about that but
let's take a moment to appreciate that
2017 was an incredible year for Magnus
Carlson on the board and also online
truly I mean there there was like a page
I feel like that ikaru turned in this
rivalry but at the beginning Magnus was
he was doing everything to be Hikaru in
the bullet I think is the biggest
statement from this 2017 performance
because you know he might catch Hikaru
in the blitz but Hikaru always had that
bullet so for Magnus to do that was like
a real shock
but then something amazing happened
amont Hikaru started streaming back in
The naka's Knockouts days I don't know
who in the chat remembers those evening
streams I would always tune in then he
started streaming on his own channel I
was living for those streams and
something clicked something changed the
car and I can wear the Beast became
Hikaru Nakamura the big boss the
unbeatable and in the subsequent few
years he did not face Magnus in the SEC
finals but that's not to say he didn't
face stalwart opposition just look at
some of those opponents and look at some
of those scores 18 and a half 12 and a
half in 2021 he defeated Wesley 23-8 and
yes we're deliberately leaving out 2022.
we'll get to that in a moment but look
at this domination I'm on
this is a I mean this is a storyline and
we're all here following it it started
with Magnus getting the better of him
but then Hikaru is reminding people and
proving that look if you don't put
Magnus Carlson in these tournaments I'm
gonna dominate the competition and win
it every single year
indeed and when it convincingly when it
without any doubt I mean even the
quote-unquote close matches were
essentially controlled by Hikaru from
the very beginning and nobody it seems
other than Magnus can match him on speed
and on accuracy and nobody other than
Magnus seems to share hikaru's ability
to just turn it on in high pressure
moments most of these top players as
experiences they are they struggle in
high pressure situations but Hikaru
actually thrives in them and a big high
pressure situation in which Hikaru
thrived in a big way Amman came in last
year's SCC final against Magnus
this is I mean this is what it's all
about Dania I mean NACA getting his
revenge is such a storyline because I
feel like in one of the most unfair uh
takes ever it was like oh Hikaru can't
uh compete with Magnus it's like this
old thing that people used to say and I
remember when he first beat Magnus over
the board I feel like things just
clicked uhikara woke up and he was like
I can compete with this guy not just
over the board online in every single
format every single facet and once that
I guess he was just like getting over a
little bit of a hump there once he did
that he woke up and started competing
with Magnus seriously and a lot of
people watching uh this this streamer
and I don't know why you'd be watching
Magnus vs Hikaru on a Friday afternoon a
month and there's so many better things
to do than watching an SEC final but in
case you have carved out some time uh to
watch us Vamp about this match it was
incredible just the extent and of
magnus's over-the-board dominance back
in 2013-2014 I think their over the
board score at some point was something
like 7-0 with a couple of draws and like
you said him on hikara won one or two
games and it's like something clicked
that I think coupled with the confidence
that his stream has given him and his
community has given him has turned
Hikaru into somebody who almost never
fails to perform at the highest level
Under Pressure which is which makes him
a unicorn even among his peers at the
very highest echelons of Chess and last
year was an incredible final it was a
one point match and it all came down to
the wire Iman it came down to Magnus
trying to Checkmate Hikaru with enough
time to play another game in the match
and Hikaru was able to procrastinate
that two seconds until after the match
clock ended were you watching that final
and you better say yes yes look whether
or not it's true I was I was did no I
was really there I I've actually been
watching every single magnacy car match
I'm a fan as much a commentator and a
player myself and just speaking from
experience Dania as someone who played
chess and then started streaming uh yeah
I know how it feels to kind of lose your
Edge in the competitive aspect of Chess
so what Hikaru is doing is truly
phenomenal truly unique he started
streaming and it feels like he's only
gotten better it's it's actually insane
it really is and you said excited I'm
excited like a little Schoolboy you know
like coming to school in the morning and
discovering a box of donuts and they're
all yours you know they're nobody else's
but yours this is going to be amazing
but let's talk a little bit more about
the player's frame of frames of mind
going into today's match after his match
against Wesley on Tuesday we asked
Magnus if anything has changed between
the two of them between him and Hikaru
since last year's final as well as his
outlook on this year's match let's take
a listen to Magnus Carlson
to be honest I was pretty sure that I
was going to beat him in the final last
time so
I don't think that there is that much of
a
that much of a difference there
um yeah well I'm still up to one against
him and in speed Chess Championship
matches so
you know whoever um whoever wins this
one is gonna have some some writing
rights for sure
okay I'm on there's two there's two
things that should jump out to me there
the first is that he's Ultra confident
in spite of his performance last year
the second thing is that these matches
are equally as important to the players
as they are to the fans neither Magnus
nor Hikaru whom we'll get to in a second
are thinking of this as a casual Friday
afternoon match that doesn't decide
anything which I love this is important
to them
yep yep this isn't some online Maps the
SEC has become the the Pinnacle Online
event and trust me these guys know the
score between each other I don't think
they're forgetting those numbers Magnus
is quick to remind it's like okay you
know Hikaru got me but guess what I've
still got the lifetime score so this
match is really important there's a big
difference Daniel between two two and
three one absolutely and it reminds me
of you know when they'd asked Michael
Jordan after a big game you know Michael
were you aware that you were about to
get 60 points what do you think I was
born yesterday of course I was aware I
was looking at the scoreboard the entire
time they know what the head-to-head
score is they know what's at stake here
and uh of course Hikaru does as well the
CaRu defeated mvl in the semi-finals
that was a Topsy Turvy match but
ultimately Nakamura ran away in the
bullet after his performance in the
interview we asked Sakara what he
thought the key would be to beating
Magnus in the final today and reprising
his incredible performance from last
year here is what Hikaru had to say
well I mean the first thing is that I
get to play Magnus a lot I mean I think
I'm playing him on Friday in the final
and I'm playing him on Monday in the
chess Champions Tour as well so I'll get
to play Magnus quite a bit in the the
next three days um you know I think
looking at the match it's it goes
without saying that also play a lot
better than I played today I think today
um I started off very very poorly in the
first couple of games Maxine was really
really sharp um so I'll have to play a
lot better if I do I think I have
chances obviously I won last year um but
you know Magnus obviously has been on
been on a big run so we'll kind of see
how it goes I I feel I feel like if I
played to the best of my ability I'll
have great chances especially if I can
keep it close going to Bullet but again
you know and if anyone's guess what will
happen
good evening
that was Hikaru Nakamura after his
semi-final against mvl I think one thing
is very clear two things are very clear
the first is that if both the car and
Magnus played at the best of their
abilities online we will get something
resembling last year's match it's going
to be close the second thing though I'm
on is that Hikaru will have to step up
his game compared to his match against
Maxine because Magnus is not going to
let go of a three or four point lead in
the bullet
yep I think uh you know all things
considered I think it is fair to say
that coming into this match between
these two players uh I think Carlson is
on better form than Nakamura you know
respective to themselves he has been
doing something else in this SEC
competition the way that he just stormed
through Wesley so like he wasn't the
competition that he in fact is uh it's
just incredible both of these guys I
mean I'm so excited to get into this
match Daniel but Magnus and Hikaru you
can't ask for anything better than this
I mean are we are we trembling is it
about to start traveling we're five
minutes and changed away from the match
and you set it him on when Magnus is
angry when he's got a chip on his
shoulder he's even more terrifying than
you know a happy Magnus and a happy
Magnus is already pretty terrifying so
the stages the stage is Set uh but we've
got another couple of minutes to delve
into this match that will be played
today let's take a look at our Deloitte
game analytics we're thrilled to have
Deloitte a leader in their field as the
official Data Insights partner for the
speed Chess Championship their
dedication to Excellence aligns
perfectly with the chess.com mission to
grow the game in the sport of Chess and
without further Ado here's page one of
our Deloitte game analytics the age both
of them over 30. well not a spring
chicken anymore
yeah the graying hair the arthritic
hands how are they gonna play bullet
should we eliminate the bullet portion
of mine
I think that the bullet right now
between these two is such an interesting
part of the match because Hikaru is
basically supposed to be the guy in
bullet but Magnus had you know had that
over him at the start I feel like he
doesn't have it anymore and kikaru
Nakamura has that it's almost like the
nitrous boost at the end of a race that
he has that ability to win any match
even when he's losing in the bullet even
Magnus is well aware of that well said
it's the cheat code for Hikaru Nakamura
and the fact that Magnus holds that 30
to 24 lead in the bullet that's a
confidence boost from Magnus Carlson and
I think a lot of that is due to the one
second increment that we have in the
speed Chess Championship they've also
faced off in the last few bullet brawls
and I think they're still pretty evenly
matched in OnePlus zero but I think the
increment that one second does give
Magnus Carlson a little bit of a boost
and on that note let's go to page two of
our Deloitte game analytics the rating
information and also the game win
percentage Magnus Carlson well over 50
the only SEC participant to have a win
rate in any individual game a likelihood
of over 50 percent how incredible is
that
yeah I remember commentating another
match in the SEC and these players that
I was commentating had win rates of 30
and I was like guys this is actually a
really high win rate there's a lot of
draws at the top level yeah getting 30
of your games is super super impressive
and then now you see Magnus and he's got
over 50 win rate and Hikaru not far
behind these guys win a lot I'm hoping
that we see that kind of a battle Daniel
where you know we'll get some draws but
I'm excited to see wins by hikar wins by
Magnus back and forth we are gonna go
back and forth and that needed to be
clarified in mind if you see a 47 win
likelihood it doesn't mean there's a 53
loss likelihood probably means there's a
40 draw likelihood and a 13 loss
likelihood well the likelihood that we
get a close match is very high smarter
chess seems to agree as we take a quick
look at the smarter chess predictions uh
who calls for a victory by Magnus
Carlson and he believes that Magnus will
do the heavy lifting in the three plus
one portion and I think that's a reason
reasonable take Amon given the fact that
Magnus has actually never lost a three
plus one portion to Hikaru Nakamura
previously so that might indeed be the X
Factor in this match that middle 60
Minutes of three plus one chess
yeah you know I feel I feel like one of
those Sports analysts who's like you
know when this referee has called the
game on a Wednesday the three plus one
portion has always been won by Magnus
and it's like that's weird to think
about it's been such close matches
between these guys it's gone back and
forth you wouldn't think there's a stat
out there that is overwhelming in one
player's favor but yeah I guess this is
one of them so actually be on the
lookout for that one the three plus one
section often and always goes to Magnus
Carlson and I also feel like a sports
analyst I'm on I feel like the sports
analyst was about to say something
completely wrong and mispredict the
course of the match and that's why I've
I know better than that at this stage in
my commentating career we have no idea
what the X Factor is going to be in this
match we have no idea what the decisive
segment is going to be in this match it
really could be anything and that's a
product of the incredible level that
both these players display if they're at
the top of their game we might get an
even match until the very last game we
just don't know and Magnus Carlson also
agrees he said uh on uh his 2022 final
versus the current Nakamura the
following this is as good as it gets
speed chess matches between Hikaru and I
be that Blitz or Rapid or even boulay
that's as good a show As It Gets In
chess that's coming from Carlson himself
so if the players are excited if they're
amped up that's the best news that we
can hear we already talked about it I'm
on this is really important to the
players they're taking this as seriously
as an over as a serious over the board
event maybe even more so
honestly I feel like this is as good as
it gets you know speed chess matches
between Hikaru and Magnus whether it's
Blitz Rapid or even bullet I mean that's
as good a show As It Gets In chess which
is what I think I think we could just
look at the cams of the players without
even seeing the board for the whole time
and we would be plenty entertained but
no we promise that a chess board will
appear shortly as will the first game
between Hikaru and Magnus the gong is
about to sound and we will commence with
90 minutes an hour and a half of five
minutes with a one second increment
seat belts fasten them on and mandatory
mandatory for the first time in the SEC
because we are underway with Hikaru
having the white pieces in the first
game here we go
here we go indeed E4 E5 and I mean
thinking back to the the very first time
they played they didn't even have five
plus one Daniel they were playing five
plus two
and back in the day when we had the
telegrams and uh we had the phonograms
and Thomas Edison was still alive uh but
we still had the Roy Lopez and they
literally did because this opening has
been around since the 1500s that is when
uru Lopez de Segura a Spanish priest
published his treaties on chess openings
and recommended this opening for the
first time and we see the D3 variation
uh as we so commonly do uh these days
yeah I feel like uh you know white is
always on the lookout for something that
doesn't just you know completely
simplify into these martial type of
lines with D5 you know Pawn sacrifices
the players are so well prepared that
yeah they they can do these things and
just liquidate and simplify to a draw
and that is part of the reason rookie
one is played to discourage the move D5
which could be played anyway the other
reason I'm on is this classic re Lopez
maneuver where the Knight comes out to
D2 and then drops back to F1 and settles
on G3 kind of massing the forces on the
king side because the king side is
ultimately where white wants to butter
his bread
that's right that's such a classic
maneuver and if anyone is you know
onlooking and being like I don't
understand anything about these e45
positions I see them in every top level
match well you just highlighted such a
great maneuver to just be aware of the
Knight comes to G3 and then I think the
thing that bothers players the most is
Bishop G4 it's a pin on the Knight it
looks hard to break but with the Knight
on G3 you can just play H3 and kick it
away
indeed and we see Carlson expanding on
the queen side C7 C5 all of this is
standard fare this is what I would call
a chigorean pawn structure uh the
chagoran variation itself uh it refers
to a main line where white has a Pawn on
D4 but it's important to think not only
in terms of moves but also in terms of
the general Pawn structure and you're
pointing it out I'm on white could
actually strike with D4 especially if
Black's light squared Bishop lands on E6
which it just did and there you go that
definitely lends itself to the move d4
there are other prep moves that you
could throw in like for example
completing that maneuver Knight G3 H3 is
always a decent move as well and white
often has that choice do you want to
play the move A4 and just pry open that
a file because if you trade the Rooks on
A8 it could be a timely uh moment to
bring that Queen away from the center
yeah nothing in this position happens
too fast you could look at A4 and say
what does this move threatened the A8
Rook is defended it's not about
threatening anything in on this move
it's about building up the pressure on
both sides of the board and eventually
the flood gates are going to open how
are they going to open well either by
white playing D4 or black playing D5 or
action starting to happen when White's
Knight let's say gets to F5 but right
now we're still in the you know all the
soldiers are kind of sitting in their
headquarters drinking coffee phase
that's right and there's going to be an
alarm that's going to sound very soon
and just like a you know fire department
everyone is going to come down the uh
the fire pole there H6 played actually a
really important move sometimes when you
rush the move D5 Daniel Knight G5 hits
like a truck hitting that bishop and
losing the light Square bishop and
conversely losing the dark Square Bishop
for white that's a really bad feeling
and Hikaru fighting for control of the
light Square light squares there the
bishop goes back to B3 and now we have
this italian-esque tension between the
Bishops I don't think black is going to
take on B3 we rarely see that because
that relinquishes control of the F5
square and Knight F5 it's not a
devastating move Black's Bishop could
drop back to f8 not a huge deal but not
a move that you want to allow uh to be
played easily you want to fight for that
square normally so I'm expecting Queen
D7 maybe even Knight A5 but he grabs it
he takes and he might might want to go
D5 to follow up
yeah at this point he's just making you
look bad he heard you say there's no way
Bishop takes B3 no way oh actually
actually there is one way and make that
I wonder is he gonna do the same thing
that you were mentioning with D5 but
just immediately so let's say Bishop
takes Queen takes immediately with with
D5 because I mean stuff like that you
got to be super careful about your
e-pawn
yeah and that Queen trade could
accentuate the weakness of White's
lights of White's Queen side pawns right
that B3 pawn it may not seem accessible
right now but Knight C6 to A5 and some
end game could be unpleasant and that's
how Magnus thinks Magnus is always
thinking about the ramifications if the
Queens are swapped we know that he's the
best end game player probably of all
time I certainly consider him to be and
Hikaru might want to get his Queen off
the D file if that is indeed the case
maybe a queen E2 here yes knowing that
Queen E2 is yours exactly he's keenly
aware Bishop f8 is one of these
professional moves you know it opens The
Rook up against the queen that was newly
placed on E2 and also the move Knight F5
you want to be able to play King H7 and
G6 to boot that night out so you need to
support your H Pawn and Hikaru continues
to accumulate his forces on the king
side and I think he's finally created a
threat you see it I see it Bishop C1
takes H6 overloading the pawn on G7
that's why Magnus slides his Queen up to
E6 simultaneously protecting the Knight
on F6 you want your moves to contain as
many ideas as possible and remember I
mentioned that B3 Pawn well it's
actually under Fire now
yeah it's more than Under Fire it's as
you mentioned a very annoying Pawn to
work around like what are we gonna play
Queen D1 here I think you have to just
counter attack and say look if you grab
B3 stuff's gonna happen to you on the
king side that's exactly what Mac has
gone for I'd love to move Knight F5
great move by Hikaru very heads up
decision uh to switch to the counter
attack on the king side it also bothers
Magnus that his A8 Rook is tied down to
that square you would love to bring that
Rook to d8 just to increase your control
over the center but you've got to
babysit that A6 Pawn until it reaches A5
and black might not have that Tempo to
push that pawn up especially if White's
other Knight drops into G4 later on I'm
on I will
oh could drop the F5 Knight back to E3
and fight for control over the D5 Square
so not all end games are necessarily bad
for white especially if he grabs control
over that square
absolutely I was even looking at a line
where you know if you bring that Knight
G4 move up as you mentioned the Knight
captures you could even sack this Pawn
but get your knight to the D5 Square I
think the compensation would be palpable
for Nakamura I think the G4 Square
either way is going to be involved
either uh as a placement of the Knight
on G4 or even Pawn G4 just running white
spawns up the board you could try to go
brute force and go for checkmate because
you've got a lot of forces on the king
side all three minor pieces are
participating your queen on F3 is
supervising the attack from a distance
your Rooks aren't involved yet but you
could think about a king H1 Rook G1 all
of this happens faster than people might
realize
yeah and honestly the move King H7 seems
a little cryptic but it's it's again
connected to the idea of G6 and making
sure H6 is defended you want to kick the
Knight out and honestly after Knight G4
it may not be completely insane to see
the move Knight G8 just to play G6 and
support that H Pawn again absolutely not
insane that is a very magnus-esque move
and Hikaru after a long thing that
breaks him down below a minute Rook 88
setting a trap I'm gonna interrupt
myself Rook takes a six Knight D4 is an
incredibly devilish tactical idea
take it away
oh man and it's like it's like it you
would probably think that's a blunder
but it's Magnus so you've got to think
twice here Knight D4 and it's actually
white who's getting Hoodwinked here it
is because Rook takes E6 the Knight
captures the queen with check and black
recaptures The Rook of course Hikaru
sees that and as we go back to our live
board and said he's played the move 93
down to 30 seconds in the first game as
he Nakamura the D5 Square Amman is the
reason why I think Carlson has chosen to
keep his Knight on F6 and now I think he
can grab the B3 Pawn
yep the V3 Pawn is loose well B5 is
hanging so it actually really invites I
mean takes but actually he's gonna need
it with Rook A3
okay Queen has to drop back and then B5
is lost and he's go he's going for it
yeah this looks like a really weird line
here Rook A3 looks I mean gotta go for
it
19 seconds for Nakamura as he restores
material equality now Magnus struggles
with weak pawns on the queen side but
he's grabbed another Pawn on e4 he has
eliminated the linchpin of hikaru's
central pressure Rook A4 the immediate
response laterally hitting the Knight
and that night is it gonna drop back to
F6 you can't you can go back to D6 I
think tactically but I'm expecting
either Knight F6 or even some sort of
crazy Knight D4 move using tactics uh to
establish that night in the center
now Magnus is a professional he knows
that hikara has 20 seconds he might look
for a really complicated way to proceed
because you want to use the player's
time against him how many times have you
seen Hikaru Nakamura actually down on
time by more than a minute against
anyone
no I mean almost never he's usually the
one putting that pressure he's usually
on the black side of these types of
positions Magnus pausing this is a
critical moment where does he put his
Knight even Knight D2 is on on the menu
I'm on trying to shuttle that Knight
around to B3 so that it can supervise
the weak Queen side pawns Magnus now
below a minute he's got to keep an eye
on his own clock because this minute
evaporates so quickly and Knight D4 is
on the board he's found in the best move
and I don't even have to assign a
brilliancy to that one because it popped
up for us takes and the queen is hitting
the Knight on F5 the knights are a
little bit clumsy when they're defending
one another because they can't move but
a very calm response by Hikaru he come
to comes to terms with the fact that
he's going to lose back the night and
instead he helps himself to that A5 fun
Magnus still has the initiative the
Smoke Clears a little bit and look at
how nicely Magnus pieces are positioned
all in the center Queen F6 here would
hit the F2 Pawn Magnus has to continue
making threats among and complicating
the game and hikaru's time pressure but
how does he do that
yeah it's really complicated and Hikaru
has done I think a phenomenal job the
the patience to play Queen takes A5
there when pieces were getting sacked is
actually unbelievable and he's so calm
under pressure
but the pressure continues C4 by Magnus
opening up popping open the diagonal for
black star Squad Bishop but Hikaru gets
his knife and fork ready he might have
forced the move C3 and if Magnus plays
C3 I think this one is heading toward a
draw I think Hikaru has enough time to
stabilize the game Rook C2 perfect
question Dania is can Hikaru do it
without ever moving the C1 Bishop oh my
gosh and I think he's about to move it
on the next move so Magnus better offer
a draw now yeah and Knight H3 there wait
Knight H3 Knight H3
and Magnus forgot to play that move it
was still a draft or Knight H3 but there
would have been winning chances and a
drag read
so I I think draw agreed here makes
sense but don't you think that if he had
actually played Knight takes H3 black
really pushes that right
black absolutely pushes that there was
an Intermezzo with blacks Knight on F2
could have captured the H3 Pawn with
check it would have been a three on one
I think Hikaru sees it he's shaking his
head why is he shaking his head I think
he realizes there was a little Mutual
blunder there uh at the end of the game
but the fact remains a draw in game one
what else could we have expected other
than a sharp even game of on of course
that's what we got and of course it
wasn't just like oh yada yada let's
trade all the pieces make a draw it's
like no uh we actually saw Hikaru down
to 10 20 seconds we saw a peace
sacrifice we saw two pieces for a rook
we saw a lot and it ended up in
stalemate and I would caution people in
the chat about making you know
conclusions on the basis of the first
game the players are still settling in
they're still testing each other's
opening preparations even for Hikaru and
Magnus there is a period of adjustment
where you have to settle the butterflies
in your stomach and I think they did a
great job of doing that overall I think
we're gonna see Hikaru playing a little
bit faster in subsequent games although
as I say that he is taking his time in
this second game also a rue Lopez this
one a little bit different but largely a
similar structure
yeah and it's such a such an interesting
concept uh Daniel what what would be
your like you know 30 second explanation
for why you would bring a bishop out to
develop and castle and then castle and
bring it literally back to the starting
square like how can you make that make
sense I think what people need to
understand is that open and closed
positions operate very differently this
is still a closed Center position and as
long as the center remains closed the
value of each individual Tempo is
greatly reduced you can often afford to
make more than one move with each piece
and that doesn't necessarily completely
change the dynamic of the position black
is still very fundamentally sound and
there's the answer to our question I'm
on G6 by Magnus redeploying the bishop
on G7 why in order to protect the king
and to exert long-term pressure on
White's D4 upon
and NACA with so Knack is with the black
pieces here unless I have it backwards
just confirming no um it does have black
okay just making sure
um but Bishop to G7 and it looks like
we're gonna see this Knight G3 maybe I
mean maybe just a slow moving game you
know what's interesting is this is the
same structure as a king's Indian but
it's vastly different in the sense that
rookie 8 you're not playing F5 and going
for that oh you know F4 G5 G4 I don't
think we'll see any of that so it's
gonna be much more Central play and
another big question how is white going
to is white going to resolve the tension
in the center if so there are two ways
to do it white could play D5 and then
the game does take on a more King's
Indian flavor and we actually might
potentially see black dropping the
Knight away from F6 and trying to push
the F Pawn although I agree I think it's
very unlikely but I think the likelier
scenario is for white to take on E5 and
open that Center up and then try to
massage those squares in the center get
the Knight not to G3 but maybe to E3 and
eventually to D5 Magnus though he keeps
the tension gets it to G3 how is he
going to continue are we going to see
those kga4 Bishop D2 moves just trying
to keep the tension exert as much
pressure as possible
yeah I feel like these are the kind of
games where you see Queen C1 and you're
like oh yeah that's a really really
impressive move
um yeah I I honestly think your speech
about Tempe is so relevant here you were
talking earlier about how close
positions the value of individual Tempe
is not as high and look at this we see
moves like Queen f8 rookie there's
nothing that has been captured yet
Daniel incredible still nothing that's
been captured and hikar literally
begging Meg please open up the D file so
that I can Target your queen on D2 look
at that standoff between blackstroke and
White's Queen and this greatly increases
the probability that Magnus plays D5 but
still he keeps the tension it's reached
its peak amazing amazing look at this
it's like I don't know how you want to
go D5 especially because it kind of
traps the Knight like Knight C6 can't
happen and Knight B7 to d8 to where
sorry D5 really does make sense but as
soon as you close the position Daniel
then the move at five becomes a real
idea for uh Hikaru espa with that
Queen almost posing as a rook on f8 man
that Knight on A5 reminds me of having
to fly to all those remote locations for
the world youth Chess Championship I'd
go like San Francisco to Istanbul then
you'd fly to some small Turkish city
then you'd hop on a bus and go four
hours and then get a taxi that you would
have to share to the hotel that night is
a long journey back to civilization but
look at Magnus keeps the tension shifts
his Queen from D2 to e to Y I think he's
eyeing that A6 Square actually because
Hikaru has shuttled all of his pieces to
the center in the king side and finally
we get a release of partial I should say
release of the tension as Hikaru trades
once drops his Knight back to C6 and
where is that night going from C6 that's
been a key narrative I'm on if you go to
B4 after Bishop B1 white will be
threatening A3 and the Knight is finally
trapped on B4 truly
yeah for the first time we finally see
the move D5 committed but a little bit
different now Knight E5 played in we
might see I was about to say we might
see actually Knight D2 with the idea of
f4 but he actually takes right away
okay and Rook takes E5 will likely be
met with F2 F4 although you don't want
to play F4 without careful consideration
because in the long run the E4 Pawn is
weak and an idea that we shouldn't
neglect them on is H5 H4 targeting the
Knight on G3 and softening up White's
defense of the e41 that's why Magnus is
not playing F4 automatically and might
not play it at all mm-hmm that's right
yeah white might be more interested in
maybe anticipating this and preparing
perhaps F3 just to be solid in the
center indeed and rookie 7 indirectly
defending the A7 pawn something tells me
that pawn is not going to be captured I
just I don't know why I'm just getting
that sense
you you have a very keen sense for the
position uh Dania good sense of danger I
was right Iman look at me he doesn't
take the pawn
and then this little Bishop C8 moved the
bishop is almost like what what is it
this game maybe even this match it's
like Queens on F1 and f8 I've seen both
Bishops return to their original squares
like these guys are playing so cagey
right now it's some sort of artificial
official random game I mean how often do
you even have a queen on FAA Rook not on
E8 but on E7 kind of a weird arrangement
of pieces it seems to me like Magnus
holds the advantage in this game he has
more space he's got better control of
key Central squares and the opening that
this structure reminds me of is a benoni
right that pawn on C5 White's Pawn on D5
and in a benoni the engine often
evaluates it in White's paper but in
practice it's actually very very
difficult to make concrete progress and
Magna says I'm tired of the kg play I'm
gonna go E5 and I'm gonna run you over
in the center
totally and there's an idea which I
barely even get to talk about before I
believe it's on the board right now I
almost want to award this a double uh
exclamation mark just because of how
thematic it is Daniel Pawn takes and
then white continues Pawn to F5 and all
those black pieces that want to use the
E5 Square are looking at the pawn and
saying come on dude move out of the way
and it and it does move out of the way
but he rips the Band-Aid off but he
invites White's Knight into the center
and that's the problem after Knight
takes E4 F6 is threatened D6 is
threatened the G6 Pawn is weak as well
hikaru's position is suddenly on the
verge of collapse Iman I call that
technique the square clear it's where
you push your Pawn up and vacate the
square left behind in order to put a
knight on that square Black's position
is in Dire Straits
and we are all wondering how you came up
with that great name I'm known for my
originality man that's why they pay me
the big bucks to commentate the SEC
finals and after uh E4 we essentially
have the same position except the D6
Pawn is missing because if White had
played F5 first there would have been a
Pawn on e4 Pawn on D6 White's position
is so much better with these moves
included Rook E8 and tactics everywhere
Rook takes E4 is the threat right now
yeah and the move F6 which probably
tempts a lot of people watching this
show right now I think it fails
tactically black can take on F6 and
after the trade the E3 Bishop is going
to hang it's actually a pretty easy line
to visualize if you look at that E3
Bishop that Bishop would love to be
anywhere but there and that's why Bishop
G5 here has to be seriously considered
by Magnus but it can be met with the
move F6 so yes the eval bar giving a big
Advantage but in practice a very hard
position to navigate accurately the
bishop slides up to F4 instead of G5
yeah and you know the double uh question
mark is showing up there Daniel but it's
almost a double question mark because
you could have done better not because
Bishop F4 itself was so bad
oh my goodness Hikaru forgot that Rook
takes E8 is gonna pin the queen he drops
a minor piece
yeah at first I was like wait a minute
Bishop A6 is he forgetting there's a
queen on F1 but then it was a step
further than that he knew the queen was
there but Magnus Rook takes E7 and Rook
takes E8 he is going to pull away with a
victory here especially with 10 seconds
left on the clock for Hikaru after the
Splendor and he resigns because A6 Falls
you can't take the queen and Magnus
strikes first after that initial draw
Hikaru pays the price for his time
management I actually think that in the
early going of this match the fact that
Magnus develops that 45 one minute lead
on the clock in the middle game that's
coming in very handy later on as the
game continues to complicate
absolutely I mean you can see the uh the
two competitors on screen there do you
think that is is a it really as
important as you know the fans might
make it out to be drawing that first
Blood Daniel that first win are these
guys thinking about it that much no
because this isn't their first rodeo
this isn't their first match Aman and I
don't think he car was sitting there
thinking that's it they get matches over
I didn't win the first game
he has to make in-match adjustments I
think the players are using their losses
and will use their losses as evidence of
what they're doing wrong and a big
question is going to be whether they're
able to make adjustments during the
match are they going to tweak their
openings you see Caro going to tweak his
time management the answer to the first
question at least thus far is no we have
yet another rui Lopez and this time a
third structure with the center finally
closed not by white but by black
yeah and this this uh push Pawn to D4 it
feels like wait a minute isn't white
just you know basically given a free
hand on the king side you know Black's
closing the center but still there is a
lot of play for black the move C4 is not
out of the question and it's not as
closed as white would like it to be and
if we could pull up an analysis board
I'd like to indicate a very quickly a
positional idea that's important let's
let's say white plays Bishop D2 which is
not unlikely by the way black could play
dcbc and then carve out the D4 square
with this move B4 and the reason that
move is so unpleasant is if white plays
C4 and you look at this and you look at
that Bishop on D5 I'm feeling like I'm
feeling awesome well you know what's
what else is feeling awesome a knight
that lands on D4 and after the queen
drops back to D1 black can start pushing
A5 and later on can develop that Queen
side pressure with his Pawn majority
this is to be avoided by Hikaru and he
avoids it by instituting some Queen side
tension with A4 but does that actually
increase the likely that Magnus goes for
this operation
I I think it might get exactly what you
were saying on the board guaranteed like
and no questions asked because now
before yeah by the way I I was thinking
wait a minute is there time to play a
takes B5 but actually there might not
have been because you could take on B2
there
oh okay that didn't even work yeah
instead Hikaru goes Bishop to B2 what is
the idea of that move well he is
preparing for B take C3 and he has one
goal in mind to keep that D4 Square
under lock and key you know that's like
when you go to Target and you see all
those headphones behind the glass cage
like that costs a lot of money that D4
Square your car is not giving that away
without a fight
absolutely Knight on G3 I mean look at
the prospects right Pawn on G6 was
covering everything and uh there are
greener pastures over in the center and
on the glitter side 93 yeah these are uh
some light pastures here as far as the
green ones I'm actually not sure okay
well E3 we'll call that really faster
and Bishop takes G4 runs into Bishop
takes F7 check look at how the play is
suffused with tactical awareness from
both sides there's so much of on that
remains behind the scenes and so much
that we take for granted even this small
tactic I think a lot of jams would rule
out Knight F1 oh G4 is hanging not
Hikaru both of these players so good at
spotting the smaller tactics
yep yep Queen D7 is not a bad move but
it doesn't make the threat that it seems
to make and pawn takes Knight D4 are we
just gonna snap that off
we are gonna snap that off
but now the C file opens and those
greener pastures on the queen side the
Bishop from f8 uh could access B4 The
Rook is itching to be placed on C3 nice
Outpost unassailable because white has
given up the dark scored Bishop I don't
remember when that happened
yeah exactly and I think there's a
really key uh interaction going on which
is that white cannot play Knight D2 to
C4 if that Knight could get there I
think White's position would suddenly
just be better so you want to trade
light squared Bishops Knight C4 is
anchored there but when you play Knight
D2 there was Bishop B4 so I think if
white can achieve Knight C4 and trade
these Bishops this could actually be a
really strategically sound position for
Hikaru Nakamura absolutely his Queen is
also very nicely placed on F3 uh it's
defending the D5 score it's also
pressuring F7 so it's really tying black
up on the king side and Rook fb1
threatening Rook B7 Hikaru says guess
what you open the queen side I'm going
to try to make you pay the price for
that
yep and Rook B7 will come part and
parcel with another idea of Rook takes
on F7 if you move the queen have to be
careful of that Bishop G4 there's still
the bishop to F7 move from uh previous
and I was looking at the move Rook C2
it's kind of a cute way to maybe
threaten Bishop G4
and Magnus big decision he takes on D5
and goes after that pawn but what he
does do is yield the E4 square that
square is going to be accessed by
whitesnite momentarily there's Knight G3
and Hikaru that's a positional sacrifice
he's going to give up the Pokemon D5 and
Bank on the activity of his Knight of
course that Rook could also come to B7
right now using some three tactics along
the long diagonal it is not off limits
and although Magnus is up a pawn right
now and it it is clearly up upon I think
that the Knight provides more than
enough compensation and in a Blitz game
I feel like I might just rather play
down the pawn here totally I also love
the placement of the G4 Pawn which
prevents black from kicking the Knight
away with F5 and makes moves like Rook
B7 possible for newer players the reason
that Knight F6 check doesn't win the
queen here is because the queen on D5 is
guarded by The Rook on d8 and that's the
Tactical underpinning of the move Rook
B7 you're trying to deflect the queen
onto a square along this diagonal that's
undefended and B7 happens to be the only
one of those squares
that's right and Bishop E7 and a very
nice move I mean you talk about tactics
um yeah carbon Nakamura is going to be
the top cut in the list to see them
instantly and Amman I think it's safe to
say he saw Rook B7 within a couple of
seconds he wasn't calculating this move
tactically he was just assessing the
other moves in the position he knew that
this move was in his pocket he was
looking for something better how strong
is Rook B7 I don't think it's quite as
strong as it might appear to be if
Magnus defuses the tension with Rook to
D7 here
yeah Rook D7 and still we don't have
Knight F6 available remember if the
bishop and knight ever trade that
actually favors Magnus so you have to be
super careful as Hikaru that you don't
just liquidate into some end game here
you have to keep the Queens on the board
probably keep the minor pieces on the
board and make use of your activity
maybe Rook D7 should be met with Rook a
to B1 it's so weird that The Rook on B7
is hanging and you're just casually
continuing to play Magnus could also
move his King up and if he does if
you're Hikaru you have to not forget to
move the Rook away from you know B7
that's like when your credit card
expires and you know you stop playing
paying your power goes off you're like
wait what happened hey you need to
update your card man and he does that
cut that cut uh like a real dark real
quick dark and I wasn't talking about
the power
I think we should point out because
you've been mentioning that diagonal
that this was a one of the only squares
where Knight F6 could be met by Queen
takes F6 so you weren't losing the queen
there
exactly and King G7 was played The Rook
is no longer on B7 it's now actually not
even on B6 anymore it's on B8 but it
doesn't have too many squares along the
eighth rank wait a minute Rook GHC Rook
GA check wow wow wow because Magnus
Ammon Magnus moved the Rook away from D7
so the queen on D5 lost its Defender and
I think Hikaru has it close to a
technically winning position
yeah so it really relies on this a pawn
can we actually get like pick up this
Pawn black is going to be trying to win
first of all if these pawns could
disappear from the board the a pawns for
either side big benefit for Magnus he
wants everything on one side of the
board and just have his nice cozy
position all on the dark squares and say
hey let's make a draw could we do a very
quick instant replay on Rook G8 check
just for for newer players to see that
again three moves ago Rook G8 check yeah
go ahead I'm on it just happened so
quick that we didn't even see the
brilliancy symbol pop up because it
absolutely was one Rook to G8 checking
the king and Dania it's almost like what
you mentioned earlier that's the right
thought process to have you mentioned
the Rook on d8 guarding the queen well
he found an amazing way to create that
position again with a hanging Queen on
D5 so well explained Amman and keenly
aware of how every move impacts the
position Rook D7 to C7 that's a small
move but with big ramifications he will
release the Queen and now Hikaru has a
queen against a rook and a bishop but
the game not only is it not over but
Magnus has somehow found a way to guard
the A6 pawn and I actually think he's
managed to build up a fortress two moves
ago I think Hikaru found the wrong way
to Target that Apon it allowed
blackstroke to slide back to the sixth
Rank and I think Hikaru is going to keep
trying maybe get his King over to the
queen side but are his winning chances
realistic at this point
I think they're quite low
um with this basically every piece in
Black's position is defended on a safe
square right absolutely everything
defends something else so there's no
weaknesses and you need something to
Target and I don't know what that
something is going to be and imagine how
frustrating this is and this is an
indelible component of facing Magnus
Carlson you find one brilliant move
after another two moves with the same
theme on Rook B7 and then Rook G8 check
Bang Bang Bang the narrative is spawn
you played a brilliant game boom you
stare down the barrel of a position
where you have absolutely no way to make
progress this is what makes Magnus into
Magnus he can receive as well as he can
give
I mean basically what we're seeing here
is probably going to be a very long game
with no like no end in sight I mean I I
don't see how you're going to do this
there are some cases where you can sack
the queen but in this position there's
so many pawns for black that I I don't
think you can get that adventurous yeah
and Magnus got a little adventurous
there moved his Rook away from the
eighth rank you know that's like the the
baseball player uh who's leading and
drops back to the base as soon as the A6
Pawn is attacked the thing is you don't
have any zuke's Von potential because if
black runs out of Rook moves Magnus
could just shuttle his King there we go
from G6 to G7 but look at Hikaru
chiseling his way through those weak
squares but Magnus is unconcerned King
F5 here could be met with Bishop E7
that was a joke pinned pieces protect
very good
yeah this is like the only idea right
sometimes let's say you're playing queen
against Rook imagine the bishop wasn't
there there are ideas like sacking the
queen for The Rook but when you have
that extra piece it's simply not an
option and he decides to call it quits
before these guys you know bang their
head against the wall too many times
without him without getting anywhere
okay we have a Berlin here a rookie one
Berlin do you think Magnus Carlson still
doesn't believe in fortresses after that
game
yeah he's probably ever since he said
that I'm sure there's been again
everyone is like Magnus who's the
Fortress
I thought he said wait what did he
resign if he doesn't believe in
fortresses exactly that Magnus I thought
you didn't believe gotcha yeah exactly
it changed her I'm sure he's tired of it
but yeah he benefited from one there
they do exist
um and he's he's obviously saying thank
you to uh the fortresses for that one
you know that's in the same category as
the the Anish giri draw memes like he
had one tournament in his entire career
where he said all the games and then six
years old we're drawing is Gary I'm so
funny you know he he's like he never
played another tournament with even 50
of draws and and people are still
harping on it now speaking of fortresses
and draws this rookie one variation has
an interesting reputation I'm on it is
played by some players as a way to
liquidate and make a draw but it can
also be played for a win and Magnus is
obviously in the latter category
he really is and Magnus uh has always
been able to put little bits of pressure
on this specific variation in the Berlin
and yeah it looks so symmetrical but I I
would highlight the one key difference
between the two positions the Knight on
C6 black doesn't really have that C6
Pawn structure which is so solid the B7
Pawn on ideas like Queen B3 is a little
bit uh weaker the bishop on C8 needs to
stay there and the D5 Pawn for the exact
same reason so structurally Magnus has
what is basically the best pawn
structure against the Knight on C6 great
Insight Amman and of course you could
say well I could drop that Knight away
from C6 and play the move C6 but then
the E5 score is weakened and that's why
we see Hikaru taking fairly drastic
measures to keep that square protected
and trying to restrict the Knight on F3
I think he is likely to play a move even
like Knight C6 back to B8 in order uh to
secure the pawn on D5 especially since
that pawn is now x-rayed by the bishop
that magnus's fiancherod he's executed
among on the same maneuver two games in
a row in the last game we saw Bishop f8
G6 and Bishop G7 here we see Bishop D3
to F1 to G2 and we do see Hikaru
reinforcing his Pawn just in time
yeah and the players obviously we're
operating at uh simply speaking the
highest level of Chess so Magnus knows
that precise moment that you know you
don't want to play C4 when the knights
on uh C6 but as soon as the Knight moves
away and it's about to be strengthened
he hits with C4 he's happy to take this
isolated Pawn position because look he's
playing this position for a win he's not
trying to just draw you know make it
symmetrical Magnus hasn't balanced
things and honestly chances for both
sides here yeah he has unbalanced things
and I love seeing this because the
rookie one Berlin can lead to some long
drawn out boring structural games now we
actually have a fairly dynamic position
with a lot going on in the center I'll
point out that Knight takes F6 check is
a good try because Queen takes F6 drops
The Rook on E8 unfortunately that pawn
is also protected by the Knight on D5 so
a dream scenario for white is to take
that Knight off the board that's why I
would consider a move like Knight E4
back to C3 as passive as it seems the
issue to Oman is that the Bishop from C8
could come up to E6 and black could
continue reinforcing his control over
the D5 Square
yeah very important to understand that
like the D5 square is what this entire
game is all about
um Bishop E6 I mean uh he went for your
your move there is it time for Bishop E6
It Feels So logical I think Bishop B6
Magnus is actually kind of bailing out
he's probably going to take on D5 then
take on E8 and take on D5 again and we
spoke a little bit too soon about the
pawn structure getting unbalanced it's
gonna get rebalanced and I think the
game is going to head in a very balanced
Direction subsequently
yeah I think you know if it's our
prerogative to uh Razz on the chat for
you know the the on each draw stuff I
think it's fair for them to be like oh
yeah commentators that's a super
exciting position yeah take that super
exciting position how about what a pawn
appears on D5 yeah Bishop takes D5 and
here's that very nice
you know what this reminds me of those
those reversed time travel movie scenes
where the the objects that were crashed
on the floor are put back together and
moved back to the table order is
restored we had a Berlin and we end with
a Berlin now it should be pointed out
that this position can be agreed to a
draw in this position
but I forgot what I was about to say
goodbye and next game three tries now
yeah it's like these guys have the best
win rates in chess that's what happens
when the highest win rates go against
one another by the way we have such an
even match but remember there's that
early lead that uh Magnus took from that
Victory so he's basically that's the
only difference between the two players
right now I mean what do you make of the
match in the early stages Daniel yeah I
mean it's fascinating that every single
game uh has started out as a rue Lopez
that in and of itself is an interesting
little factoid I don't know if we've
ever had an SEC game where the first
five games were the same opening from
both sides but to answer your question
I'm on it is a balanced match I think we
are going to see more excitement in
these games as the match heads down the
stretch especially if one player
develops a two or three point lead
because his opponent will then have no
choice but to take a little bit more
risk but I still think we're less than
halfway through the five minute portion
the players are still in the kind of
settling in Phase they don't want to
take too many big risks I think that
that's totally understandable if you put
yourself in their shoes
absolutely and uh you mentioned no big
risks playing the same opening is
definitely in that wheelhouse they're
not looking to get too adventurous
playing a structure and they're just
trying to find those minute differences
you know small inklings of an advantage
that they might be able to claim uh for
example Bishop B3 was Tried by Hikaru we
saw Knight H2 Queen F3 now we're seeing
A4 so just different ideas you might be
like why why on Earth are they switching
up like 10 15 different ideas in the
same opening it's because he's just
probing to see how his adversary is
going to respond and whether or not
maybe he can use this opening over and
over again and given that Magnus and
good column on Knight H2 once again on
the board preparing Queen F3 uh and
Knight G4 Knight F5 you know that I
couldn't I I know a mistake uh I know a
mistake when I see one yeah and on that
note I would take a quick detour as we
see Magnus immediately striking in the
center with D5 very logical move Hikaru
has moved a piece away from the center
and the textbooks command it Magnus
plays it D5 on the board and we will see
a different Pawn structure in previous
games Hikaru allowed magnus's Pawn to
reach uh D4 but I would hesitate to call
Knight H2 a mistake you know any of
these move assignments before move 20 or
25 we should take them with a grain of
salt because a move that changes the
eval from equal to minus 0.3 let's chill
out a little bit
yeah absolutely like an insanely harsh
evaluation there I think yeah someone at
chess.com yeah not not a perfect move by
Hikaru
okay what do we make of this Pawn
structure transformation I'm on first
thoughts to me are pretty positive for
black he's got the space Advantage he's
got that like reverse morosi bind
structure that holds the D3 Pawn on a
weak Square on the other hand Hikaru
does have some pretty good prospects for
his Knights speaking of which
yeah there we go we talk about greener
pastures Knight on E3 looking to return
to its former glory I do think that
Magnus should be happier with the
developments uh in the position so far
it just feels like uh tikaru had a
little more going on when he kept it
closed and played for his Queen F3 idea
but here the D3 Pawn is such an obvious
Target and B4 played your idea once
again Dania he's trying to get C4 he's
trying to get Pawn takes B4 but Hikaru
is never gonna play those moves and the
drawback of B4 is that it weakens the C4
Square something tells me Magnus will
not miss the fork on B7 whoa
beautiful man I'm gonna ask you to do
that again in a bit yeah be on the
lookout anytime we get close to that
square I don't know why Magnus misses a
fork on B6 you're gonna have to do that
again
okay that's fair I can I can uh I could
do that for you uh Knight C4 threatening
Knight V6 and I mean Bishop takes C4 you
might look at it and be like okay double
pawns why would we why would we not play
that move right uh four pawns against
three and well I was about to explain
why we wouldn't uh but now I'm perplexed
it's the second time the Magnus has done
that remember I did that in game one
where or game two or there was that
capture on B3 and Magnus in the early
going of the match I don't know how to
formulate this correctly but he's
playing very concretely when there is a
possibility of of seriously changing the
pawn structure or transforming the game
I think he usually goes for it he keeps
trying to face Hikaru with new
difficulties in the position at the same
time I don't think that this is a
particularly challenging position for
white to hold even though he carves down
upon look at Black's pawns on the queen
side A6 C5 their week White's Bishops
are nicely harmonized Black's Bishop on
f8 leaves a lot to be desired so I'm
actually not the biggest fan of this
part particular transformation I think
Magnus could have fought for the
advantage by keeping the structure as it
was
totally and it's actually so much that I
think the move C4 by black almost
inviting to potentially lose the C Pawn
in the future maybe to A5 or xc4 you
might want to do this because then you
can go Rook C8 Bishop C5 and try to make
your own trades
your point is well taken and so I would
consider the move Bishop to B3 or Bishop
to D3 well Bishop D3 gives up the D5
score for black snide but Bishop B3 it
freezes the pawn on C5 and you could
stick your Bishop later on on C4 you
could start massaging the A6 Pawn so in
an Ideal World the best setup would be
Bishop B3 and then A5 and Bishop C4
Magnus of course is not going to allow
20 of that
exactly I was just thinking of a of a
line like Bishop C3 or sorry Bishop B3
excuse me Knight E4 looks really logical
because well we can't go there now you
give up that square by covering D5 I'll
take it and it looks like Bishop D5 is a
fork but there's Knight C3 Daniel and it
just like explodes and probably in a way
that Magnus is looking for
and that's a very important line and
that's probably the motivation for
Bishop D3 that's the impetus behind
putting the bishop on a slightly
flimsier square and you've prevented
Knight E4 some doors close other doors
open and Magnus opens the door that
leads him to D5 hitting the C3 Pawn
hitting the bishop on E3 Hikaru might be
banking on the awkward looking move
Bishop to D2 but I don't see any big
tactics off the top of my head I'm on
it's important that Knight takes C3
attempting Discovery fails to Bishop
take C3 and The Rook on D1 protects the
other Bishop
yeah it's it's such an awkward looking
move although it is exactly where we are
trained to put those Bishops right it
covers technically all the the forward
uh Forward Motion squares that I could
use
um and yeah we want to play maybe bishop
C4 the movie A5 by the way it see it
looks like nothing totally innocuous but
it fixes that pawn on a light Square the
one color complex that black just
doesn't have as much control over so A5
controlling Knight B6 fixing the pawn
that's a big time move if it could
happen and instead we see Rook ac1 by
Hikaru indicating that he's not opposed
to an opposite card Bishop end game and
neither is Magnus now I think that the
probability of a draw has increased
tenfold just because okay technically
black is up a pawn but because of
White's Monopoly over all the light
squares I don't honestly see a world in
which Magnus develops serious winning
chances although that's a very dangerous
thing to say when you're watching Magnus
in any end game
that's right because I mean Magnus is
probably thinking to himself okay
opposite Bishops but I have that one
extra pawn and that's why I think has
quickly gone for Bishop B5 closing this
open file and saying look you pretty
much gotta take
oh but Bishop D six that move sends a
very very clear message Iman he's here
to play he's here to play
yeah
uh I think he's he's definitely in the
right to do that because look Rook D5
like you're not going anywhere down the
D file and the King can move over to E7
and then you can try to move your Rook
but the nice thing for Magnus is he
always has the bailout Bishop back to E7
so from his perspective why not go for
it well the eval bar is showing us zeros
and that's such a misleading assessment
because it's so clear to us that white
is on the defensive he's down a
protected passer on F4 and yes it's I
wouldn't call it a dead draw it is a
draw largely because black has such a
hard time getting the Rook away from D.A
that's why I think Magnus might go King
E7 but the moment he does white shuttles
The Rook over to G1 what you do not want
to want to allow under any circumstances
is for a black Rook to land on G3
because then White's blockade is going
to be dismembered
absolutely I was looking at Bishop C4 as
a way to even stop oh sorry there we go
uh stops Rook G8 right and if you go to
the B file at any point of course you'd
need this move first you can always
block it again with Bishop B5 so I
actually don't think the car is going to
have any difficulty making this draw
um and Magnus is probably realizing that
he doesn't really have anything my gosh
if he puts a bishop on D5 and The Rook
on B1 then hikara will control all of
the entries and exits in the position G8
B8 the D file only two pieces and the
King on F3 uh a nice cherry on top just
making sure that Black's F Pawn never
causes any problems and in a nutshell as
Magnus essentially offers the drug this
is why opposite colored Bishop end games
are so hard to win because you can never
surmount a blockade on the color complex
that you don't control
yep and just in time by the way I know
it looked like we were just immediately
going for the draw but just pointing out
that the bishop was hitting the h-pawn
so King G2 to H3 was actually picture
perfect just in time to guard it and now
the draw is truly in hand and we're
gonna have a fourth draw out of five
games with Magnus carrying the one point
lead as the first half of the five
minute portion comes to an end but I
don't think anybody Amman can rightfully
look at this game and say that the
players haven't brought their fighting
Spirit to the table we called for an
evenly matched Affair and that's what
we're getting
yeah truly
um we're getting a very close match in
fact the only thing between these
players right now is the fact that
um Hikaru had that one sort of major
blunder Bishop A6 so he basically was
actually trying to execute a tactic
missed a counter tactic and then in the
game that would have been
hikaranakamura's bounce back result Rook
G8 we remember that brilliancy he won
the queen but Magnus just defended like
crazy found this Fortress and that's the
only reason that this match is not
deadlocked right now Daniel you're
totally right we've had great moments
from both players But ultimately Magnus
Carlson has the edge as the first 45
minutes of the match wind down folks we
will go on our first break of the day
and we will be back with the second half
of the five minute portion of the SEC
Final in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
thank you
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
by focusing on classical chess but later
he fell in love with playing Blitz and
bullet online
chess has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
battle hard in Valkyrie might give you a
game once she's done arm wrestling a
Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her though those fear her you'll
need to bring your A-game if you want to
be this witch yes that probably is a
rabbit up his sleeve or a huge Fireball
with your name on it we hear Wizards are
pretty good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
through the five-minute portion of the
long-awaited speed Chess Championship
final presented by coinbase in which
Magnus Carlson holds a three to two lead
over Hikaru Nakamura it's been a super
interesting high level Match full of
real Lopez games literally and the SEC
is fun not just because we get to watch
Magnus vs C Caro but because of the
story to history and this story to
history at its centerpiece has featured
exactly two people one is Magnus Carlson
having a hard time remembering the other
end if only we had some photos of him
I'm on
it's a good thing we have precisely five
uh because he's won so many times and
it's actually incredible to think about
uh Daniel that there's only truly been
two champions of the SEC and we have
them here facing off
and it's crazy not just because it
demonstrates their superiority over the
rest of the field but also their
stability the fact that year in and year
out they're somehow able to bring their
a game to this tournament in particular
as well as all of the other ones and I
think both have brought the their a game
to this match as well hard to make any
hard and fast conclusions we've largely
had a balanced match as you said before
the break come on with the exception of
that one uncharacteristic Mistake by
Hikaru uh in the third game in the
second game
that's right and I actually feel that
okay that was maybe a more significant
blunder because it kind of lost
immediately but in some ways I feel like
both players have committed you know
that one kind of tactical shot
um they missed something so hikar did
hit Magnus back with that Rook G8 move
but he just didn't get full credit for
the victory so I do feel like in terms
of the overall match uh both players are
are thinking to themselves okay you know
I see some vulnerability you know
they're not like seeing absolutely
everything they are human so I don't
think uh hikar was panicking at a 3-2
score Magnus will have white in the next
game which will begin momentarily and
I'm curious to see if we will have any
opening variability and as I asked that
we see opening variability on the very
first move Magnus as the Russian
expression goes changing the record
player you know just changing the track
changing the tune and we now have a
completely fresh opening the Queen's
Indian defense is hikaru's response to
this new Magnus Carlson the first time
in his life that he's ever played one
before man
yeah yeah D4 what a move I actually
think that the Queen's Indian is a
rather interesting response by Nakamura
I'm more shocked by that because uh
let's be honest Dania at the highest
levels this doesn't have as strong of a
reputation as some of the other more
solid opening choices that block has
against D4 nope and they're taking a
trip right down to the 1970s and 80s
this particular variation
and I'm referring to 5a3s called the
Petrosian variation you will never guess
who it's named after I'll leave chat to
do the guessing but this featured very
prominently in the Kasparov korchnoy
candidate candidates match of I think
1983 or something and then it kind of
fell off the map I think the current
evaluation is actually close to equality
but I've always felt that White's
control over the center and the ability
in the long run for white to develop an
attack on the king side you could think
about a move like E5 later on and maybe
even a Greek gift sacrifice that makes
Black's position a little bit harder to
handle
yeah and there's an interesting Dynamic
that often develops in this opening
which is like when the Knight goes and
commits itself to the D7 Square the move
E5 becomes much more likely it stops
Knight F6 Knight C5 Knight E5 that D4
Pawn holds it back and the Knight on f8
is it doesn't do that much what you'd
love to do after E5 is have a knight on
D5 but the Knight on D7 has a bit of a
hard time getting there whereas Knight
C6 come on didn't you get the memo that
the Knight can now move in an L shape
plus two Knight B8 to D5 you don't
realize that's illegal now is it what
are you doing commentating the finals of
the SC the man doesn't even know the
rules of chess
unprepared obviously that or shall I say
a man doesn't even know the rules of
chess
that was not even close to your king
take C6 joke which was the best moment
of the broadcast so far we see Rook D1
by Magnus Carlson accumulating pieces in
the center first priority for whiteamon
is to make sure that white center is
defended because if the D4 Pawn
collapses the entire position collapses
yeah the the other thing about these
positions is uh sometimes you can
actually thrust with the move D5 even if
it looks like it loses a pawn you
mentioned E5 to open up the bishop I
mean D5 kind of accomplishes the same
thing it also opens up the queen so
there are some tactical possibilities in
the air but white is being a little
cagey as well not committing that Bishop
to B2 nor uh E3 just yet and again black
is waiting with that Knight the ultimate
decision Knight D7 or Knight C6
yeah big question Knight D7 I think is
the more standard way of developing
Knight D7 and then maybe Knight to F6
and guess what uh the far-fetched future
in which black has accessed the D5 score
actually becomes reality but the benefit
of putting the Knight on C6 is that you
apply more direct pressure on uh the def
on the D4 Pawn there is one tactic to
point out though on really really
quickly if you could play this on the
board let's say white plays Bishop B2
and black plays Knight C6 one thing you
need to be careful about is the move D5
and it might not be that good here but
after Ed oh look at this Rook takes D5 I
was gonna say fails to Bishop H7 check
and Rook takes D5 but the line goes on
look at this Knight to D4 apparently
wins Back The Rook Knight D4 Queen E4
check and then black has the crucial
move F5 and you're tied up hand and foot
you can't take the F5 pawn and you're
gonna lose back the exchange with
interest so basic calculation really
having calculated that line Magnus plays
guess what move Bishop B2
yep yep you saw that one all the way
through evidently uh Bishop B2 and I
wonder yeah this is such a key moment
Knight C6 or Knight D7 I honestly think
the instinct is 97 because you see
Knight c65 and you get freaked out and
he's played Knight t75 and ironically D5
actually does work in this version
because the E7 Bishop is going to hang
if black takes twice on D5 there is this
weird move C4 C5 C4 by black but white
beats him to the punch
yeah and I think this is I mean it's not
uh the end of the world but it's kind of
a small achievement for for Magnus to
play C4 and have this bishop looking at
the D5 Pawn like that sometimes B5
breaks up the team of Pawns but I mean
if not B5 white can play A4 and I think
just has a not overwhelming but a
comfortable Edge
definitely that pawn on D5 very
impressive looking that pawn is not
gonna win you the game you need to other
you need to develop other assets because
right now black does have the defensive
Firepower to keep that pawn under lock
and key speaking of other assets Magnus
kind of starting his 401k on the queen
side he's gonna go A5 and potentially A6
and he's gonna add some Tabasco sauce uh
to that area of the board
and the Knight on D7 it does do uh you
know a little bit of work here defending
B6 so A5 is not the end of the world but
it would actually love to be on the D6
square and you know again I didn't get
the memo maybe they do move like that
you and your it would be nice if the
Knight were you know in Hawaii sipping a
pina colada right now uh so Knight F6 98
Knight D6 is a very standard maneuver in
these types of positions that's part of
the reason Magnus played A4 it's not
necessarily because A5 creates such a
big effect it's that if the Knight moves
away from D7 then A5 seriously targets
uh the B6 spawn so Hikaru might want to
bring his Queen back to C7 or D6 uh he
goes Rook a beat same type of idea right
just making sure that A5 isn't all that
dangerous and now A5 might run into B
takes A5 with problems down the B file
so maybe Queen C3 sidestepping things I
think that Magnus can play this position
fairly slowly because if the knights
trade off I think he's a bit better
after A5 if the position remains you
know how it is right now I I do think he
has the edge so Magnus is looking to
build this into a bigger Advantage
Magnus looking to trade Queens man never
said that one before
you know he's pretty good at end games I
heard is he man you and your assumptions
I don't know that's been untested and
Hikaru he does play Knight F6 ultimately
I would also draw attention to that
Bishop on Asics which is doing two
things it's x-raying it's counterpart on
D3 so if that D3 Bishop is left without
supervision Knight takes D5 is a nasty
tactic the second thing earlier is that
White's move A5 could have been could
have been met with B5 that's no longer
the case but now with the Rooks off the
board A5 just doesn't carry any backup
so you're not really targeting the B6
Pawn
and Magnus is obviously strong enough
that he's not going to let something
like this happen but I should point out
that if Hikaru can trade the bishop for
the Knight we could easily enter an end
game where despite the protected pass
Pawn despite the A5 we've been talking
about that Magnus could actually be
worse and that's the type of end game
that you know you can win with the
Knight against the bishop because you're
all over the dark squares totally and we
see A5 by Carlson he tries to keep up
the heat on the queen side black could
take on A5 and white can't really
recapture because you dropped the E5 at
night of course that's not magnus's idea
he is trying to separate Black's Pawn
chain and ultimately Target that C5 Pawn
which will be left without a Defender uh
should black take on A5
yeah it's interesting you know it's
given a question mark here by our very
harsh uh engine analysis but like my
English speech it's based on Pawn takes
and what bravery from Nakamura to just
call it out and say okay you want to
play A5 and you can't take it back be my
guest but I actually like A5 from a
practical standpoint Magnus also keeping
an eye on hikaru's clock and he
continues to pose difficult decisions as
Hikaru Falls now to below a minute for
instance Rook takes you when Queen takes
E1 there's a hidden threat Knight E7
check suddenly Forks the king and the
bishop on C8 so you might lose back the
A5 one Hikaru has so many problems to
solve here and 37 seconds now on his
clock and taking down that nagging time
advantage that Magnus has had throughout
the five minute portion could come in
handy here as well
absolutely I was thinking maybe bishop
to D7 but he made maybe a more logical
move A4 get the pawn Off The Square
where it's being attacked I don't think
he's planning to hold on to that pawn
but he would love to finally achieve
that long-term goal of a knight on D6
it's just so difficult to do over 75 000
people with over 50 000 watching on
YouTube and watching us Hikaru tries to
hold this difficult end game with only
25 seconds on his clock and will they
watch as Magnus recaptures on C6 with
the pawn that seems to be the spicier
move it's also potentially the riskier
move but I would play DC in a bullet
game I think it's a harder move to face
practically let's see what Magnus
decides here
yeah because Bishop takes then we
actually do get what I was mentioning
earlier where even though you have that
protected pass button I actually think
that she carves practical chances are
through the route black can actually now
win this game you called it a while ago
you have a knight versus Bishop
situation it's an imbalance and it's
also easy for white to accidentally
abandon his King if the queen moves away
from E3 look at how quickly Black's
Queen and Knight can combine Queen F4
well not anymore but Queen F4 Knight E4
and you have to keep an eye on your king
I think that's what Hikaru is trying to
do G5 creating a Luft Square for his
King on G7 and also creating the
potential preconditions for counter play
against White's King
that's right yeah G5 is I mean he's just
probing at this point a queen trade we
should point out absolutely favors
Hikaru so we will definitely see Magnus
keeping the queen on the board that's
the the thing that's tying black down to
the defense of the C5 pawn queen A3
right you'd have to watch both pawns
maybe with Queen E7 I'm having a hard
time understanding how Magnus makes any
progress here and again like the
previous game right like the opposite
color Bishop end game black is a
monopoly over the dark squares that
Queen on D6 is entirely unassailable
it's impervious to attack and if that
Queen remains on D6 I want to see how
Magnus tries to unshuffle hikaru's
blockade here and we're getting our
answer Queen A3 Queen C3 but how are you
going to make that final bit of progress
yeah it looks very difficult to do and I
will say as magnus's time gets lower his
position will become more and more
frantic to play because there's not a
clear answer here it's really easy to
shuffle a knight on the dark squares
we need four and Hikaru adding a little
bit of heat to the center and suddenly
the time situation has evened up and
Bishop takes C6 I think Magnus might be
regretting that choice just about now
Queen be one check and queen back to E4
would be one way to repeat the position
Thrice Magnus might just start going
Bishop C6 Bishop B5 honestly yeah I
think this is the moment where oh if D6
Magnus oh if he goes just a little bit
too far Hikaru is gonna switch and play
for a win but he hasn't done that yet
there was a brief instance where Magnus
could have pushed his Pawn there to D6
and D7 and that was missed that was
missed because both players with three
seconds on their clock who's playing for
a win it might be Hikaru
I wonder Queen A6 to maybe in 10 D6 I
think he's what he's trying to go for oh
that night was pin D6 transformation
here but it doesn't really change the
dynamic of the position Magnus Queen
takes a 70 Cars one or the pawn that's a
mistake that is a big mistake now
they're big deal winning chances but
still drawing chances for Nakamura who
keeps his piece tandem active but look
at that seatbon on it goes to C6 and
Hikaru now in big trouble he's got to
keep the C7 Square under lock and key
yep it's so difficult to do now Bishop
D5 you start to panic about the Knight
and Hikaru loses he loses the pawn end
game with Pawn promotes and Magnus wins
no that was that was just an outplay but
based on that blunder of the A7 Pawn so
he transformed the position with D6 took
on C5 and that was the transformation
that white needed to finally play for a
win D6 was such a heads up move and it's
so misleading looking at that with the
engine because D6 is unremarkable it
doesn't change the evaluation obviously
that resulting position is drawn but
Hikaru was unable to deal with a new set
of problems after having defended that
other position for 30 moves this is what
makes Magnus into Magnus he's so good at
confronting you with a whole new set of
problems just when you think that he's
about to acquiesce to a draw that's not
what does and he has a two-point lead
them on
and you know it's that exact moment I
feel like and I can speak from
experience here you sort of let your
guard down you're like okay I've done
enough for a draw he's not making
progress and you start to think to
yourself okay uh this is easy and it's
in that exact moment where he uses that
you know false confidence against you
and plays for a win and you're not and
remember when he started playing Bishop
C6 to B5 to A4 I Think Magna saw that D6
idea and he had he had marked it and I
think he was lulling Hikaru into this
false sense that he was okay with a
repetition but all along I think Magnus
was looking for an opportunity to
unbalance the game and to keep it going
incredible end game display but we're on
to the next game and we're back to where
we started another Rue Lopez
exactly Nakamura basically you know he
wants to go back to something that's
worked there's also uh you know the old
uh Russian adage you know go and go
ahead and make a draw after a tough loss
he doesn't want to just bleed out here
and have the momentum really start to
build for Magnus so he's going to
something that he's familiar with and
honestly Hikaru has gotten some great
positions with white but this one
looking a lot more symmetrical indeed
and one to tie up our discussion of the
last game another encouraging thing for
Magnus fans is how he was able to acquit
himself in high time pressure situations
this has been hikaru's calling card even
in previous SCC matches when things get
down to five four seconds Hikaru is
nearly unassailable but Magnus well he
was able to assail him in that game and
now we're having some really interesting
tension on the queen side we had a pawn
Cube briefly Hikaru trades on B5 and
drives his Queen to B3 will we see a
rook lift by black will we see Rook F6
setting up some sort of exchange sack on
F3 is this a French
it actually is not as crazy as you might
think in fact Rook F6
uncomfortable so you might want to play
Knight D2 but you don't have that time
enjoy Magnus Rook F6 and Knight H2 is
typical but G4 is a bit of a dead end
even if the Knight gets to G4 and The
Rook slides back to E6 now the bishop on
E3 is occupying you know your apartment
with Central Park views and that Knight
might have to drop back to H2 Magnus
taking the opportunity
instead to Target the A3 Pawn can Hikaru
take twice on C5 I think Magnus is
intending Knight F4 at the end of that
line
yeah I almost want to just pull up an
analysis board and show how Let's Do It
um you know things can go wrong if you
think that uh Magnus Carlson has just
hung upon well you might be right that
it's hanging but I look at Knight F4
Rook G6 Queen H3 Dania and yeah for the
price of a pawn uh I I'm not interested
anymore totally and apparently Knight F4
before Bishop takes C5 is even more
accurate the reason why is that E5 Pawn
isn't hanging here and it threatens
Knight E2 with a fork but your point as
well taking them on I would calculate
Bishop takes C5 and Knight F4 and just
on the basis of that position
particularly when Magnus Carlson is sort
of sitting in front of you I mean he's
actually sitting in Oslo but you get
what I'm saying I would rule that line
out not fun that's a good point yep
great point and instead oh well he's
actually still pondering I don't think
he's thinking about taking them
is he pondering
yes the unintentional planamon you are
you are breaking new ground truly
does that mean I'm good at it or bad at
it
you're good at it it's it's the highest
form of humor I think the honest it
means the puns are you have internalized
them that's yeah they flow naturally
exactly
G3 speaking of Pawns
that's double attack you've ever seen
Brooks the old the old Rook F6 King G2
defends both the knight in the pawn at
the same time so that's what he was
pondering
nice one anyway
well I'm just living off the I'm writing
the coattails you know I'm just like one
of those fan boys
you know if you can't beat him join him
the high school English plagiarist you
know yeah I totally invented that phrase
G3 King G2 and you know what G3 is
exactly how you want to react on a you
know a more global scale to a night on
G6 the move G3 is exactly the way you
want to handle it in fact we've seen
Magnus play the move G6 they handle
White's Knight on G3 in almost every Rue
Lopez game so now things are reversed G3
is a move that we might take for granted
when we see it played oh you know of
course he's stopping Knight F4 but how
many people would would have the the
cojones to actually play G3 against
Magnus Carlson I think it's a great
positional move it's based on accurate
calculation because if a rook F6 works
it wins the game you have to see King G2
and I actually am starting uh to become
more partial to hikaru's position here
because he clamps down on the D5 Square
the bishop on f8 struggles to find a
clear role to play and that's why Magnus
sensing the moment explodes the center
with D5 excellent excellent move and
good awareness of the game not going in
your direction so it's time to change
the tenor of the game
yeah and he's done exactly that with D5
because Rook D6 no matter how it gets
taken you might trade the Queens first
but Rook D6 in order to take on uh D5
or to take on D3 in the event of uh you
know down the line that pawn just might
be hanging D4 is also loose so in fact
taking this Pawn might be worse for you
in the in the long run well I'm afraid
to ask what happens after e takes D5
because I get that if you play Queen
takes D5 black and trade queens and play
Rook D6 I guess he takes D5 Rook D6 oh
look at this line Edie Rook D6 Rook C5
we can put it on the board and suddenly
Rook back to F6 oh no Queen takes H3
because by sliding a rook away from E6
you've also opened up an attack on the
H3 Pawn great whole board awareness by
Carlson so after Rook D60 car would have
to leave the d-pawn on pre give some
credit to your move though uh you know
yeah double attack here
and okay if you takes if white has
connected passers
that's a good point even even better
Queen takes H3 but point is not
interesting at all for Noob to
transition into that I would play Queen
takes D5 if I'm facing Magnus just lay
liquidate get the Queens off the board
and he does just that D5 was such an
All-Star move by Magnus oh speaking of
which Rook C5
yeah hey there's a there's a great
double attack I don't know if you saw it
uh Daniel Rook F6
ah where did you find that Iman in some
like remote flea market you know just
another uh Hamilton original you know
Hamilton's an original Rook F6 though we
should now point out because this point
has become more Central in the end game
after Rook F6 for instance Knight D2
taking on C5
to me this is out of the question even
if the eval bar doesn't rise too much
just look at white spawns look at the
Knight on D2 which is going to jump with
great effect to E4 this just doesn't
seem appetizing to me most importantly
this isn't necessary because Carlson
could play the calm of Rook B8 guard the
D5 the B5 pawn and then surround the D5
Pawn slowly
and I mean look at that Rook B8 played
you called it Daniel this move is so
patient just understanding that you have
the time in the position to collect this
Pawn later
H4 though Hikaru trying to make Magnus
regret it and trying to take his
attention away from the E5 Pawn but H5
he meets him at the top and the G5
Square kid can it be used as a Transit
point for White's night you know what
the problem is I'm on if you play Knight
G5 and Black's Rook drops back along the
D file not Rook F6 but Rook T8 then
black will be threatening Bishop takes
C5 and then Rook takes D5 so the
exchange attack will lose its luster
yeah you cannot go for that I think he
needs to do that right about now and he
goes to d8 and not D7 because I think
Rook C8 he wanted to avoid and again the
time situation again it's that nagging
irksome 45 second time advantage that
Magnus has put to such good use when the
game becomes critical when it becomes
tactical love what Hikaru did there Rook
C7 that's the best Square for the rook
and don't sleep on Knight G5 because now
that it hits the F7 Pawn this move is a
lot more tempting to me
and Bishop takes B4 I like this move
Knight G5 maybe bishop back to E7
hitting the Knight ready to take on D5
Bishop A7 these guys are playing on
every side of the board incredible Rook
be said why Bishop A7 to open up the B7
Square for The Rook why open up B7 for
one Rook to open up C7 for the other and
we're gonna get likely Piggies on the
seventh Knight H tripled tripled on the
seventh here are we gonna get a knight
h8 sighting on his own volition usually
that move is only played if the Knight
is kicked Away by a pawn but here that
move might be played in order to guard
F7
come on come on Magnus please go Knight
h8 just for the for the culture for the
for the memes you know
and he does
and Knight G5 Hikaru is not stopping
there
yeah Knight G5 is the natural follow-up
and I think we might get to a situation
where uh the bishop drops back to f8
guards G7 you kind of admit that you
can't keep guarding F7 but no D4 he
wants to clarify the center and maybe
pick up that B Pawn what's mesmerizing
about this game is how both players are
using the board as their cannabis
they're like two artists painting on the
left side and in the middle and Hikaru
is striking everywhere but Magnus look
at the defensive construction that he
has adopted on the king side it's it
would survive a nuclear apocalypse
and truly let's not forget the bishop is
also defending the b-pawn so if pieces
start to trade it's actually going to be
Madness of all people who walks away
saying I actually might play for a win
I'm not a big soccer fan but when people
describe watching Lionel Messi I've
heard it describe it you think that you
have more than 11 men on your field when
you watch Magnus and Hikaru handling
their pieces you almost feel like they
have more pieces on the board to start
with they've like found a cheat code
watch out though if you're Carlson
Bishop back to f8 I think a repetition
of moves is likely Hikaru he has enough
compensation for the pawn in the form of
his incredible piece of activity he goes
for it though Hikaru playing for a win
here but I don't really see a future in
this position and he does yeah yeah
exactly he doesn't that's all that
matters exactly
I think long term the most that he could
hope for with everything so defended on
the king side is yeah he can win the
b-pawn but it will trade a pair of minor
pieces and you know the Knight on h8 as
silly as it looks is actually an amazing
come on what night on H and now it's
Magnus who goes for he says you let my
knight back in the game I'm going to
make you pay for it but now there's a
Frank pressure and I think we're gonna
get liquidation and finally a draw now
guaranteed
yeah a draw guaranteed but you know the
most moral of Victories for Magnus
having the night against the bishop it's
like haha and that was a real test for
Magnus because he was under pressure
from the early middle game Hikaru did
some great stuff on the queen side and
every time that Magnus had to find an
important move to stay afloat he did he
found D5 he found Knight h8 he arranged
his pieces perfectly and Magnus is just
indicating that he is in phenomenal form
yet again
he is um I mean ikaranakamura is step
for step with him but just to be able to
do that on defense is very very
impressive Magnus letting his clock run
down there too like one second but now
he builds it back up and it is he like
playing for a win here you have to be a
little bit careful
King H1
Knights are are tricky pieces and with
the King cut off here this is not this
is not nothing I've played Magnus in
enough bullet games to know that he can
win with no pieces on his clock and
Hikaru he seems annoyed I don't know
what he's annoyed about this is still a
draw me I'm wondering as well whether
it's like he's annoyed with himself or
having to be the one defending or what
huh whoa whoa whoa
what is going on
we're seeing some kind of pre-moves and
maybe that was the reaction he pre-moved
Bishop F2 or something
but wait Magnus is black here he gave up
a bishop
wait what on Earth Hikaru could have
captured that immediately and won the
game and now he must have pre-moved it
which is why he's like just thinking to
himself I can't believe I just played so
quickly we're gonna have to do an
instant replay after this game finishes
nothing to say after that I thought that
it was a glitch I'm on I thought that
the board lagged or something but no it
didn't Magnus had made a false pre-move
and Hikaru had responded with a pre-move
instead of capturing that free night
foreign
that was so strange but here we are in
this position he's trying to play Bishop
f8 uh let's be clear even after uh that
well let's call it a blunder is what it
was initially it would have been
immediately lost for Magnus but when he
did win the piece it was at the cost of
both of his pawns so yeah I think this
is actually going to be a draw anyway
and there's just no way to make progress
that's the whole point if both pawns
disappeared this game would last for
another couple hours but as it stands
that King on G6 is on a perfect
defensive position Magnus did a great
job of adjusting you know he blundered
that piece but he didn't Panic he found
the only narrow path to a draw and again
I will point out for the hundred
thousand of you in the chat who are
sitting there saying I didn't see what
happened like what on Earth just
happened why the isikar up a minor piece
we will quickly revisit that moment and
try to explain retroactively what
happened
yeah right now it's uh it's all about
this rook and Bishop Magnus is playing
so sloppy here Rook b70s blunder the
g-pun yeah he got his idea
and he had rookie eight there I think
but he's just doing everything possible
to give you car winning chances
yeah that's true Rook A8 is a is a good
spot but hang on that pawn will most I
think you could probably find a way in
50 moves to to win that pawn what do you
think Daniel I think you could surround
it eventually I there are a bunch of
fortresses with Rook Pond and King
against Rook bishop and King and this
might be one of them this might be a
situation where as long as you keep the
Rook on A6 Hikaru actually has no way to
surround the F6 but I'm not sure
yeah it almost feels like one of those
uh you know potential worst case
scenarios for Hikaru where he's played
you know so well and what is he gonna
come out of this with just another draw
like he's itching to get that one full
point converted because he's had so many
opportunities just not quite enough in
terms of an evaluation
man but this would be so huge if
something crazy happens in Magnus
blunders the pawn and loses the
subsequent end game that would be so
that would be recite I would decisively
change the momentum and the tenor of
this match so Magnus has to keep his his
annoyance in shakikaru just continues to
you know make those motions I I mean I
would be happy that I even have the
extra Bishop to begin with
I mean what what's going on here yeah
the players are reacting to something so
it's like I can't wait to see what it is
what it is yeah
I'm wondering if there's yet another
blender because they have too much time
to be flagging yeah I mean if white
blenders the rookie actually loses
because black has the F Pawn
maybe the bishop got blundered and then
now it's Magnus pushing with one Pawn oh
whoa what
what just happened we need so many
instant replays right now well clearly
I'm teleported into the future we were
lagging on like 20 moves and we were
those 20 moves were made and Magnus lost
the game I have to start we have to look
over what happened I need to at least go
back to where that pawn Was Won how was
it lost
I don't know how that even occurred
it's just a dead Fortress Hikaru went
around the side he went around the side
and somehow amazing
he somehow got the pawn and then he won
Incredible that's really incredible
insane
and then I'm gonna fast forward because
they played so many moves they were just
coming instantly I'll just show the
finish of this bishop and night uh sorry
bishop and broke
they don't have that many pieces you
didn't get the memo him on it was
blundered
and and then wow oh my gosh stopping
going to A5 and I mean
I'm not even sure what just happened
there are we on to the next game I'm
looking for the next game here
I don't think we are just yet um I think
maybe the players are adjusting to this
new reality
I have so many questions and not enough
answers first of all Magnus said no
business pre-moving with four seconds on
the clock and that night he got too
comfortable I think being in the
driver's seat of that end game and then
suddenly he gives up the night then he
gives up one Pawn then another one and
then the thing we haven't talked about
he actually lost broken Bishop versus
Rook which for newer players is a
theoretical draw which means with best
play you are supposed to be able to make
a draw but there's no one better than
Hikaru at squeezing wins quite like this
one
yeah and for more experienced players
it's a theoretical draw as well
um just yeah you know and Magnus would
make it in a classical game
he he would the thing about what we just
witnessed is you know we could say
whatever we want about oh you know your
car pre-moved he missed that free piece
let's focus on what actually did happen
he he actually played a game against
Magnus and he won rook and Bishop
against rook in two pawns it feels like
oh he's got that extra piece yeah he
always had winning chances no that is so
dead drawn it's actually incredible that
he was able to win that and not in my
wildest dreams would I think magnets of
all people could lose that position you
needed a momentum boost as Hikaru
Nakamura you just got it I would not to
be the Debbie Downer of the party as as
we see the next game underway and I just
think we see it in magnus's body
language he might still be incredulous
you might just think I I I'm gonna wake
up from this any moment now but the
reality is he's still up a point in the
match we're still in our first segment
so the objective effect of this game on
the course of the match is probably not
as big as I think some people might make
it out to be especially because I think
Hikaru has misplayed the subsequent game
and I think Magnus is even angrier now
he's got an even bigger chip on his
shoulder
yeah and he's gotten what he wanted
totally if anyone is you know wondering
yes we did miss the opening but hey news
flash it was the same opening as every
other game so uh that's a consolation
prize here as we are now up to speed
and I wanted to add one last thing as we
see Queen D2 by Carlson connecting his
Rooks setting up the Potential Threat of
Bishop takes H6 he's got more space
better pieces hikaru's position riddled
with Pawn weaknesses and Bishop takes H6
right now has to be seriously considered
last thing I'm on when the eval bar was
showing TB
um when they transitioned to rook and
Bishop no it did not self-diagnose
tuberculosis instead it refers to table
base and table base refers to all of the
positions with seven pieces or under
having been studied so chess is actually
a partially solved game and the
evaluation table base was a draw that's
what it means when the eval bar switches
to TB
that's a good explanation and much
needed because it's like hey hang on
where's my evaluation
especially when it switches from TV to
uh Checkmate in two at the very end
oh
okay the elephant in the room literally
the elephant because look he's gonna
play it he had time to think about it
Daniel that's the thing he had four
minutes and guess what he's pissed off
from that last game so of course he's
gonna do it and the other bishop and
when I say elephant in Russian and in
some other languages Bishop is elephant
so that was the pawn look at the
Exquisite play again using both sides of
the board it should be three uh does he
have a thread him on
uh I heard they defend but they actually
don't not here Queen takes G6 after
Bishop B3 is the now elephant in the
room and uh Knight h8 I know he might be
trying to uh steal an idea but uh does
not work as well here Knight F5
threatens Checkmate on G7 and queen f8
you've got the F6 Knight to pick up and
the problem is Hikaru tries to stir up
some complication I think that was the
only move the only feasible move is that
Black's minor pieces are dangling and
without pawns to protect them black
essentially can't multitask black can't
simultaneously keep his King protected
and keep both of his Knights under
control that's why I would play Knight
takes E5 right now and only after the
Knight leaves G6 would I jump with the
other Knight to F5 that's essentially a
double attack right it's a double attack
on the queen on G7 but also on F6 and
when the queen drops back to f8 you can
simply start picking up Black's minor
pieces none of which are protected by a
pawn none of the four are protected by a
pawn
yeah and that's a really high level
calculation there Knight takes and then
an Intermezzo Knight out of five but you
stumble upon these ideas when you
realize Knight F5 as tempting as it is
Queen f8 meets it so well so you want to
move that knight from G6 or force it to
move the move Pawn takes on E5 Daniel is
pretty much achieving the exact same
thing black has to get the Queens off
the board even if it comes at the cost
of a minor Pace you might want to just
go Queen f8 and bite the bullet White's
got this sick response Queen H6 to C1
actually hitting the bishop on C6 I will
confess I didn't find that move on my
own but if Hikaru saves this one with a
minute now on his clock I would be even
more shocked than I was given the
proceedings of the last game and I think
after Knight F5 we might see resignation
very shortly
yeah Knight F5 Queen f8 um talking about
Force moves Queen takes on uh F6 and
maybe he's trying to get something going
with like Knight takes F3 doubling the
pawns Rook E6 Rook G6 swinging over in
that direction so I feel like that might
be what hikar was thinking about he
knows as well as Magnus that there's no
way this works out for him but no you
still have to find something King H1
just get let go of that Bishop get away
from it because King taking the bishop
is radioactive right Knight G4 check is
going to pick up White's Queen and lead
to a complete liquidation it's I love it
when you leave a piece on pre like this
and play King H1 that produces such a
nice aesthetic effect at least for me
totally and and this is a reminder like
Bishop F2 I'll admit I didn't even think
of it because
the moves were so overwhelming for white
that to be honest it maybe wasn't
necessary but you know that's a fault of
mine I didn't even see this counter shot
Hikaru is truly so resourceful but
Magnus just does not need to bite on
this bait Bishop takes F2 here and he
can he can play King takes F2 and When
the Smoke Clears he will beat up a pass
Pawn on Def in fact he'll be up two
pawns but we know how good Hikaru is at
manufacturing chances in Lost end games
it's the you know the quintessential
Unstoppable Force meets immovable object
both of these players are such Wizards
in the end game that I wouldn't flirt uh
with with even an iota of possibility
that Hikaru builds up some sort of
Fortress Magnus calculating it if he
plays King H1 he virtually ends the game
on the spot
yeah but you gotta have the confidence
to do that because in some ways King
takes F2 is kind of a stable Edge you
know you have that couple extra pawns
later whereas this you know there's
Knight takes F3 there's Bishop takes E1
Rook uh E6 to G6 you have to be sure
that you're not actually throwing the
game away by by miscalculating here so a
riskier approach but the correct one and
here's what Magnus had to see Rook G6
would have run into 97 check with a fork
that was critical and Hikaru blocks with
a knife he tries to keep some Intrigue
on the board but I would just go Rook F1
here I would just move the Rook away
everything is hanging and Hikaru is
going to start dropping minor pieces
here what a game what a win by Carlson
to rebound from that shocking loss in
the previous one it's it's really
impressive just from a mental standpoint
to be able to do that right to bounce
back from getting checkmated rook and
Bishop against Rook he even had two
pawns on the board the outplay from
Hikaru in the previous game was insane
you know full credit to Hikaru but to
just basically silence everyone it's
like by the time we had appreciated that
he had already gone and won another game
and speaking of full credit we wanted to
credit the over 100
000 of you watching this amazing SEC
finals match presented by coinbase uh
across the the various platforms you
know when I say that I appreciate people
taking time out of their busy Fridays
these are not just cliche words uh this
is not just boilerplate we truly
appreciate uh the chat and the the
energy that people bring it it lends a
magical quality uh to these events and
these match and it makes them truly
Unforgettable so give yourself a pat on
the back everybody we hope you're
enjoying the match and we've got the
best yet to come we have two more
segments uh the match remains close even
though Magnus up by two he's only up by
two and he's like played the best SCC
segment in history that's no truly
Hikaru in a nutshell
it's like 99 accuracy beats 97 accuracy
or something I know now what's going on
here Iman you're the French expert this
didn't start out as a French but it
certainly looks like one
uh where you see this uh this G5
maybe we should ask him what do you
think through this position
I think the king side is uh maybe a bit
open after G4 and G5 phone I think drops
here and yeah okay
yeah very good yeah
okay Queen's xc5 what's a move okay now
I can't I can't escape the accent yeah
no now it's you're trapped in there a
little bit Yeah you must continue
okay so are we gonna see Knight B5 by
Nakamura to Target the C7 Square
these positions I have to say are so
stressful to play with the black pieces
like you you feel like you've done the
absolute best right when when you read
the blueprint for the the French let's
say because it is more like a French
position right now you think okay get
rid of the center right E5 D4 let me
undermine the center that's what the
french is all about well guess what
you've done it and the position is still
extremely unclear as the eval bar points
out that black still has lots to worry
about
absolutely but white also has white has
more to worry about than may meet the
eye because once Black's Bishop from f8
comes out to C5 I'm on it targets the F2
pawn and the fact that white hasn't
developed his Queen side might bite him
in the behind pretty shortly
yeah I think I think this is all about
first of all the g-pawn is hanging so
yes you can take it it's not that easy
for black to play Rook G8
um because you need to Long Castle Lots
needs to happen so the G4 Pawn is up for
grabs but I like Knight B5 however
Bishop C5 is a very aggressive way to
react and it just could become a total
mess
okay Bishop E3 instead Hikaru
prioritizing his develop development
Magnus could now secure the G4 upon with
H7 H5 that of course is the kind of
boilerplate response uh once you advance
the pawn to G4 or he could similarly
prioritize his development and get his
dark squared Bishop out which path is he
going to choose
H5 feels really natural and I guess now
that Bishop E3 has been played the clear
reaction is Knight B5 there's no Bishop
C5 uh to think of so Knight B5 I imagine
has to be
um nakamura's idea but you know the the
engines I've looked at these positions
enough the engine will always be like
you know what it's not that bad for
white even if you just develop black has
problems to solve the king is never
fully safe castling kingside and
castling mean side is not that easy to
achieve well you got the square we got
the square right we got the piece wrong
he's put the bishop on B5
E5 by Carlson leading to complete
pandemonium in the center but I'm on
this doesn't actually threaten I think
this is very important e takes D4 is not
a threat because if Bishop takes D4
Bishop G5 so Hikaru can take this
opportunity to say you want to open up
the center I'll take it to you A Move
Like C4 and Knight C3 would terrify me
if I were in magnus's shoes and that's
very much a picaro's alley it really is
but he needs he needs to find the
confidence to play those moves I think
he knows that this position calls for
those types of moves if you talk about
the move C4 the move F4 is equally
playable how insane are these moves here
and C4 Hikaru Nakamura strikes I'm gonna
go ahead and give that a Brilliance oh
wait it's already done both of these
players have such a keen sense of the
initiative they know exactly when their
opponent starts to lose the thread and
they pounce like a tiger out of the cage
this is also going to be among the final
game of the five minute portion so a win
by Hikaru would go such a long way
toward re-establishing the momentum that
he seized after that end game victory
I'm just go ahead gonna go ahead and say
it um Magnus surviving this position
will be so astounding to me because I
said it earlier this position is nothing
but stress for black to play you're
getting attacked the whole game C4 is an
incredible move and Hikaru is feeling
the the Zen of the position he knows the
type of moves that need to happen and
that's frightening so I don't know how
Magnus is going to survive here correct
yeah sir I'm just trying to grasp the
Zen the Zen of the position and uh
speaking are we mellowing out Daniel I
remember when Robert Huebner practiced
Zen meditation at the 1970 uh hugovin's
chorus of icons a tournament and this is
getting scarier by the second literally
because Magnus is now down to two
minutes why am I think for newer plays
you look at this position it's chaos on
the board why is this so bad for black I
think it boils down to two things the
first is your permanent lack of King
safety the king is stuck on the e-file
it has nowhere to run because the king
side is wide open look at hikar Knight
C3 and that's the second thing the
superiority of White's piece placement
Black's pieces are stumbling on each
other they're not able to
no one one was not enough there this is
the second look at how many pieces are
hanging
oh my gosh I don't think that was enough
exclamation marks them on I just want to
make it clear that when you hang this
many pieces you deserve some credit
Hikaru is head bobbing we know what that
means he's feeling the position and he
is ready to go into the break with a
victory here I I said it once I'll say
it again I don't think Magnus is going
to survive here it's too tough to play
he's not just head rubbing he's also
chewing and you know what that means if
you have the mental capacity to go for a
snack during the game that means you're
confident that things are going your way
if black takes the bishop what actually
happens you might be asking white takes
the D5 Pawn with a knight takes the B5
Pawn with the other Knight and then both
Knights are staring at the C7 square and
you can put this on the board really
quickly as Magnus starts to come to
terms with I would say the hopelessness
of his position we might see this on the
board he will have to allow Knight C7
check give up the rook in the corner and
try to run his King to the king side I
do think that that is the best practical
chance yeah Magnus just rugby yeah look
how calmly he's defending even in the
face of almost certain death that's
actually an excellent move by Carlson he
says if I'm gonna die I'm gonna die with
an extra minor piece in my stomach and
this game is not over this is not over
and it's it feels insane to even say
that you know at this point white could
consider just like a regular looking
move like Queen D2 Rook D1 those types
of moves will still build up uh insane
pressure on the position so uh I wonder
if there's something more forcing here
Daniel but I might be thinking about
just moving the queen
Queen D2 also you're setting up
potential ideas like Bishop E3 to G5 in
order to cover the d8 square but My
worry is that Magnus is actually only a
couple of moves away from finding better
shelter for his King he might play the
move F6 and then King F7 and that King
on F7 is going to be a whole lot safer
than it was just a couple of moves ago
yep and it will be on a light Square
which is the one piece that white is
missing in fact a nice move maybe
instead of Queen D2 but same idea is
just to check the king first and then do
it so you force the king to go to that
you know undesirable d8 Square
absolutely and now Hikaru down a minute
on the clock I don't think he's finding
anything that he truly likes he forces
the king to d8 but now the king is very
nicely sheltered by the Knight on D7
Bishop to B6 setting up but what exactly
is the threat I think that's the problem
with this move where are you actually
gonna jump with the Knight A6
I think the bishop B6 move is doing my
favorite thing threatening to threaten
yeah
but but it looks scary right I can say
that for sure if you move the Knight you
know you want to run away with the King
right now I think it feels to me like
it's time to move that Bishop so that
you have an escape path great column on
Bishop to B4 on the board The Rook on
you one is also hanging and again white
is down a minor piece even though it
doesn't feel that way do you make a run
for it with King E7 is now the time and
it is and is Magnus starting to take
over the initiative unbelievable no
Bishop C5 check but what about takes
takes Bishop C7 I guess you Retreat the
Knight
Bishop D6
I'm on Carlson is one move away from
establishing his King on G7 the safest
Square on the chessboard black is now
better
I can't believe this and he's kept his
extra piece the entire time
I mean this is incredible uh defensive X
before and he's blundered Rook takes C5
and Hikaru once again is in charge B5 B5
oh Bishop D4 was really bad really bad
by Carlson
Magnus lets it slip a little bit because
look at the pieces look you're up
material but those pieces aren't in the
game they're not playing so if you're
not using them they're not affecting the
the evaluation of the position
there was absolutely no need for Carlson
to give up his dark scored Bishop now
look at those dark squares along the
long diagonal Queen C3 and rookie one
and this feels like a completely
different type of position than just a
couple of moves ago at the same time if
black snake gets to E6 then it's very
much still a game
Queen G5 dangerous looking move but it
covers the things it needs to cover like
the F5 Square the the queen looking at
oh he blundered on passant
wow yeah I was thinking even Queen C5
but this is even better H4 and the
attack rages for black and now the
bishop can't move because you get mated
on G2 you're gonna have oh
and Rook takes G3 blundered his Queen
Magnus blunder this queen he can't cover
with the Knight
oh my God he had Knight G4 but that was
nerves exactly he definitely thought he
had Knight G4 now it's over 98 Rook
takes D1 and comes back tonight and
Hikaru wins
unbelievable the I mean I think we were
looking at about a 99 accuracy match the
entire way and this game went up in
Flames NACA gets the win Danya that is
so needed five to four is the score how
many turnarounds did we have at the end
of that game first it was almost a
surewin for hikara after C4 then Carlson
starts to stabilize he takes over the
advantage gives away his dark Spirit
bishop and then blonders his Queen just
when he was about to deal the final blow
the score is five to four and we have
gotten everything that we've asked for
him on and then some
wow this was such an insane finish to
the five plus one portion I mean this it
speaks for itself Dania that the match
is within one point I think we need an
instant replay of the final blunder we
don't have the time to go through every
turnaround of that crazy there was a lot
I'm not gonna lie if we could go to move
32 I'm on really quickly after F4 Hikaru
forgetting about onpassant which sets up
the mate threat on G2 he has to waste
the tempo to bring his Bishop back now
H4 would have won on the spot because it
would have forced the bishop back and
would have forced the queen trade
instead Carlson gives Nakamura a Tempo
he uses his Tempo to bring his Knight
back H4 Queen C3 check and now the
shocking move of all F6 here would have
kept a winning Advantage but instead he
goes Knight F6 forgetting that white can
simply capture F3 and simultaneously
prevent H takes G3 which was played
because of Rook takes G3 picking up the
queen now I say Obviously but with 10
seconds on the clock in a position this
chaotic God himself wouldn't be able to
figure this out properly
truly I mean what we just saw was uh I
think a great sign for Nakamura he was
not afraid to sack multiple pieces to
take the game to Magnus Carlson yes
Magnus wiggled out of it a little bit
but it was never to the point where it
was done and dusted and you know we were
on to the the next uh format or anything
like that no this game was still up in
the air the entire time and you're gonna
be rewarded for being the aggressor
incredible Hikaru was the aggressor in
that game Magnus still the aggressor in
the match he leads by one and we will
let the players take a much deserved
breather before the next segment but
before we do that we wanted to ask if
you wish that your financial systems
were as fast and as smart as the 2023
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbus well they can be check out
coinbase.com update the system today or
use x-glam coinbase in the chat to learn
more well we have assigned a lot of
exclamation marks to the moves in this
match and we will continue to do so you
are watching the finals of the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
more action in just a couple of minutes
thank you
foreign
[Music]
almost daily I love them honestly
because they taste great I know that
sounds silly but not everyone wakes up
looking forward to taking a supplement
and I legitimately do because they're
tasty obviously they're phenomenal for
you or I wouldn't be taking them a few
years ago I went completely corn free so
I don't eat anything that has not just
corn but any type of corn syrup which
these days is in everything and so I
spent a lot of time looking into these
supplements whether it's pre-workout or
just to like start my day
and I spend a lot of time looking into
that stuff and there is nothing better
than the ingredients in it hey
phenomenal for
any type of thing you're looking you're
looking for whether it's just adding a
little more whatever you want to call it
fiber vitamins all the stuff in them you
know into your diet if you're lacking
some of that if you're legitimately
looking for energy and and ways to kind
of start your day on the healthy side of
the of the bed if that's a thing or the
chess board but uh no the the
ingredients in this stuff is the highest
quality if you are looking for anything
to boost your diet
around it's it's awesome I also actually
take this liquid stuff which is vitamin
D with vitamin K these days if you're
not taking vitamin K with vitamin D
you're basically wasting your time if
you didn't know that Pro tip you gotta
have vitamin K with your vitamin D so
anyway I uh I love ag1 whatever reason
you might be looking for it
it just tastes so good like honestly I
have to be careful not to drink too much
because then that can you know could be
too much for your tummy but it's
phenomenal tastes good good for you good
energy makes you feel like you're
starting the day fresh and I recommend
it check out ag1 right now
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh
GF hey you have Rook D1 oh
that was sick oh my God that was nasty
rugby whining
oh my goodness
goodbye one bang bang
in the bishop yeah Bishop F7 rookie six
is a mate threat
oh he's lost his position does he have
enough time oh my gosh Magnus has to
show off the mouse speed right now this
could be over if Hikaru can bleed
another minute off the batch block here
we go oh oh oh no he doesn't have enough
time it's over Magnus gives a little bit
clap forehead car Nakamura
back we are at the 2023 speed Chess
Championship final presented by coinbase
I almost said 2022 I'm on we had that
incredible highlight reel there from
last year's finals I've been
experiencing withdrawal for exactly a
year and I'll be experiencing withdrawal
for another year after this but we still
have a lot of Chess left to play as
Magnus Carlson holds a one point lead
let's take a quick look at his 2022
performance up until the loss of Hikaru
Magnus was rampaging through the field
at one
yeah and it kind of reminds me uh
surprise of this year right it has had a
really similar run and you know if he
ends up losing this finals to Hikaru
obviously he's gonna be thinking oh you
know he car's done it again that same
type of run from last year so Magnus is
out here looking for his revenge and
guess what Dania we are approaching
that stat that we talked about earlier
the three plus one section this is his
best section against Hikaru Nakamura so
this is his best place to cement that
Revenge this is where Magnus has to
butter his bread but in order to do that
he's got to set himself up mentally
especially given his last two losses
they weren't consecutive losses he won a
beautiful game there in the middle but
first there was that insane end game
where he gives up his night in a dead
drawn position and then that final game
where Magnus somehow climbed out of a
dead lost position only to make the last
blunder so Hikaru he had the last laugh
in the five plus one segment who will
have the first laugh in our next hour of
three plus one and the gong sounds again
a queen's Indian yet again
yeah interesting I'm trying to I guess
technically going back to that one game
they did have in it uh it didn't really
go hikaru's way but I think he was quick
to to realize it didn't have anything to
do with the opening so he was happy to
try this one again but in his shorter
time format now I'm actually gonna be
paying close attention Dania to the time
situation early on it's actually in
Chicago's favor but he has been down on
the clock against Magnus a lot in this
match and what just happened there is I
I pretty much standard fare this Knight
you 594 sequence is common in a lot of
different types of positions can we
rewind it we're on the same page yet
again tomorrow
so what's the idea of this move it's a
double attack Knight G5 is against the
H7 Square which is mate and Bishop takes
B7 so if you take on G5 you allow Bishop
takes B7 and black actually loses the
exchange because you can't guard The
Rook on A8 and save your knight at the
same time so that's why Hikaru covered
with his Knight onto E4 covering the
maid covering the bish bishop and
garnering for himself a Tempo that he
uses in order to cut the contact between
the two Bishops by developing the Knight
and now the game uh is much more stable
what do you make of this position that
they currently have
yeah that was a great explanation
exactly what the players were thinking
now I think with the Queen's Indian I
always have to just hand that little bit
of an edge to uh to White just based on
the structure like you have more space
more control of the center but this
extended F Pawn is what I'm focusing on
for Hikaru here this is going to give
his pieces some scope on the f file and
if you back that pawn up to F5 and maybe
give white the F4 move then I think the
edge in terms of the Space is really
clear so I like this move that Hikaru
has managed to get in I think it's
balanced
yeah I mean it's hard to say whether you
know the weight of white superiority in
the center because if you just look at
the center White's got the pawns on D4
and C4 White's got the potential
breakthrough with D5 on the other hand
he doesn't have his light squared Bishop
anymore I'm on
and he's just allowed to move F3 girl
Magnus calm down here I have three
anybody yeah this is going once F3 and
queen H3 and I think everyone is you
know chomping at the bit to Checkmate
Magnus Carlson in that fashion I mean
look he does have ways that he can
prevent this King H1 of course
eventually get a queen uh to F1 Queen D3
Rook G1 but why do you want to have to
defend that position that's what I'm
wondering well I'm wondering that too
I'm on am I gonna F3 and it's on the
board and e4y to prevent Queen F5 but
Hikaru says I'm gonna fly through a
different airport no direct flight from
Charlotte's I'm gonna drive to Atlanta
and and fly to H3 but Queen G4 is met
with King H2 and I think magnus's
General philosophy or here I'm on is
that in the time that it takes for black
to set up all these threats Magnus is
imperceptibly built a really impressive
Center he's also blundered the move Rook
F4 and I think he's losing the threat of
this game
yeah King and by the way H4 while I
understand it I actually thought that H3
was a smarter decision for the same idea
King H2
um after Rook F4 I think the engine of
by the way no no no no
come on come on come on
I think
I think that the engine doesn't
understand how good this is for black
like I think this is actually one where
Hikaru understands that he's completely
winning and the engine is actually still
coming to that oh my gosh oh my gosh
there's an incredible move here you want
to go when it takes H4 most people want
to do it but white plays Rook takes F3
and eliminates the pawn so what you do
is you deflect the queen with Knight
takes C4 then you play Rook takes H4 and
there is an Unstoppable made threat
along the HL for example Queen d3omon
black just plays Queen G4 and that's not
the end of it let's say white plays D5
Rook H1 Chuck King takes H1 Queen H3 and
queen G2 how sexy would that be and yes
I said the word because no other word
would accurately describe this
combination
truly I mean this talk about a game
after the break like Magnus just came
came out and played this E3 allowing F3
and now it feels like he's just getting
checkmated and he's slowly coming to
that realization this is not the way you
want to start to three plus one section
and Hikaru knows that something exists
he has now paused for a minute which is
a long time in a three minute game I
think he's searching searching for that
crushing blow Knight takes C4 is an
incredibly difficult move not only
because it sacks a piece but because it
occurs on the other side of the board
with 30 seconds on the clock you Caro
better find it because he might no
longer have the time to manage this
position for a long time he needs to
Checkmate Magnus now and he has found it
unreal and he has found a move
Knight takes C4 you explained it
perfectly deflecting the queen all you
need is that one moment that one move
after Rook H4 to play Queen G4 and look
technically this is playable if you take
and maybe give up The Rook but your your
loss and Hikaru knows it what a game
what a combination and there's basically
only two players on the planet that can
find a move like this in a Blitz game
and they're sitting in front of us right
now on the camera one is Magnus reminds
me of his Knight takes B4 move against
vidit how the delicious irony right
Knight takes B4 now we shift it one file
to the right Hikaru finds Knight takes
C4 is Magnus gonna find Knight takes D4
sacking the knight in the next game
yeah we're just gonna work our way over
yeah Brooke takes H4 and it's over Queen
G4 is Unstoppable
Queen takes G3 oh
oh my gosh there's a queen size oh
oh my goodness that is beautiful the
word sexy we have to use it again Daniel
didn't girl
oh
wow just wow nothing but just pure shock
I have to go back yeah yeah that one
Daniel there's there's no way that we
can't show that again and explain what
exactly was going to happen Queen takes
G3 of course a brilliancy look King F1
is not even a question so you have to
take it but then you unleash the F Pawn
moving down to F1 and Rook H1 incredible
and then the mate King F1 Rook H1 King
E2 and look at the mate F1 queen king D2
Queen C1 shuttling the queen to E2 and
then Queen E1 mate you have exactly two
squares that are accessible they are the
mating squares this was Exquisite this
was a work of art and you knew honestly
that something was gonna go down on
Hikaru landed upon on F3 Lolly's mate he
said it on his stream a million times
you knew that he started to search the
moment that pawn landed on F3 what a
game to tie the match
and you think about how you know that
was almost you know not taking anything
away from hikar but it's very
self-inflicted by Magnus he played E3
and said push your Pawn to F3 and Hikaru
said uh sure I'll do that and I'll mate
you with a couple brilliances is that
what you wanted
clearly that's that's what Magnus asked
for and that's what he received it was
unnecessarily provocative and it was
more annoying that from Agnes that he
did it with the white pieces in a in a
queen's Indian where he was hoping to
play without risk instead he gets
checkmated I feel like I try as a
commentator I'm on now to make less
comments about body language because you
you never know what the players are
actually thinking but man after that
Bish rook and Bishop versus Rook game it
seems to me like Magnus hasn't been the
same yet
yeah it's it's so interesting because he
bounced back immediately with an
incredible win to sort of Silence uh
that notion but then you look at the the
games that have followed and yeah I I
couldn't agree more he's not fully
himself and let's give credit where
credits do Hikaru Nakamura has
absolutely you know he's he's joined
this match in a real way he's back in it
and the momentum seems to be in his
Corner in this uh three plus one segment
that he's struggled with in the past and
so far he's also adjusted his clock
management subtly but still in a big way
now he's holding the time advantage in
the last couple of games this game
included we have a really interesting
Sicilian where Magnus has just released
the tension with D4 and C5 the drawback
of this approach is that white now has
some light Square control on the queen
side you can see hikaru's Knight heading
over to C4 the bishop could also Park
itself on A4 uh I think the position is
approximately balanced but I would
probably take white here
yeah the the structure does look pretty
pretty Pleasant here and remember Hikaru
Nakamura is currently playing for what I
believe would be his first lead of this
match he's tied it up and started in the
best possible way now he's got the white
pieces he can keep piling on the
pressure that would be momentous as
would a potential kingside attack that
Hikaru would develop if he lifts his
Rook up to F3 or his Queen to G4 Queen
G4 very thematic move for him on you're
not necessarily trying to Checkmate
black in one Fell Swoop you're trying to
set up the preconditions for a potential
kingside attack I mean Bishop H6 and F4
would come really really fast and that
Bishop which would land on F6 I don't
think that's a reliable Bishop at all I
would go Bishop H6 and take my chances
here
right because Bishop F6 he's saying okay
E5 I've got it covered but F4 renews
that exact threat and if you play E5
you're opening up this bishop in general
yeah that that looks really scary I'll
tell you what Magnus missed I think
Magnus was relying on King h8 he might
play that move and there might be a pawn
that lands on F6 mirroring the narrative
in the last game Hikaru would play E5
anyway and after G takes H6 he takes F6
Black's King side is going to be in
shambles and we're going to get another
thematic attack by Hikaru here Magnus is
in trouble yet again I was gonna point
out I mean it feels like we're stating
the obvious but you have to take a step
back and think that Hikaru Nakamura he's
gotten his wins and actually we've seen
Magnus under the most pressure when he's
kind of just closed his eyes and started
attacking like caveman style he's going
for the king and it's so refreshing and
I think the chat has got to be
entertained by this type of Chess Daniel
you don't always see this from you know
the absolute highest levels because
those barbaric kind of attacks don't
work but that is exactly what's working
for Hikaru barbaric is a great way to
put the way that this match was preceded
I'm on it's not one match it's been two
matches where are the balustry Lopez is
gone are the positional straws
are the long end games gone are the
maneuvering battles now we've got all
out bloody sanguinary action against
each other's Kings except it's really
only against one king Magnus hasn't
really taken too many stabs at ikaro's
King recently
[Music]
you know Rook G8 let's let's at least
give some credit to the bishop on B7 who
heard that comment from you and said I
could make some threats too but more
horses you're absolutely right this is
uh you know Hikaru is gonna bring that
that Rook into E1 maybe 95 F5 is also on
the cards hey the H6 Pawn is hanging as
well C5 and the C5 Faun is saying and
Hikaru might absolutely say listen I
don't I'm under normal I didn't sign a
contract that I have to win this game by
Checkmate he might take C5 and then
trade Queens on D6 Magnus is also down
to 10 seconds I feel like the wheels are
really coming off in this game
you have Rook G6 feels like a normal
move to hit the F Bond guard the H Pawn
but then as you mentioned you could
switch gears and just take on C5 and now
you could switch gears and go Knight E5
which is the square relinquished by
magnus's last move Rook to E1 would be a
great build up move
three Bishop C2 so many ideas yeah if
you can bring that Bishop to C2 remember
with 5.6 seconds you just need the most
you know complicated procedure for
magnets to find and that alone might be
enough so I'd really like to move C3 I
think it's tough to handle and we called
it right he's just taking material and
Knight F3 Knight G5 oh no that could be
a hammer blow and he finds it because
Rook G6 is impossible The f8 Rook hangs
every detail has been accounted for look
at this this is exquisite called it
that's actually a really key detail and
Magnus was having that precise panic in
his head he's like oh Rook G6 the nh6
that's easy but with the Rook hanging oh
Bishop C2 Bishop C2 he doesn't recapture
the bishop and Bishop takes G6 or queen
takes f8 and he wins Hikaru is on fire
he wins with a Miss oh God what an awful
that was again he's just taking it to
Magnus Carlson right now this is
honestly amazing to watch I said it
before but I'll say it again you don't
see these kind of like this is not
supposed to be magnus's Kryptonite but
it feels that way at the moment Hikaru
Nakamura is on another level and he's
just any chance he has to attack the
king he's doing it and it's working
right now Magnus needs a game to calm
things down and I like magnus's decision
go back to the real Lopez the Queen's
Indian hasn't been working very well and
what impressed me the most about that
game it wasn't the fast attacking moves
it wasn't the bishop H6 is an f4s
because that's pretty standard fare it
was the slow moves right the Knight f3s
and the C3 Bishop c2s Hikaru was able to
keep his composure and find these slow
build up moves when a lot of people
especially against Magnus would start to
panic and throw all their pieces Into
the Fire Hikaru completely disarmed
magnus's attempts at counter play his
time management isn't approved the good
news for Magnus is that he's only down
by a point we're talking about this like
it's a 10-point match no this is still
very close
yeah this is what we expected we talked
about those win percentages from these
players earlier we're starting to see
where it comes from both of them have
taken leads gone on runs this is
speaking of leads hikaranakamura's first
lead of this SCC final
incredible now what do we make of this
latest real Lopez I again am a little
bit biased in White's favor and the fact
that 97 cannot be played here forces
Black Knight to an awkward Square
that's right and we've seen this opening
before from ikaru and I believe this is
the game that featured his uh you know
sort of uncharacteristic blunder of a
full piece uh last time
indeed and look at that Knight on B7
it's uh does it have a future I that's
more of a rhetorical question that's
your opinion not gonna answer that with
words I'll just let the arrows do the
talking I would go C6 here honestly with
with Hikaru I would try to change the
course of the game also Bishop D3 is a
major threat and the B5 Pawn cannot be
defended
yeah and it's a little unusual to feel
so comfortable giving away your dark
squared Bishop if your Magnus here but
it comes with a very well and you see
the move C6 played because the b-pawn is
so weak Bishop D3 he's I think he's made
the right decision Dania followed your
idea C6 just needed to happen necessary
evil and there's two main reasons the
first is now you can protect the pawn
with Queen B6 the second reason is how
do you harness your Bishop pair well
normally you do it by opening up the
center and that's what magnus's last
move is aimed against Bishop B3
controlling the D5 square and
discouraging Hikaru from opening up the
center with D5 we might even see a move
like Queen D3 and the knight from D2
could access the D5 Square through F1
and E3 and that would spell major
positional trouble for Hikaru Nakamura
who still struggles with that Knight
that terrible night on B7
and there's there's a long-term reason
why this night is no good right now we
can see its future is pretty bleak but
Knight d8 you're thinking okay 96 but
white is going to play the move G3 maybe
the move H4 and you start to see wait
every single forward square is covered
and again we're seeing the classic play
on all three sides of the board Queen
side Magnus has the a file Center he's
got the D5 square but was Bishop D5 a
little bit premature because the queen
is not the piece that you want occupying
an outpost you want to take the Knight
and put it on D5 and that's like you
know taking a parking spot that's
reserved for the business that Queen is
going to get towed away pretty shortly
but that's gonna cost Magnus a couple of
Tempe and Tempe is money in a position
like this the C3 Pawn could come under
Fire
oh the interconnected business money
references Dania is going crazy right
now I like that one Rook A3 guarding the
C3 Pawn but multi-purpose as well Rook
to A1 and Rook A6 Rook A7 you're gonna
bring the Rooks into the party and again
that Knight is looking for somewhere to
go Knight C6 great call I'm really doing
much and Knight E6 you will see the move
G3 and you called that when there was
still a piece on d8 so pretty impressive
the Knight finally has a future it's got
the E6 square and Magnus has clearly
lost the Lion's Share of his Advantage
which is uncharacteristic these are
exactly the positions where we know
Magnus to be nearly Flawless in Blitz
but Bishop D5 was a bit of a panicky
reaction I still think he's got the
preferable position
but if Hikaru gets a knight to F4 God
forbid if blackened pushed D5 here the
tides could really turn
totally and that's why you saw Knight E3
he actually wants to play G3 but I think
he realized Knight C7 accomplishes the
same thing as Knight F4 and if you can
play D5 you might sack the pawn right
and play each one that could be
devastating D5 is very much in the cards
it's being threatened
and I think Hikaru could even play Queen
C6 here targeting the C3 pawn and
preparing D5 once more and Magnus is
going to say Over My Dead Body he's
gonna shift The Rook from E1 to D1 and
it's so clear what the battle is
revolving around the battle is revolving
squarely around the D5 Square oh yes
you're getting good at it Daniel there's
one step at a time long-term thing that
we need to be very careful of if we are
playing with the black pieces here do
not let a pair of knights trade and the
other night reach the D5 Square that's
like you know worst case scenario and
something went a little bit wrong in the
last few moves by Hikaru because Magnus
is very close to turning that into
reality even if the F3 Knight doesn't
manage to reach D5 I still think this
end game requires a lot more Precision
from black than it does from White and
it's almost like Precision to see Cara's
calling card
yeah he heard that he's like yeah I've
got that I've got that
there's a weird line here because H4 if
the bishop goes back Knight D2 and I
think white is achieving a lot so the
idea
Bishop C1 and like what's going on there
I don't like Rick takes B5 by Magnus
hecaro simply doubles on the C file he's
gonna win the C3 Pawn back and I feel
like the worst is behind him I think
he's gonna hold the draw here with with
room to spare
I agree I agree you can't defend that
pawn the Rooks will invade and if you
don't play Knight takes Bishop then yeah
you may even risk something as well
because the rook's Gonna Get Behind the
pawn Rook B2 there's gonna be gonna be
threats it should be three and Bishop E3
is going to be threatened uh after black
puts the Rook on the second ring so be
careful if you're Carlson
yep Rook I guess you could go Rook C2
but you're running into uh running into
Bishop E3 there instead he wants to
clarify things win the pawn immediately
we've seen Magnus pull out wins in these
types of end games but given hikaru's
current level of confidence it just
doesn't feel the same way when Magnus
had these end games against Wesley you
were almost expecting something to go
wrong now I'm expecting something to go
wrong but from the opposite side it
feels like Magnus is suddenly worse
agreed yep so well but he's got the
confidence that's what really matters
he's playing with that that uh different
different level of intensity right now
the position starting to sharpen up and
now it's liquidating back down finally
we see a peace trade and the C Pawn
might get traded eventually for the beep
on that's how these games are often
drawn
I think so yeah the king is going to try
to move over to C1 but everyone is just
gonna stay put yep ooh a little bit of
tactics here don't go Rook B6 and
blunder Rook C6 that's the one way to
lose this true and Magnus is going to
sign the peace treaty here in a way of
mon that was just as frustrating as the
losses because Magnus got exactly what
he wanted with the white pieces and he
couldn't deliver
yeah well said and uh Nakamura is doing
what he needs to do when he's a little
bit worse he's fighting well and he's
making those draws but he's taking his
chances his opportunities when he has
them so the match has really turned and
I feel like Hikaru is following the the
perfect match strategy right now Magnus
is suddenly Under Pressure to get a win
because he hasn't seen one come his way
in a while
crazy the way that the momentum turns in
these SEC matches just when you think
you have a handle on who's in charge and
who's calling the shots boom not only
did he results change but the way the
moment the course of the games have
changed completely we have another real
Lopez this time Hikaru playing kind of
an old setup with a Pawn on C4 this was
popular I think in the 80s uh the C4 D3
E4 setups and I'm gonna be honest I
don't have a pretty good handle on
anything that's happening with the bond
structure here
yeah it definitely feels like C takes
needs to happen but you know light
squares for Magnus all I'm seeing are
Easy Pawn breaks for black like Queen D7
C6 F5 like it feels like everything is
coming for black here and are we gonna
see counter attack is it time for F5
Magnus needs to strike this is where
Magnus needs to say listen the momentum
isn't going my way but I'm gonna take
this one over he has to play out five
because if he takes on D4 he allows
Knight takes D4 and white suddenly
clamps down on light squares on both
sides of the board C6 F5 Magnus taking
his time that tells us the wheels are
turning in his brain he's definitely
calculating F5 right now
yep and F5 what is the variation so F5
happens if Pawn takes on E5 Pawn takes
on e4 I want to pull this up on the
analysis board Danny because this is
critical E6 looks really scary I think a
lot of people would see this move and
rule the line out but look at the d5's
pawn after Queen I guess Queen E8 was my
idea
um yeah Queen C8 I think to keep the
pawn protected and Knight D4 that's the
problem it gives up the d-pawn if you go
back to E1 I'm on instead of Knight D4
you allow Rook to F5 picking off that
pawn and White's position collapses but
Magnus he Engineers a different Pawn
break he's decided to strike on the
other side of the board and this seems
to carry a lot less punch than F5
definitely it it has a more um I guess
liquidating nature to it
um F5 was definitely playing for the
edge but it was equally you know it was
risky as well uh oh careful whoa whoa
whoa five and he's 97 that's it and it
sidesteps it Queen 96 and Bishop F6 and
he will pick up the D5 Pawn but yeah
Caro could even go Knight C6 and I find
it hard to believe that he's in real
danger in that position maybe a smidge
worse because of his pawns but they're
not really accessible to Black's Bishop
that's right yeah I think we probably
will see something like that maybe
bishop C3 here
um I feel like what hikar wants to do to
be perfectly fine he's played Bishop C3
and then B4 once that pawn gets up to B4
I think he knows like nothing bad's
gonna happen at that point and I don't
want to keep harping on the momentum
because it's still a one point match
this could change at the drop of a hat
but I think Magnus early in the match
would have played F5 I feel like after
he jumped out to that two-point lead he
was making decisions quickly now he's
playing with a little bit more
hesitation trying to avoid getting
behind you know by two or three points
but eventually he's gonna have to start
taking risks again
yeah I I get the feeling from this
position that Hikaru is very content to
play Bishop here uh at some point play
Knight C6 and I was gonna say play the
move B4 and Magnus I think is well aware
that he wants to play B4 so that Bishop
doesn't feel secure on the C3 square and
it's a three result game I mean White's
not the only one with weaknesses on the
queen side in fact I would go so far as
to say that black now uh it has the onus
is on black to make sure that A6 is
protected Rogue B5 I think might be the
only reasonable move here because white
can't take on A6 there because if Bishop
takes C4 with the lateral attack on the
bishop so I'm expecting Rook B5 I'm not
expecting Rook A8 which would lose the
game to Knight B6 and Bishop C7 after
Rook d8
yep that's a good point
um and certainly Rook A8 just doesn't
feel right anyway you know
um but Rook B5 super strange move to
play we talk about moves that don't feel
right uh Roxy doesn't feel right
although after Knight B6 I guess there's
I was gonna say Rook C5 but there's
Knight D7 there he's gonna sack The
Exchange after Bishop C7 I think he's
gonna pick up the pawn on B3 take back
on d8 with the rook and this is actually
I think a really high level decision by
Magnus Rook to D2 isn't coming Bishop F6
and those Bishops are dominating the
Knight on B6 which is no way back
because of Bishops amazing and this is
this is so high level by Magnus I think
it's still equal but this puts serious
pressure on Hikaru to play accurately
wow you know just got to uh you know
step aside and let it happen because
that that was sick I did not see that
um at all and this is exactly the type
of shock moves that these players are
capable of because that looked
unplayable I mean you were like this is
lost and I I couldn't see any reason why
not Bishop F6 and suddenly I'm like oh
you were right but for who this isn't
the category of Magnus Carlson moves
that I would never play in literally you
can give me a million years to train and
to acquire knowledge about the game and
I don't think I would ever decide upon
an exchange sacrifice out of nowhere in
the end game look at this position why
does a full exchange up he could even
trade the Rooks of The Rook A8 he might
do that but the B2 Pawn is so
problematic that Hikaru decides to bail
out Rook takes F6 sacking The Exchange
back in a very heads up decision I think
yeah honestly this is like you know Rook
takes B4 Bishop B5 check King H2 takes
takes Rook uh D2 and we you know it's
just like amazing from both sides the
way they do it and Rook D4 will defend
the B4 Pawn is anybody playing for a win
here nominally I don't think so Rook to
D2 maybe but I wouldn't give up the B4
Pawn unless you absolutely have to
yeah and there's a weird bit of
coordination like Rook D2 Rook takes B4
Rook takes F2 and sometimes King G1 you
know just shocks you for a minute
because you're like well I can't take
that pawn on G2
okay
Bishop to B5 but suddenly he's given a
B4 and whoa he goes he puts a three on
three with a B Pawn and this is a draw
objectively I would even go so far as to
say this is a handle black should make
the draw handily but why is he flirting
with this yeah
I don't know this is uh this is
something you could definitely lose here
the pawn is gonna go up the board it
should be a draw but yeah you mentioned
I feel like Magnus has improperly
arranged his pawns now King to D4 how do
you win these positions you have to
sacrifice the F2 Pawn at some point but
you also could lose this with white if
you accidentally stack your two pawns
and black plays G4 he car was thinking
about it though and he's gonna buy he's
still thinking by the way like the king
F3 is not like let's make a draw it's
I'm I need more time to process what's
going on King G4 now don't go King G6 if
you're Carlson he gets his King to H5
but how does he progress over here F4 F4
definitely F4 is gonna happen but you
can't get your king out of the cage
without giving up G2 with a check oh
he's loud King G4 what on Earth did he
just do
but wait now
wait wait a minute so can he actually
win this Pawn
that's the question the king comes in
he's gonna put the pawn up to H6 he can
win the F Pawn maybe but after H6
remember the king is gonna hide out on
H7
if there has to be a winning plan here
but maybe Hikaru find it with under 10
seconds on his clock
okay moves are easy B1 Rook before you
give the lateral checks as long as you
can White's King will approach the rook
and that's when you play Rook B1 King E6
and black is in Zog zwang King F5 he
wins same thing no way how on Earth did
he take that game
I have those were some of the most
obvious Ed movements I've ever seen from
Hikaru Nakamura and just you know let's
give him space to Bob accordingly
because he should after that performance
he just won that position he's winning
games against Magnus Carlson that you'd
never expect anyone should be able to do
you saw this game and you could put a
silver dollar on the fact that Magnus
Magnus is the one from whom we're used
to seeing these endgame victories out of
nowhere it's a three on three I'm on and
we already have seen this we saw it in
the game where Carlson hung a knight
here he didn't hang a night he actually
got outplayed first he gave up the
b-pawn he made a concession and thought
that Rook end game was easy to save and
somehow you know the the path to a draws
my coach used to say when it gets
narrower and narrower narrower like that
eventually you're just not used to
having to find a single Force move
Magnus is reeling right now and he is
down by two points
he's reeling and he's making decisions
which I would say are uncharacteristic
you know normally such a practical
player why did he want a position where
seemingly like he could only play to
lose it right the material was even then
he gave up a pawn to play a rook end
game where it's like you your best
result is a draw so why go down that
path only bad things can happen and bad
things did happen
and they did and Magnus needs to stem
the bleeding this is a huge game because
this is the game before our halftime
break of the three minute portion Magnus
deciding to go into the Berlin end game
in a very thematic Pawn sacrifice
pushing E6 damaging Black's pawns even
further and now he's gonna get his knife
and fork ready and try to win that E6
Pawn back
that's right and you know we're gonna
have that classic situation where
White's trying to get a mobile Pawn
majority three against two whereas you
know Black's Pawn majority is not I
wouldn't use the word mobile because the
pawns are doubled and you can't create a
pass Pawn easily
125 000 of you across to which in
YouTube watching I see Carver Nakamura
seizes the momentum and the two-point
lead for the first time in this match
what an incredible turnaround although I
like the way that Magnus is handling the
end game when you're reeling that like
that Amman when you're struggling it
doesn't matter if you're Magnus or your
Joe schmoe you want to do the same thing
you want to steer the subsequent games
in the direction that you feel most
comfortable you want to go back to your
roots and for Magnus that means getting
into end games in which he feels
comfortable
so I was I mean gonna ask the obvious
but did he hang the C6 Pawn did he
realize it was hanging or
is there yeah what's going on Rook takes
C6 and The Rook evacuates via C4 even if
black plays Bishop D6 it doesn't trap
The Rook yeah did they both miss a free
Pawn it's almost like Mutual blindness
uh they're seeing all the same things
and they're missing all the same things
that's really weird it was literally sh
up rook takes C6 simple as that now
Hikaru puts his King on B7 I still think
he's worse I think he's struggling to
get his pieces out largely because of
the H6 bonamon because you can't go
Bishop G7
that's right and there still is a 3v2
brewing which is why you know Black's
not necessarily in a rush to take and
trade because I don't I don't know like
what what's the next procedure after
that
hmm hard to develop hard to develop
Magnus he really really needs this win
this is the kind of position we're used
to seeing him convert
and he's gotten the dream Berlin setup
he has the three onions already on the
king side and more active pieces
yep no this is uh I would say one of the
most important games of the match I mean
uh Hikaru pulling off a draw here is
going to feel like a win totally
and Carlson trying to prevent that from
happening pushing H4 trying to introduce
more attackable weaknesses on the king
side
yeah it's I mean I don't think that's a
mistake at all really it looks like a
pretty good move to me King H3 and
Knight H4 of course he wasn't going to
blunder the g-pawn with Knight takes H4
thing well they blunder the C6 but I
never say never mind yes good point you
well you don't say
okay GH Rook G5 Hikaru trying to go
after the Jeep on but Knight G6 might
defend upon tactically Knight G6 takes
H5 check King G4 and you've got two
pieces hanging at the same time easy
pickings for Magnus Carlson who's gonna
bury his Knight back to F4 we just
talked about blundering fun and it's
like there we go Oh you mean like this
now I'm on Knight F4 it's so important
to understand that Rook takes C5 and
Bishop takes F4 is losing for black
because the minor pieces are incapable
of handling the H Pawn
mm-hmm yep but that is a really it's
like such a strange concept because you
always always in chest and two pieces
for The Rook of course is better than
two pieces but the minor pieces are
notoriously very very poor at defending
not only against past bonds but
especially ones on the side of the board
A and H pawns and that's exactly what
white has I would also be tempted by the
move F4 trying to give up the H Pawn in
order to shuttle the F Pawn off the
board quickly but if you can play Knight
F4 and you get away with it you
absolutely should Knight F4 Rook F5
there's King G4 White's pieces are
ideally positioned to support those
minor pieces
but Magnus that lack of confidence is it
going to bite him yet again he's now
down on the clock he has to find that F4
that is a really really important move
yeah and it should be said that F4 is
like a very decent backup and this is a
complicated move to play Knight F4
invites everything because you might
think oh the king is coming and if my H
Pawn is not going as fast as I think it
should it's not something that you can
use confidence I'm on 15 seconds he's
played the bishop to F4 he puts a third
piece on that square and Rook F5 sacking
the bishop in order to go after White's
Queen side pawns what an incredible
decision in Rook G5 Hikaru is navigating
these tactics with unbelievable
precision
yeah Bishop takes H6 it was just Rook
takes F2 I believe and pawns falling and
without any pawns left you're not gonna
G2 Magnus has to be careful here I know
it sounds crazy but I would be playing
this for a win given the time situation
if I'm Hikaru he's bobbing his head Rook
takes F2 oh my gosh or it's just
carefully surviving Magnus is going to
lose the B Pawn and he has another end
game to defend I I can't believe we're
saying this and he let his clock run too
low
mm-hmm
yeah Rook D3 is such a stable move so
Rook F3 you have to I was I mean D3 Now
isn't that just a draw
it was now he's gone Rook B2 allowing 97
the Knight
going back where is it going back to D5
Bishop Fate has to be considered but
don't get yourself checkmated for Hikaru
Rook D7 Jack and Knight C6 that's up on
mate threat and that's why he goes to F4
and back to A8 and Bishop B8 whoa that's
why he does this
oh my gosh he's playing for a win
yeah this is very very strange
he's playing for a win magnus's Knight
is stuck and black has connected pastors
them on this is the one that needs to be
careful though yeah for sure
King B7 and there's no Knight D7 oh no
oh no oh no oh no there's only one move
in that position and nobody could
produce it no absolutely insane I can't
believe it Magnus is like how did this
just happen this was the most
unbelievable end game yet
have you ever seen a mic drop in chess
this was one of them this was an actual
mic drop moment Hikaru has left Magnus
at the board he gets up emphatically and
I mean he should be walking like a champ
right now I can't believe that he's won
back to back to back games that it
looked like he had no business that was
literal Wizardry and I wanted to point
out him on the last moment where Magnus
actually made the losing move was here
and we already knew that things had gone
completely Haywire the Knight was stuck
such an instructed moment for newer
players you see how strong much stronger
the pawns are than the Knight the only
drawing move was and I'll let you show
what I'm on sorry Rook H6 Rook H6
instead of Rook H3 sorry Rook H6 and uh
Rook H6 like you know to play this move
would be like actual sorcery what is
this the point is King takes B8 Rook
takes B6 and then Rook B4 rounds up the
pawns but the second point the one
that's harder to see is that if instead
of King takes be a black plays C3 you
actually use the Knight on B8 as a
springboard and stop the pawn from C6
but that at this point was impossible to
find Magnus let his clock run too low
and he gave up that H Pawn and that's
when you sense the game starting to turn
yep and to for this to be the basis of
that position being equal it's like no
you have to go back and revise your
evaluation no Hikaru was playing that
for a win and this was it practically it
might have just been lost right because
totally you can't you can't base the the
uh evaluation of oh yeah it was equal
and you know magnets just blundered no
if he has to find this those were
insanely good practical winning chances
from Hikaru and he knew that going into
it and if Magnus can't convert this
position if Magnus can't do what he does
best what he's hung his hat on for his
entire chess career then he's in huge
trouble in this match and he's in
trouble objectively losing the three
minute portion four and a half half and
he really really needs this break but
before we go on break we wanted to
remind you not to miss out on what month
is it not September it's September
through the end of this month claim up
to 30 off on all new Subs on Twitch
subscribers gain access to exclusive
break time content during broadcast
unlock new emotes and score an ad-free
experience on chess.com don't miss out
on the deals this September subscribe
now
okay well we will let this September
continue with an incredible SEC finals
presented by coinbase Carl holds a
three-point lead Magnus has coming back
to do he has some mental work to do and
we will be back with the second portion
of the three minute segment in just a
couple of minutes
[Music]
thank you
yeah it's the same thing every time why
did you on passant bro I swear to God
ambassan should be enforced all my
friends watching and this is taking
forever play faster if I could move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb I should
be able to flag him no matter how many
times I repeat moves 1400 years and it's
the same game every time you
know what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it still
mate is now a win for the player who
gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen trout pawns can
move backwards why is that and never not
been a rule pawns come backwards now
every piece should be allowed to on
passant what that's not even possible
how ship it dunzo update enter
Wiseman ending there's just two kings on
the board what is this Purgatory this is
so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chess why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
[Music]
four actually explode
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update take down
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
absolute Insanity has broken out at the
speed Chess Championship Finals
presented by a coinbase I see Cara
Nakamura has jumped out to a three-point
lead halfway through the three plus one
segment but it's how he's done it on the
strength of some unbelievable turnaround
victories and he leads the three-minute
segment four and a half There's the Man
himself Hikaru has been nothing short of
incredible this year thus far in the
match and of course the previous five
years icaro has instituted his hegemony
over online chess and he's done it
through one finals win after another
which one is the craziest to you
well you're gonna have to explain what's
like what's a gallon uh we don't we
don't have that up here a gallon wait
listen mom in South Carolina gas was
under two dollars back when he car and I
can rewards in the SEC Champion
unbelievable
it's just a Mainstay you know like death
taxes and Hikaru being the SEC champion
truly and if he continues that I mean
he's gonna be taking down Magnus Carlson
which he's looked poised to do thus far
but I mean it's Magnus Carlson he's
never gonna go quietly you feel I've
never Magus has never lost like a
blowout match so you have to feel that
if if your car keeps this pressure up
and keeps getting these wins we're in
for a result that we've simply never
heard of from Magnus Carlson well first
and foremost Magnus has to he has to win
a game he has to prove to himself that
he can win a game in the three minute
time control and this has made all the
more incredible by the fact that Carlson
has not lost to date a three plus one
segment against icaro and this is very
likely to be the first but let's see if
he can reduce the deficit going into the
bullet 22 minutes left and we have an
opening that we haven't had before the
rosalimo which featured very prominently
uh in several SEC matches thus far
and I mean I guess more important than
the change of opening is the change of a
tire here for uh Magnus is this uh do
you think this is uh you know oh that
shirt was attributed to a bunch of
losses this shirt Fresh Start let's see
uh if this can shake up the momentum
hey you gotta do what you gotta do chess
players are pretty superstitious maybe
he he's gotten sweaty and I wouldn't
blame him I mean you you just get sweaty
by definition when you're facing an
on-form Hikaru Nakamura what's going on
in this position the center is open
black and stick are Rook on d8 and that
seems like a kind of low-hanging fruit
type of move white now has to decide on
accommodations for the queen and I don't
see a square that I particularly like
here for white
yeah I think Rook d8 is one of those
moves that of course you expect like you
know your opponent's gonna chase your
queen but still when the moment arrives
you're like like really have to move
this thing as you mentioned Queen C2
might run into Bishop H3 Bishop F5
there's a lot of tactics which is why
Knight D2 is played to support that
Knight Here Comes Knight before great
response by Magnus and I think an
encouraging response by Magnus showing
that he's still confident in his ability
to handle complex tactical situations
the D3 square and the C2 Square those
are the main problems for white I would
consider Queen to B3 Hikaru with Bishop
to D4 and immediately Magnus sacrifices
the bishop of H3 change of shirt change
of Play Change of attitude for Magnus
Carlson what do we make of this
I was actually going to say change of
shirt but the same guy underneath
remember he hit Bishop takes H6 in a
previous game and this feels reminiscent
to that because I'm looking at how you
defend against this and while The Usual
Suspects are Knight H2 right to cover
the the G4 square but hang on you can't
play that move the other idea is to get
something to F1 C5 and Bishop F1 or
queen E2 Queen F1 those are the ideas
but it's not that easy to achieve
there's Knight C2 in the position
there's a rook takes D4 after Knight G4
idea there's so many things that can go
wrong and he is trusting his instincts
guess what he does not have absolutely
everything calculated Dania but he knows
that this is the you know things are set
up perfectly for this type of sacrifice
and it's not even such a high risk move
he's gotten two pawns for it right this
is very different from sacking a queen
or sacking a rook you don't necessarily
have to prove anything right now you can
just kind of chill Hikaru certainly
can't chill he's under a minute and this
isn't even the first time I'm on that
Magnus has sacrificed a bishop on H3
remember in that real Lopez game that
rebound game in the five minute portion
feels like eons ago he sacked on H6 and
he did it very similarly he followed his
intuition and magnus's intuition in
these types of situations are second is
second to none Hikaru doesn't have a lot
of seconds left to figure out a
defensive strategy
can he pull out another miracle
he doesn't want his seconds to turn to
none if he wants a chance in this game
Bishop to E5 he's trying to bring
reinforcements in but I mean there's so
many things wrong with the current
position Knight D3 Knight G4 I mean take
your pick at a good looking move here
Knight D3 excellent move good column on
Knight H5 going after harassing that
Bishop but also preparing to get the
Knight to F4 that's a very magnus-like
move I've played him enough in bullet to
know that Magnus loves these cagey
unexpected moves and right on cue
amazing yeah at this point I mean Knight
G3 is as much of a threat as Knight F4
totally so I think I mean it just looks
like you don't have any options here of
what comes to mind this looks so
frustrating yeah Knight G5 kicking the
queen away queen says I'm more than
happy to sink my teeth into F5 also the
other side of the board don't ignore
that Bishop on B5 which can be targeted
with A6 that's also a very magnus-like
move he likes to use both sides of the
board just when you think he's gonna
attack on the king side he throws you in
for a loop and goes after the other side
of the board I'm totally almost
expecting A6 he could also go Queen H3
and take a and go bobbing for apples
again
yeah that's a really good point because
there is going to be just a knight B2
move to follow up so I love A6 Force
Bishop A4 and then instead of taking the
Rook you can actually take the pawn on
B2 take the bishop and then grab the
rook in the corner and you kind of like
picking apart the white position as you
mentioned on both sides of the board I
mean the king is going to be left to
hang out to dry at the end of that line
yeah because White's Queen is going to
be on A4 presumably it's going to
recapture the Knight so that move Queen
H3 Magnus is keeping it in his pocket
and awaiting the perfect opportunity to
go back after oh and queen E5 is even
stronger Now The Rook is hanging F5 is
threatened and the wheels are coming off
completely the knights are woefully
incapable of Defending all the
weaknesses F5 resigns and rookies
how about that I'm on Rook takes D2 and
queen E1 after F5
beautiful beautiful the wheels are
coming off as you mentioned G3 is going
to be hanging Rook D2 tactic Magnus has
started this portion emphatically not
only did you need a win but you needed
to win precisely in the style I'm pretty
stunned that he didn't find uh Rook
takes D2 he has a little bit of work to
do here and after seeing the previous
few games uh Amman can you blame me for
you know still being a little bit on
edge
you have four connected passport I think
Magnus needs five you know maybe even
six to just to be safe you know
nights are tricky pieces but 4.9 seconds
and a dream is all Hikaru Nakamura has
here he's gonna play Knight D5 he's
gonna you know box out that that Rook to
claim a basketball term here and King G7
and push the H Pawn I think you want to
pawn as far as possible from those
Knights you want to go G5 H5 H4 just
indiscriminately start pushing your
pawns because White's Knights are are
stuck in place if you move the D5 Knight
away you lose the other one the other
night on E5 had no squares there's
nothing left to play for and the way
that he won that game is so encouraging
for Magnus fans he went back to what he
does best playing intuitively putting
pressure on all sides of the board and
on the clock
yep and he's back to a position that
he's had success with so I'm sure that
he'll be happy to be here but obviously
if Hikaru is repeating he's probably
checked this position out I think if I'm
thinking back to the the beginning of
this three plus one section did we not
have that insanely nice attacking game
by Hikaru and was like what a way to
start remember Pawn F3 I think that was
the first game and now first game after
the break it's Magnus who comes back and
says okay I'm a different person here I
got a new shirt on don't forget and it's
hard for me to even say this but 45
minutes into the start of this 60 Minute
segment comes magnus's first win I mean
not only do we not say that every day
we've never said that I mean we expect
don't say that at all we don't say that
we might never even say it again so you
know taking this match while it's going
I don't love the kinds of positions that
Hikaru has gotten out of the opening
which is also a weird thing to say
because it's an end game but it's also
an opening can Magnus open up the king
side with G4 and F5 can he create
connected passers
I think that Magnus is playing with the
kind of energy right now that that's
exactly what he's gonna do uh there's
one defensive idea if crazy call it a
defensive idea but if you didn't play
them with G4 black would actually play
H5 themselves and stop to move G4 which
would stop the move F5 which would halt
the E5 Pawn so it doesn't look like much
but H5 I consider to be a real threat
there and if you play it now you're not
in time to stop F5 Rook F1 Magnus is not
gonna miss this chance to push no and E6
here he can push now the other Pawn
forcing the Knight away and then play F5
now what is Hikaru banking on he's
banking on a dark Square blockade on F6
the issue is that he can hold these
pawns down for a while but eventually
when White's Knight joins in the action
through G4 which I think is a square
that will be opened up after the trade
it's only a matter of time to me until
Carlson can set his Pawns in motion once
again
that's right and remember there's no
pass Pawn coming from this four on three
over here so it's basically two
connected pass pawns a rook that can't
join The Fray and yeah you mentioned it
we might just see a bunch of pieces
trade and although we won't see the
pawns crash through and make a queen
immediately long term I mean White's
just gonna bring the king up to the
center H5 I think has to be tried to
prevent Knight G4 at all costs you have
to prevent F6 but now Carlson will
switch to a slow burn approach and this
exact thing this Slow Burn technical
conversion is what we are used to seeing
him do flawlessly he's also struggled
with it mightily in this portion so this
is a big game also from a confidence
perspective can Magnus convince himself
that yeah I'm still Magnus Carlson and I
still win these types of games smoothly
or will Hikaru pull out yet another
crazy comeback in the end game
yeah I was thinking Rook H4 is kind of a
it's almost like he baited that like
Rook F4 and now Exquisite Rook here and
you know as tempting as Rook h8 Knight
G4 is I think it's smart to play King H1
first maybe because I'm worried about
Rook G8 but Knight G4 is such a
beautiful you know geometric move pins
Galore and King h1omon is also a great
move because you're preparing Rook G1
and Rook G7 so Hikaru I think trying to
defend from the G5 square but the moment
The Rook is kicked away from the G file
that Rook on F1 is going to find Green
Pastures to continue a uh a sub theme of
today's commentary on G7 which is a
green Square
that's right Rook G5 and you can't quite
Kick The Rook out it's like a little bit
annoying yes you can play Bishop C1 but
then you remove the possibility of
Bishop takes Knight in Rook H5 you can
play Rook G1 with a drop that pawn and
then Knight F3 but you drop F5 so it's
not that easy
in Rook hf4 preparing to involve the
Knight he rolls out the red carpet you
know the airplane has arrived and where
is that Knight going from F3 well that's
the big question G6 comes to mind
because if you can kick away the bishop
on E7 then you remove the wrong Jenga
block and the whole Tower comes crashing
down which I think is gonna happen I
would have played Knight H4 though he's
allowed Bishop D6 and I think that's a
small imprecision giving Hikaru a little
bit more latitude on the king side but
look at this Knight G6 anyway and 97
Knight G8 wins
which might be good enough but this is
even better this is the Magnus that we
know he didn't just win this he won this
with a lot of room to spare now he can
take either minor piece I would take on
F4 because the Knight is much worse than
the bishop it's stopping these passers
totally and after you take here you have
the perfect setup your pawns are on
light squares and your Bishop controls
the opposite color complex on the dark
Square so you can play F6 F7 and the
pawns cannot be stopped he could have
flirted with the immediate F6 but what
is the point of that you can just move
your Rook back you can play C4 you can
play F6 this one is a couple of moves
away from its conclusions hikara might
resign right here there's just nothing
left with which to stop these passers
he wants you know F7 Rook takes E6 f8 In
Your Wildest Dreams exactly oh not gonna
happen well we see a rook sack on G8
followed by F7 like Knight f8 E7 96 and
Rook G8 forces The Rook away from E8
that's what we're missing that's the
cherry on top and I think we're gonna
see it I think the gods are gonna grant
us a rook sack at the end
nope well there was it was impossible
because of Knight takes F6 actually
Knight takes F6 and well I was actually
starting to think of uh you know the
gamesmanship in Hikaru because why else
would he be playing this on right he's
already playing the clock and with 10
minutes left in the three minute portion
I think you're at that threshold where
every minute starts to become important
and I actually think Hikaru wants to get
into the bullet ASAP
yeah I'm just gonna point out here uh
Bishop takes C5 in a terrible terrible
mistake Rook takes C5 keep the king cut
off now Magnus you gotta preserve the
seconds here what are we talking about
and maybe avoid stalemating with a queen
A7
Queen E8 mate is coming up and Hikaru
has gotten to the point where he is
checkmated in two moves he can still go
King F1
um so he does have a safe move
and he's gonna take a solid 90 seconds
off the match clock with uh uh with with
this gamesmanship as you called it and
and look say what you want about it but
this is the precise thing that got
Hikaru the win last time
right so I mean and it was so literally
the fact that he had done this earlier
in the match that you know later on in
the bullet segment when it came down to
one win it was like two seconds remember
two seconds that he had taken off the
clock earlier and that's why he won and
I'm gonna be dead honest with you man
this is what I truly think
Hikaru in the past he's had some
questionable antics you know he
sometimes gets emotional after losses
but this milking the clock when you're
up on the match and you want to get to
your best segment as quickly as possible
is a completely legitimate strategy he's
maximizing his chances of Victory and
what do we truly want from the players
in this match you know do we want some
imaginary concept of chivalry or do we
want the players to maximize their
chances of success I think it's still
the latter
yep yep and and you know everyone is
well within their right to to do that
you know it's not it's not something
that's just reserved for him
um but I think because he's so talented
in the bullet segment that we see him
maybe more than others uh do it and it
it's just because of his prowess there
and it's easy to say I don't know what
I'll be doing with those 30 seconds that
we're waiting for Hikaru to let us clock
run out but I think we're all gonna
survive and will Magnus survive another
Sicilian Hikaru going for a slightly
weird line I don't like the bishop on C4
it's just kind of biting on granite so I
would consider dropping it back to D3
and maybe opening up the diagonal with
E5 of course Magnus could beat him to
the punch with D6 but not right now
because he would drop your dark squared
Bishop to B4
yeah and I think that's exactly why I
like the move C3 because I want to play
Bishop D3 but no need to drop the bishop
pair or hand it over so C3 and now you
can bring the bishop back but more
trades introduced by Magnus here
it does feel very equal
indeed and the Knights are gonna get
swapped here Bishop F4 possible but
instead hecaro trades immediately just
to kind of I mean given that this came
from a sicilian this is very vanilla
it is
um there there's also this A6 pawn it
feels like nothing right now but it's
actually very annoying for Magnus like
you can't just play Rook da go D5 or
something you will need to probably play
the move A5 at some point
um which you know it's not the worst
move but it's a move that he has to
spend indeed and how is Hikaru going to
arrange his pieces I mentioned Bishop D3
earlier he plays it now and the Big
Moment of Truth will we see D5 or will
we see a slower approach like A5 and D6
I think it's in magnus's style to push
D5 he's shown it a willingness to change
the structure and create tension
especially in the last couple of games
where we see the more confident Magnus
that made an appearance at the start of
the match I think we're gonna see D5 and
likely a bunch of trades in the center
yep and it's important to remember that
the pawn on F2 is stuck you can't just
respond with you know F4 E5 and close
things up the only way to get that to
happen well you know ping pongs they
can't move ah that rule it was
introduced uh I was uh I was aware of
drinking some lemonade all right go
ahead it's time that Hikaru Nakamura was
not the SCC Champion puns could play to
F4 here I remember that time too and D5
is on the board after a sizable thing
will we see a bunch of trades on e4 and
another end game yes sir
why the heck not I definitely see why
Hikaru wants to play this I mean if
you're Magnus you're not gonna shy away
from something like this you know you're
not significantly worse but I do think
that the queen side majority if there's
just the slightest of advantages or
preferences I would take white because
of that I totally agree I'm on it I like
to point out in such situations that the
side with the smaller Pawn majority has
an easier time creating the past Pawn
when I say smaller I don't mean smaller
like you have less of a pawn majority
smaller numerically it's a three on two
versus a four on three on the king side
and if it's a two on one then it's
really easy to create a passer if it's a
two on three all you have to do is play
B4 C4 and C5 whereas for black the
distance between these actual pawns yeah
is a lot wider but all of this is a moot
point as long as you have a bunch of
pieces on the board because it's really
really hard for white in practice to
actually set his Pawns in motion without
creating weaknesses
that's right and you know I think the
king placement also contributes to why I
feel uh like the key Carver's position
is uh pretty nice here and so Magnus is
looking to equalize that and immediately
get the king into the middle of the
board it just it's one of those things
that needs to happen eight ASAP
and we have Rook to C4 threatening OC
car was threatening anything about him
having a hard time uh perceiving you
know if there's any threat with this
move
yeah well whether or not there was and
we'll never know the move B5 has been
played to kick the Rook out B5 was
played before before
and will B4 be played before before
I think before will be played
before before because
B5 could go to before before and before
we say anything further we need to cover
the moves actually played in the game
Bishop B3 by Hikaru and guess what he's
done he has reduced the size of his Pawn
majority again to a two on one now all
he needs to do is play B3 and C4 so
maybe we'll get C4 before B4
I I hope so because I have the perfect
emote to drop on that square Dania let
me tell you so and Hikaru has the
perfect piece to drop on A7 that would
be a rook and he is making moves here
yeah don't ship drops back to E3 and
King D3 this is actually the pawn
structure you don't want to see whoa
whoa whoa whoa
before before before
and we will get C takes before Rook C2
check that's what he's banking on but
Keynes E3 and King C3 I think was
overlooked by Carlson oh and King C2 we
have to show this line CB amazing Rook
C2 this is crucial King D3 Rook takes B2
King C3 now what's obviously can't take
on before but Rogue B1 seems to keep the
tension as you're showing him on uh this
line but Rogue B1 King C2 was overlooked
by Magnus and you're in huge trouble
because of this tactic and the bishop
picks off The Rook before before
that is amazing and
King D3 a Miss of course a Miss what I
guess because if you had gone to D1 you
could have gone to C1 and maybe that's
marginally better I still think King C3
and King C2 is a great winning chance
he's missed it
wow and I think what that line actually
was was that King to C1 actually trapped
the rook and forced him to take whoa
that was a big moment but Magnus still
has to be a little bit careful here
White's got the more active rook and the
better practical chances yeah
by the way we've seen 0.00 we've seen
you know Magnus be in these Rook end
games and guess what Hikaru Nakamura is
the guy who can turn these into wins so
just be careful if you're Magnus because
you have to just admit you have lost
these before whoa pretty scary and now
you've got to take with a pawn if you
take with the Rook white gets trousers I
think most people in the chat will know
that term now said it many times a
Russian Chester I'm referring to two
past pawns on either side of the board
that can't be stopped and G3 is super
precise chess he's gonna use his Jeep on
as a counterweight to prevent White's
Pawn from reaching H7 fast enough
yeah and you'll definitely see King E4
here trying to get it but even if the
black pawns were not on the board it
would be a draw so actually it's the
presence of the pawns that maybe it
gives you shaky feet here man I think
the eval bar is developing a disturbing
cough might it have
tuberculosis I think it's it's TB early
onset oh it's tpd whether it has TB but
the TB is indicating a draw and Hikaru I
think he sensed that he had a chance
there big big game and an even bigger
game to conclude the three minute
portion I'm on the bullet is going to be
one of the most epic match segments I
think we're ever gonna see
it really will and you know there's
obviously it could be said about any
match you know there's a difference
between going in with the score tide or
one player has the lead but between
these two guys where you know there's
never really been uh that much of a
difference between them at one point
that one game a half a point makes all
the difference so yeah you could talk
about momentum but strictly based on the
score and how narrowly close these
matches have been yeah this game's
important you're totally right and this
is giving me shades of the Nakamura mvl
match where Hikaru was down by two going
to the final game of this portion and he
managed to win it and that really really
set the tono obviously he dominated all
across the bullet but if Magnus could
tie the matcher man would that go a long
way toward filling him with a lot of
momentum and right now this is
resembling last year's match where the
score going to the bullet I think was
something like a one or two point lead
only for Hikaru we have a transformation
here in the real Lopez the car was let's
put his Knight on E7 as opposed to F6 as
has been standard in their games thus
far
yeah and also the trade on E5 I think
the position last time we saw this
featured you know some rather strange
like Knight A5 uh you know B5 sorts of
positions Instead This one is much more
calm all around and I think Magnus is
probably happy here with a stable
position that he knows he could not be
worse in especially as the final game in
this segment it feels like a position
where if you want to draw to go to the
bullet uh you know Nakamura would
certainly acquiesce so uh you know
magnus's game to to play it looks like
for sure and Hikaru has to decide on
which side of the board he's going to
operate B5 is a tempting move but you're
also introducing long-term weaknesses on
the queen side as we know white will
have the typical a2a4 strike you can go
on the other side and I think the move
your car is turning over in his head is
actually G5 potentially even followed by
F5 but that also allows Avenues to be
opened up such as the queen dropping
back to B3 with a check I'm definitely
surprised at the move C6 that is ultra
committal and Ultra risky because look
at the D6 Pawn
totally yeah this immediately makes me
think of like the direct approach Rook
D1 uh the pawn is loose and pinned so
the queen has the side step but you know
it introduces options for white to play
Queen B4 Bishop G3 E5 with the right
amount of pressure on the E7 Square this
can turn very dangerous and some really
basic moves that Magnus needs to play
right these aren't like you know out of
these world moves it's like Rook 8.1
let's go and I'm surprised he's not
playing them he's taking a large chunk
of his time here obviously he's figuring
out the right way to arrange his pieces
but I could just start with Rook D1 and
Bishop G3 and then think he's played it
he's got so many easy ways to increase
the pressure on the pawn bishop G3 Queen
B4 double Rooks on the D file he could
do all three of those successively
instead he expands first on the king
side that's such a typical Magnus move
again playing on both sides of the board
it's been a theme of this match it's a
theme featuring in all high level
matches and games
yeah and this actually not only maybe
has the idea of H5 in the future but it
really restricts black from that G5 idea
G5 F5 no longer exists there's no G5
Knight G6 and black could maybe try to
play for the E5 Square so the Knight on
E7 is restricted maybe it's going to be
reduced to Knight C8 which is totally
surely a defensive task and Knight C8
relinquishes the grip on the F5 score so
Magnus perfectly timing them of H5
Hikaru doing everything possible to
avoid playing G5 and allowing that
Knight on F3 to sink its teeth into the
delicious F5 Square I think you have to
go G5 though uh by hook or by crook you
have to keep the F5 Square protected and
after white plays Knight D4 the problem
is that the Rook loses contact with the
D6 Square so black actually can return
to E7 of the Knight Hikaru still holding
on
yeah the Knight on C8 is like it's
actually the only thing uh keeping him
in the game because it's guarding the D6
pawn and when the F5 squares threatened
it's guarding the I5 Square so without
that Knight on C8 big problems in this
position for Hikaru it looks easy for
Magnus to play oh what he's offering
maybe a trade and Hikaru could have
snagged that Knight off the board now he
doesn't have that chance anymore he also
could have tried D5 but I think Hikaru
is actually comfortable with this Pawn
structure he's telling himself Magnus is
burning a lot of clock and he hasn't
found a way to win the D6 Pawn yet let's
just kind of keep the status quo and
maybe Magnus will overpress
I don't know if that's the way to to do
it though because like you want to play
D5 but I think you're going to need to
recapture with a pawn there
agreed and instead he's gone B5 sending
the Knight either back to E3 and again
we're gonna see this Knight E7 classic
but Knight A5 is also very tempting
attacking that new Target on C6 that's a
more magnus-esque move I think no he
drops back to E3 okay
I think 97 Rook D well you have D2 D3 he
goes on a light Square just good good
practice there and after D5 he wants to
play Rook D1 and the pawns are gonna
find themselves on fixed dark squares
for a potential end game maybe with just
arcs were Bishops but D4 Hikaru slides
this Pawn through B4 preventing C5 what
a move obviously the Knight is
Untouchable there because the Rook on D7
will hang
and Magnus
keeping the status quo here with A3 he
could have taken A5 but I think he's
trying to surround the d-pawn with the
move Knight E3 to C2 which is a big
Threat by the way
yeah and the the moves here that are
possible Knight D5 just to showcase the
pure Insanity of how many things are
hanging in that position F5 has a
similar idea Knight C2 there would have
picked off the D4 Pawn I think that was
a big Miss by Magnus he takes the pawn
on F5 instead but Hikaru
oh my gosh no there's Rook takes G7 in
the end and Bishop Bishop B2 but the
king could sidestep but you could go to
f8 Bishop D6 on takes Bishop D6 we're
gonna have to show this after the game
or yeah might play the move no
the time is too low we have to stay with
the action now it doesn't exist anymore
that was an insane line of mine we
promised to show this after the game no
matter how the game finishes feels like
Magnus is in the driver's seat he can
support the F Pawn with G4 that's very
scary remember Bishop D4 Rook d8 you
can't just rush and take that and that's
why Magnus bringing his King up to E2
supporting the Rooks playing for a win
big trouble also on the clock he's got
seven seconds and so many weaknesses to
defend here
yeah the king is going to be improved
maybe all the way over to B3
BC
just take it
oh he didn't walk into a permanent pin
but he doesn't want to do it but Bishop
takes him yeah and Bishop F6 there was
easy Magnus allowing Hikaru to get
active again
good point
rookie 86 is coming though
okay now it's suddenly a three result
game again I mean Magnus could lose
control of this game and let that deep
on through
ooh that I didn't expect that looks like
a good but for a K5 it's not hanging
what a move Rook B6 maybe surround the B
Pawn and now a trade
check it looks like keeping both Rooks
on the board was maybe more dangerous oh
D3 oh the king comes up
sending the king back and Magnus has to
find a way to infiltrate hikaru's
blockade
oh rookie too
D3 oh my gosh
who has to be careful here oh my
goodness Rook F2 and he's gonna win the
F3 pawn and I think Hikaru might hold
this yep because if if the Rook could
get to E4 that would be different
and hikara holding the e-file he cannot
let the king infiltrate E6 so this is
incredible he's hanging on by an actual
threat and he's doing it incredibly well
he just goes rookie one rookie two I
don't think Magnus has an easy way to
make progress if you're Carlson six
rookie four careful where you put your
pieces
yeah Rook G4 was too risky though I
agree with Hikaru stay on the e-file and
that's your defensive method and I think
we're gonna get a draw Magnus just not
finding a single way to pose for other
problems I don't think such a way exists
he can't put anything on the e-file he
car is too solid I think Rook D4 is a
reasonable try yeah bring the Rook here
so at least that's taken care of but he
does it in a moment when Bishop E7 can
be played Bishop D4 Rook D1 pinning the
bishop moving the king back Magnus keeps
finding newer and newer ways to pose new
problems but Hikaru believes The Rook
end game is drawn and it is
especially with the King cut off this
way if the King was on D4 difference
you know he's lost King G6 F6 it's over
it's an umbrella he's using the pawns as
a shield this is a loss oh my goodness
how many turnarounds F7 there was
winning on the spot
as does this
and it's actually the presence of the
pawn that makes it a win because
otherwise black can play Rook takes F6
check and stalemate
and Hikaru is annoyed he's irritated and
he has lost a critical game allowing
Magnus to tie the match
I'll give you the choice I'm on we can
show that amazing line earlier or we can
show how Magnus was able to turn this
game around at the end your call
I think we we stick with what happened
uh stick with what's fresh this
ultimately was uh the turnaround point I
think it is uh instructive because it it
looked like a total draw and Hikaru was
making it a total draw he was defending
on seconds on his clock the entire time
I mean that alone is such a tough task
especially against Magnus Carlson who's
you know right right up in your grill
trying to tie this match and look at
this the King was cut off Dania and I
mean what what do you think here you
just had to leave The Rook on the e-file
right well rookie six was an incredible
practical move by Carlson and what
Hikaru had to do was defend laterally he
had to play the move Rook to A1 and the
point of that move is that after Rook A1
King E4 uh it's not even easy for me and
I'm you know I see the eval bar King G7
apparently was the only move prevent
what you have to do is prevent the white
king from reaching F6 if it reaches E5
you can now start giving the lateral
checks Rook A5 Rook A6 wherever the King
goes you pursue him but how hard is this
to figure out with two seconds Hikaru
made the natural move Rook G1 he thought
I'm tying myself to the G Pawn the king
can't move but it can and it moves to F6
yeah and now the white piece activity
overwhelms Black's defenses all credit
to Magnus how does he do this
it's amazing and the presence of Black's
g-pawn is the reason that this position
is actually lost I mean it having that
pawn here otherwise you could play
rotates F6 with a stalemate but that
guy's working for the other team
be still my biting heart I'm on that's
all I have to say and what we have to
say for you folks is that we have 30
minutes of bullet to decide the SEC
final this match is all tied at nine a
piece and we are about to have some of
the most epic half an hour of action
ever but before we go on break and set
the players up for bullet we wanted to
remind you and take a moment to thank
ag1 a new partner of the SCC ag-1 is
your daily support of key Health
functions from mental performance to
energy and the immune system it's the
one product that does the work of many
to find out more visit drinkag1.com
chess or use x Glam ag1 we think age you
won for sponsoring the SEC well we'll
let the players drink their ag-1 and
they'll need a lot of it because the SEC
returns to determine a winner we have 30
minutes of bullet coming up and we will
be back with more Hikaru vs Magnus
action in just a couple moments
thank you
we first thought that we had experienced
the chest boom that had washed Over Us
in 2019 at the end of 2018 kind of going
into 2019 we kind of looked at ah well
that was guys that was the chest boom
and oh we're a new level we completely
it was kind of then but then like
literally like covet happened we were
ramping up
so quickly in each country that locked
down Italy India but you could see the
registrations flying through as each
country locked down and it was all
happening so fast there was no like oh
this is so cool this was like oh my gosh
we're going to uh we literally couldn't
keep up and so there was no like
positive coolness out of this it wasn't
until like
we were into the you know pandemic and
then like several months and we're like
oh wow this okay well during the
pandemic more people are gonna play
chess they will die back down nope then
came POG Champs and what Dean talked
about and we're like oh my gosh then
okay after that no okay and then came
Queen's gambiter like all right well
that was definitely the peak and then
the media started writing about Chess
and then okay where is it gonna stop we
have been if you watching him three
you're just gonna get away after wave
after wave and then there's the stuff in
the media now which is like wave and
like we almost can't even come up the
breath fast enough to recognize this
before there's like another wave coming
from this point on we just don't know
what to expect is there another way of
coming probably
[Music]
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest outcome account it's just tap and
play head over to go.chess.com iMessage
or use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
has built his lead up and in additional
three-point lead he's got a really nice
position in this game he has to rush
this like he's never rushed before
yep 10 seconds here comes up
you missed it I match it's a tide match
the car should play for a win look at
the clock should and he knows it and he
does it the car will go in it away there
was a blunder would be six yeah this
part is promoting he allowed the queen
in the party you see it on magnus's face
he knows that does it it's not a
coronakamura defended his bullet just
championship title oh my goodness that
was a Clash of Titans
[Music]
he is the 2023 bullet chess champion he
defeated Magnus Carlson in one of the
most incredible matches that we have
seen quadruple over time and Hikaru
stands all tied up with Magnus the score
is nine to nine and the speed Chess
Championship final presented by coinbase
we welcome everybody who has been up
with us from the start and we welcome
everybody who's just joined you come in
at a great time Grandmaster him on
Hamilton we see a lot of three-letter
words that start with w and end with n
hmm I think I can figure this Flint out
although uh my wordal needs a little
more practice uh yeah I the most notable
one there comes at the end Magnus
Carlson also a familiar name now this is
the perfect opportunity for Magnus to
get his quite literal Revenge because
this is hikaru's wheelhouse Magnus
Carlson you know Undisputed you know the
greatest player maybe of all time but
certainly right now but guess what in
bullet Hikaru Nakamura is something else
and even Magnus knows he respects
hikaru's ability in bullet and we got a
great reminder of that in hikaru's
semi-final match against mvl Nakamura
was down a point going into the bullet
he won that match by five he was
dominant from wire to wire and the
biggest mistake by hikaru's admission
that mvo made is that he played too
quickly this is not one plus zero this
is one plus one and what you want to
avoid doing is over adjust start out by
playing too fast and end with a minute
on your clock Magnus Carlson is one of
the best at adjusting to the new demand
to the new constraints of the time
control folks the score is nine to nine
we have 30 minutes of one plus one
action my voice is quivering and this I
mean was there ever any doubt that we
were going to be tied going into the
bullet was there ever an actual doubt I
mean it helps that you know it's all
scripted anyway for an unbelievable
finale and surprise surprise that we're
gonna get it in bullet Queen A5 this
very trendy move and we are off in the
bullet portion here but that plus one is
gonna give Magnus a chance to hang with
a bullet Pro lucky card early signs
Magnus playing the first Karo Khan of
the match clearly indicating that with
black he wants to play uh as solidly as
possible he wants to get structures that
you're familiar with and that becomes
more important in the bullet at the end
of The Blitz he wants structures that
you can play intuitively as Hikaru
they're setting up a devilish threat of
Bishop takes H6 and you know faking
Magnus out Bishop C7 is a big threat and
I think yukaro's got the initiative
early in this game
and look you're willing to actually make
moves like Knight H4 Bishop H7
um just Knight back to F3 that's
something that you would probably frown
at in a Blitz game but in bullet no
you're comfortable just probing around
and not necessarily worried about every
single move and Magnus continuing to
steer the game in the direction that
makes him comfortable now he repeats
moves with Queen G6 and queen F5 he can
play G5 and force this bishop off
instead he expands on the other side of
the board and Hikaru does the same in
the center Queen B5 now threatens A4
Magnus says I'm not taking hikaru's
initiative sitting down
yeah I mean Bishop H6 is one of the
moves to look at but it doesn't really
come with the next move Bishop E5
however Pawn is loose as well I'm on
that's a knife especially in bullet
because trading on E5 and dropping your
queen back I think Magnus might have to
go for that line but giving up F7 ouch
the entire house of cards might come
down in the center but Magnus has to
bite the bullet here what happens after
Queen takes F7 is it A4
Queen B6 exclamation mark an A4 great
move by Carlson very heads up targeting
all of White's Pawns in the center and
we're gonna get a Pac-Man game here
pretty shortly
and you could take that but you could
also take on E6 the thing with E6 is
that that apron actually might be
dangerous down the line Magnus could
have thrown in Rook f8 for starters but
that would have involved giving up the
E6 Pawn speaking of Pac-Man who's gonna
take more pawns here I think it's
actually gonna be white uh in the end
white might emerge with an extra a pawn
and a weak Pawn on E6
wow that's quite a move there sort of
walking into it almost but Queen D2 is
the next move and these Rooks yeah they
defend each other but they can't move in
a Blitz game you would take White's
position with open arms but in the
bullet segment you have to defend
against all these annoying threats black
has a bit of an initiative on the king
side he can also drive his e-pawn up to
E4 potentially and Magnus is a gross he
now slipped what was that
what did he mostly no it wasn't a mouse
up he was expecting Queen takes C6 and
he was hovering over that square what
are you doing you've got 15 seconds yeah
that's uh that's such a classic type of
bullet blender not a mouse lip as you
said but just you expect a queen to show
up there and when any piece shows up on
E6 you're ready to take it yeah you
can't prevent your like animal brain
from executing the move the problem
isn't that it's that Magnus was hovering
over that square trying to do a little
bit too much that time and after an
amazing job navigating a dubious
position Magnus drops his Queen and he
drops the first bullet game
and man oh man does he need to strike
back in this one
he does like that's quite literally the
worst way to start this uh segment uh
however I do like his position here I
think in bullet uh for the white pieces
especially looking at that F5 Square I
think he's got a pretty good practical
position very promising as he heads back
to E1 with his other Knight and Hikaru
there with B5 trying to prevent the D2
knight uh from getting to the E3 square
that is ideal real estate because you're
accessing both F5 and D5 and I think we
are going to see Knight C2 by Magnus but
look at what he car was doing him on he
is trying to play really really actively
to compensate for his lack of control in
the center and he's doing an amazing job
of it so far
yeah even though um I like what Hikaru
has done here I still think that Magnus
is kind of executing this long-term
positional plan uh and that Bishop if it
gets left over with some pawns on the
same color I I actually really like the
way this is going for Magnus God he's
faked us out so many times but finally
we see Knight C2 E3 is not the only
Transit point you can also fly through
the B4 International Airport and he
actually recaptures with the pawn yeah I
agree him on B3 might be coming soon but
Rook D6 and he's blundered because if
you trade you blunder the fork on D2 oh
yeah it's happening anyway oh my gosh
it's just lost Pawn takes
the knights hit and Knight D2
and the decision to take back with the
pawn was a really bad one here comes the
other night bang bang bang and Hikaru is
crushing Magnus in the end game
I think uh you know the the secrets out
it was not the shirt it was the it was a
blitz shirt I think he needed to put his
bullet shirt on maybe the original shirt
and now Madness is dropping everything
Knight takes G2 and Knight to D2
yeah and C takes before was when the
wheels came off Magnus outsmarting
himself there Iman
a little bit yeah that almost looked uh
like too cute too fancy
whoa BC huh BC and Hikaru wants to go C3
he's taken with a bishop
what's going on here okay Bishop back
now and then C2 Rook A1 Rooks seems like
unnecessary by both sides there it was
something very strange was going on in
this game Hikaru goes for the send game
he's gonna go A3 I think
but Bishop D2 was an amazing move
because after A2 King B2 you dropped the
a pawn and Magnus finds the most
complicated move of all instantly
incredible he had he had it all planned
it's a draw how did he say that
he's gonna play H4 King E6 I would have
said first but yes just gonna be a draw
here oh that's a huge huge save Hikaru
might extend this game though as long as
possible you're not really it's I mean
you can milk the clock you're only up a
point but this would be consistent with
his strategy
yeah I would say here don't really know
if that's his Strat because he's I mean
he's confident in bullet right he says
he's not trying to shy away from
anything no no but he is showing a
desire to extend this game as long as
possible I think if you're Hikaru you do
want this to go down to the wire you you
thrive in these high pressure situations
and so he's going to get another 30
seconds 45 seconds off the clock also
Magnus is the one who has to remain on
his toes because the Knight is the more
dangerous piece in these situations
or will Magnus make me eat my words
you said what yeah nothing nothing yet
you heard something maybe you need to
replace your headphones I have five by
Hikaru still trying
yeah he can extend this game he's gonna
be able to play Knight F4 E4 if you want
so uh match strategy clearly uh revealed
well eight minutes have already been
lopped off the match clock yukara wins
the first bullet game I thought we were
on like game one or two here what's
going on no we were still on break a
second ago and now there's 22 minutes
left this is what Hikaru is going for
and is he trying to lose the skin King
D5 yeah he has to be a little careful
here girl oh nice he's barely surviving
this he's down to like having to find
only moves now but he is finding them
yeah that's that he does that you know
sometimes once in a while come on I'm on
don't overstate the case here this isn't
the SEC finals or anything oh
wow so clever
he's won a pawn how I don't know
C5 uh Bishop to d8 got it
now suddenly White's the one who has to
be careful Knight F4 is coming it really
feels like something all night up too
he's gonna win
or is he
regardless of whether he's going to win
it's phenomenal that he's done what he's
done
how is he up upon from from
it's it's
watch the moves I see the moves I for my
brain processes the moves and I still
can't understand how we have a
two-on-one and and the worst thing is
Hikaru can now milk another minute off
the clock that's right and Knight E5
threatened
yep and he can just Shuffle that Knight
around there's no big urgency
that's such a that's such a devilish
little move because Magnus could have
very easily pre-moved a king move there
totally hold it now but it's still hard
Hikaru getting his King around
yeah King F5 Bishop E5 there's some H3
Knight F4 stuff and finally Magnus is
gonna bag the H3 pawn and bag the G5
pawn and force this game this
never-ending game to end and Hikaru is
still keeping the pawn on the board
and now wait five seconds and then take
the queen maximum squeeze
totally and let's let's not uh sugarcoat
it that wasn't just a maximum squeeze uh
in a gamesmanship way uh no he was
playing for a win there in case you
forgot and he was briefly winning
according to the eval bar if he had
moved the Knight to F2 but that ship has
sailed and they repeat an opening that
we saw quite a bit in the three minute
portion of Sicilian with a bishop on C3
I don't love the way this starts for
Hikaru I mean Magnus just seems to have
gotten a very very nice setup here
yep yep A3 and C3 you can see the
desperation to get that Bishop back to
C3
get rid of that pawn Magnus and Magnus
says no I will not
Bishop E3 I mean again hoping to
have B takes C3 played I I still feel
like Magnus is really really happy with
how this has started but he's got to
figure out a way to protect the D7 Pawn
either directly or indirectly as he's
done now he can castle look at this
tactical awareness I'm on Queen takes D7
Rook d8 traps the queen that's such a
hard idea to see in bullet and it was
because of Queen B8 covering the the C7
Square so he totally planned that I
would put the queen on C7 though to give
the Rook a little bit more latitude
along the eighth rank maybe later you
can play Rook A8 Magnus burning a lot of
clock here and this is what he was
spending it on
what a sacrifice and e-force hanging the
B3 Bishop is under Fire hikar's got to
be really careful to keep his position
together here
yeah maybe okay yeah this is probably
more what Magnus was looking for two
Bishops imbalance Pawn structure don't
take with a knight don't take with the
Knight Bishop A4 wins the piece any Karu
sees it
yeah but this is fantastic for the
Bishops right
that's exactly what you want Magnus this
is precisely the kind of position that
we're used to seeing him winning
regularly by the bishop C6
yeah the Knight B5 Bishop C6 Knight F3
you could just take it I think that's
uh he wants to play the Bishops because
there was one school of thought you know
just take Rook takes B3 but maybe that
position is just objectively very hard
to win well Magnus wants to take Hikaru
to school in the send game and I think
he thinks among that you can win the B3
Pawn on demand so he wants to extract
more out of the position maybe milk
White's clock down but he's milking his
own clock down as a result
F5 F4
okay it's gonna just defend for now but
going very aggressive now Magnus has
overpressed before and he's over pressed
again or has he because Bishop F2 runs
into Rook A1 but there's the move B4 and
Hikaru missed it B4 would have kept the
C5 Pawn defended now it should be
technically winning for Carlson
he keeps the Rooks on I don't know
whether that was a chance to to trade it
off I I think you car made the right
choice though D5 now is going to come
with devastating effects look at Black's
Pawn Phalanx not over yet though
hikaru's Rook is very very active and if
you push your pawns prematurely Bishop
D4
wow is he just gonna try to like stay in
this position as okay he's giving H7 and
Rook A6 there's Rook B6 and that spells
trouble
but is this winning
it is
that was quick it is
but not easy look at Hikaru using every
last resource but he's just not fast
enough
King C2 now
oh
yeah Bishop E3 and Bishop remember
there's like this age Fawn Bishop
configuration on the H1 Square oh D2
apparently that was wrong E5
oh my gosh this is so close to a drawl
of a sudden H6 amazing wow but how do
you win this you do you get your king
back to G4 yeah C3 and now you just walk
and eventually you'll have to play G7
and then you're playing what these two
pawns against the bishop how does that
work I'm on I don't think I would have
found H6 in a classical game that is
inhuman to leave the protected passer on
G3 G7
and now it's finally completely winning
or is it not but yeah yeah you really
have to work again here though this is
wrong color Pond but he's gonna get the
bishop off
I mean that win was
truly insane we are looking at a match
between two of the best players in the
world and one of them happens Carlson
who's a wizard in the end game you talk
about hikaru's bullet prowess how about
magnus's end games considering that they
had 10 seconds on their clock no it
wasn't Flawless yes Hikaru almost got
back in the game which was incredible on
its own merits but the way that Magnus
found H6 and handled walked on hot coals
there is amazing we have another Lopez
and another King's indian-like structure
with a very early C5 Push by Magnus
yeah in another tied match and a half
ten and a half talk about it going down
to the wire we're halfway through this
match and guess what it has the makings
of that you know photo finish oh it
absolutely does you know this is going
to be a photo finish halfway through the
one minute portion
and Carlson sacking the Ponder Hikaru
could have advanced it to F4 and taken
on C5 but in the king's Indian Amman
this is a very standard way to sack in
order to open up the queen side now with
White's control over the E4 Square I
think Magnus has the upper hand
yeah and this um Bishop on E3 I mean it
makes sense to take but as soon as you
do the Knight will return to the D4
square that you once uh had covered yeah
it's like playing uh you know knockout
basketball you knock someone's ball out
they get angry and they're like I'm
gonna come back and knock your ball out
but Knight D4 doesn't tell the whole
story because white also controls the C
file there is am on the idea of an
exchange sacrifice on D4 potentially it
could go Rook C4 Rook takes D4 so I
still think Magnus Hikaru rather has the
shorter end of the stick and he's given
up H6 yeah and it looks like Knight D4
takes there was 92 but a lot of Pawns
fall in that position I actually think
practically this is a very hard position
for Magnus to handle
and he's handling it incredibly
didn't even realize it was hanging there
what a move Queen H4 he corresponded
that in like a nanosecond but he could
couldn't take on G6 there because of
Rook G3 Magnus secures the pawn and can
he go down the C file with Queen C3
Queen C7
fruit yeah going with the queen makes
more sense you actually have some
threats like Queen H7 there but you're
also giving away the F2 Pawn in the
process
G7 Hikaru allowing Queen C1 I think that
might win
yeah if the Rook goes to C8 it's over
but he decides to take however what do
you do about this Pawn this is a serious
problem Hikaru has to keep the D6 Pawn
protected Magnus helping himself to
another pawn queen takes A6 Hikaru doing
everything he can to open up whites King
but I think Magnus has enough back Queen
F1 and queen E1 in F1 that's the move
yeah that's totally winning too many
extra pawns here
now the queen has to go back and you can
basically serve up a distraction on the
a file Black's two pieces need to be
near the king sloppy there by Magnus
Queen to E6 would have been an easier
win he plays it now Hikaru could have
actually snagged the pawn on G7 but it
was lost anyway and Magnus is back on
top
wow just like that Magnus flips the
script if I'm remembering correctly
Hikaru started out with that win right
because Magnus you know effectively some
kind of brain slipped his Queen right
and that's how things started this is
how they're going and currently Magnus
has retaken that lead it probably feels
good because he hasn't had it in a while
which is crazy to say given how the
match started we're getting another end
game and an early going I'm on I'm not
suggesting that he covers bad at end
games but Carlson is getting exactly the
kinds of positions that he really really
wants in the last couple of games that's
right
that's right and now he carved down in
the match you know might have to shift
uh the strategy because what was working
for you before might not be applicable
anymore
but he's trying to work on black center
obviously black is the bishop pair but
the king Side Pawn structure is really
weak and the D5 Pawn is weak I think
we're gonna get some sort of major
liquidation here Rook takes D5 there's
Bishop to E6 so Magnus might actually
play down upon here for a bit oh Bishop
F4 almost wins an exchange but the
Knight blocks
yeah and you have to be careful of
Bishop E3 Pawn E3 it looks like you're
shattering white Pawn structure but the
bishop against the Knight is not
favorable for black so if white can
liquidate these pawns over here I think
B3 is not crazy just to make sure you
get that nasty a pond off the board oh
absolutely and that's precisely what
hikar will focus on I think a draw here
is likely although I keep saying that
and then crazy stuff keeps happening in
the end game we're gonna see the trade
on E3 no Magnus is playing for a win
here he's keeping both of his Bishops on
the board I think I'm on you called it I
would take and go B3 if I'm Hikaru yeah
same idea B3 now and okay this is what
I'm wondering is Magnus now not gonna
acquiesce to the draw because okay maybe
I'd prefer the Knight but do I prefer
the night when I'm down in the match
like playing this on for any reason so
I'm on I think as long as both Rooks are
on the board I actually prefer black
because his Rooks are more active I
think white is the one who has to
exercise caution now if the Knight lands
on H5 then the script flips as as you
said earlier but right now I think
Magnus is still playing this on the
merits of the position
right
yeah makes sense
or it needs to keep those Rooks on the
board and he goes back to A1 and he can
just move the king like King G6 or
something and and continue oh my
goodness 11 minutes left in the bullet
segment Hikaru down by one first of all
he needs to hold this position he cannot
afford a loss here and I think he's
doing an excellent job of defending this
essentially from a position of strength
I think it's time to repeat moves or is
Hikaru going for it now
I don't think he car is going I think
Magnus is saying hey you want to play
positions out let's play positions out
I'm happy to do it now that I have uh
the edge in the match and now he trades
Rooks this obviously increases the
likelihood of a drachikaru preventing F5
and fixing Black's pawns on weak squares
but that King on G6 is ideally placed to
keep everything under a lock and key
this one is going to liquidate
yeah I I immediately saw E4 and I was
like I'm not sure if I like that move
but if the the idea is to liquidate and
just get out of this game as fast as
possible it makes total sense it does
indeed Hikaru is still making threats
there
oh and she can take E6 and take F6 and
take G6 but that is a drone Rook end
game
and it's almost like if you get into
that end game Magnus is down upon but
he's happy because the game will go for
a while totally and look we're under 10
minutes in the match now a draw is all
but guaranteed and he are trying to keep
pieces on the board this move E5 tells
me that Hikaru is still entertaining
hopes of some sort of night Fork but
it's unrealistic yeah how I mean if you
move the Knight there's Rook E4 always
so it feels like uh there's just no
progress to be made and not to mention
the H Pawn is just loose and Hikaru
keeps trying to find ways uh to keep the
game going but it's finally a draw and
Magnus maintains his one point lead and
has the white pieces with which he's
been able to put major pressure in the
last segment of this match
and it goes without saying that with
less than 10 minutes to go don't think
of these bullet games Dania is like oh
two minutes for that game two minutes
for that game no these bullet games with
plus one second they can go five six
minutes remember we had a game that
looked like it was taking like six plus
minutes and we were like wait a minute
did this just segment just start
yeah this is not like the bullet brawl
where you can get 10 games in the last
five minutes and look at Hikaru I think
he of all people senses the urgency and
he says I'm going to go for magnus's
throat and I think he's doing a great
job of it Magnus has misplayed the
opening Queen E8 Queen H5 it's an easy
position to play and that is the main
thing which makes white have a
difficulty here
totally and look at this bishop takes C6
Hikaru doesn't care he says go ahead and
win that pawn I mean at this point I may
consider C5 but
um yeah he was happy to give it up and
play on what I was expecting to be the
king side but Magnus is trying to say
hey Focus over here don't forget about
my king Magnus is doing an amazing job
of deflecting Hikaru from the King side
to the queen side which he's opened up
and look at Magnus making strides and
trying to infiltrate Rook C7 with
threaten a potential mate on H7 and
Hikaru has to shoot the queen away but
down goes the pawn
and Rook takes D6 just as a practical
bullet move is right around the corner
so don't forget about that
Rook F6 that's a sad necessity for
Nakamura I think you're exactly right
keeping his Center protected but giving
Magnus an important Tempo that he uses
to bring his Rook back to the seventh
rank
maybe D5 although there is a rook C6
move yeah he gets out of the way that
the Rope needs to move
watch out Rook takes A2 I would throw
that in if I'm Hikaru just get rid of
that last pawn and now any in-game is
gonna be more defensible for black I
think he's making strides to take over
this game once again
Bishop H3 Knight H4 is a nice shot
and he plays it anyway and gets the
other Knight to F3 the F5 Square watch
out for that square if you're Hikaru
oh
this is really well played by Magnus
right now even though he might not be
maximizing his Advantage he just wants
to neutralize what hikar was trying to
drum up on the king side he definitely
has the initiative but Bishop E7 is such
a cagey move Look At That Knight on H4
it's kind of stranded and you're not
playing G3 anytime soon because that
loosens up the other night it's very
much a three result game
absolutely this is unclear to the max
Rook takes E7 I would take I would take
and just take D6 it's bullet just get
things off the board that was winning
him on because of the fork thread on G6
instead he puts Piggies on the seventh
and this is still very difficult for
Nakamura oh that's a depressing move to
play rookie eight sort of admitting that
the tactics aren't working for black but
Rook G7 is exquisite defensive play The
Rook on E8 is now guarded by the queen
but what do you do
everything is barely holding on tv7
there goes a minor piece that's hanging
is there is there Rook takes G2 oh my
gosh there's Rook H7 there as a result
Hikaru going all in sacking the piece
wow Queen D3 is gonna stabilize
amazing Queen D3 holds absolutely
everything Rook G3 there was a Ken Rook
H7 uh oh Queen H6 threatened Hikaru
defends the queen can shuttle
trampolining back and forth threatening
mates Galore Rook F7 training Rooks
winning
and he's gonna resign immediately
he knows he needs to resign he needs the
next game to get underway it's not full
panic mode yet but this game is super
important if it's a long drawn out game
especially if it's a draw this might be
it for Hikaru Nakamura I think he's now
officially thinking of this as a
must-win game and it's interesting to me
that he keeps repeating this weird
Bishop C4 line in the Sicilian now it
makes sense though because at the very
least you're guaranteeing an unbalanced
game
yep you and this is an improvement from
last time remember Bishop C3 those
positions weren't working out instead
he's going back to what has worked Queen
H5 he might be trying to really drum up
an attack and Magnus says and it goes
without saying that Nakamura keeps his
Queens on the board I like the setup a
lot more uh with his Pawn on C3 and more
space than he did in the previous
Sicilian game
but Magnus classic Sicilian maneuver and
now we have a more standard type of
sheven and gun structure
and there it is H4 it needs to happen
but we might see Knight H2 Rook D3 Rook
G3 uh I I like it from Nakamura he can
turn it on when when he needs a result
and look the attacking games have worked
for him against Magnus so far oh my
goodness pandemonium on the board we
keep seeing Magnus advance that d-pawn
but from a practical perspective I think
Rook G3 is an excellent move there's a
lot of threats to deal with and I'm on
don't sleep on the C2 Bishop white could
play e takes D5 and queen D3 and if the
blacking sidesteps to h8 I think that
might be a huge issue so he goes the
other way
yep
I wonder if it's time to remove this
bishop with Bishop G5 because you could
also just bring the bishop all the way
back you're not worried about Bishop D4
H6 is your next idea you're opening
things up and bringing the black king to
the center of the board where it's going
to be exposed and the best news yet is
that he calls 50 seconds on his caucus
Magnus with some questions move all
about Bishop takes B2 he wants Bishop
takes D4 and the C2 Bishop is gonna hang
but what I don't like about this move is
that Hikaru can ignore everything go H6
and Terra black to shreds on the king
side
looks scary and this is exactly where
Nakamura has found success attacking
magnus's King H7 H7 wow
but how do you continue from there Queen
B7 Queen B7 and Knight C6 and then
Knight C6 whoa wow
and he's gonna win Queen takes C8 is
winning you can give up E1 with check
and just sidestep with King H2 and the H
spawn Queens what the heck is Knight F5
trying to get black to play EF so white
could take the queen with track but
Queen takes H7 and Magnus is still in
the game
he doesn't see it Bishop A3
after Queen takes H7 it was winning but
it was still a game and hecaro wins the
first game on demand
and he I think maybe it is a wry smile
because he's like okay you know we got
exactly what the people want we got one
more game and I think it's still
possible that it could be a draw and we
get another game but highly unlikely
very good chance that this is the final
game of the match and a must win for
Hikaru Nakamura and he unbalances the
game immediately he plays E4 E5 but he
puts his Knight on E7 he tries to get
opposite side castling but he's already
in trouble because you can't Castle
short you're gonna drop the H6 Pawn so I
don't like what he's gotten here early
on the Knight can land on D5 this is a
Carlson type of position
it is but you know what you gotta cut uh
Hikaru some slack here because he needs
an imbalance position and sometimes you
have to just take a bad position
straight up and then turn it into a good
one later so at the very least it's not
some sort of equal game that's going to
be a draw and I like what he's doing
he's gotten his King to relative safety
he could strike with F5 and create
tension in the center that's a very
thematic idea in these types of
positions I'm on instead he's playing
this more defensively though with Rook
C8 Knight D4 yeah I think Magnus is also
uh he's looking like he wants to go for
some trades here Bishop A2 and queen E6
is gonna pick up the pawn what a shot no
way now Hikaru with a clearly better
position up a full pawn and White's King
has been breached
yeah and now with with the time getting
as low on the match clock this is it
guys this game needs to be a win for
Hikaru and he set himself up to do it
but he's got the hardest task still
ahead of him on because if he goes for
the queen trade try winning that
opposite colored Bishop n game against
Magnus Carlson Hikaru says out of the
question I'm keeping the Kings on the
board but Magnus keeps improving his
position whoa what a live he wants right
okay one eventually
yep Oh I thought he should have played
F5 there
that would have been very interesting
but instead he's just looking to
simplify okay A5 or K1 B6 the pawns are
gonna go in dark squares King is gonna
go to B7
what a move by Hikaru shutting down
White's rook and Magnus has to bring
everything back I think the position is
now getting worse yep he cars playing
really well because he's the Rooks were
too uh Advanced on the king side like
what are they doing maggots bring them
back and King B7 another amazing move
Nakamura says hey you want to attack
down the a file no no no no no I'm the
boss down the a file Magnus doing
everything he can to distract Nakamura
here comes the queen Here Comes Dire
Straits for Magnus he's on the ropes I
don't even I don't even know what to
recommend here Queen C1 rookie two
it's insane I I can't find a move Hikaru
is doing it he's got 15 seconds to find
a move and Magnus closes his eyes and
goes all in and oh my God
Rook A2 he missed it oh my goodness work
takes me six again Rook takes P6 and
it's over
rotations
oh my goodness he still has something
maybe
both Rooks are sacrificed
oh my God this might be winning by the
way but he only needs a draw as the
match clock expires and Hikaru is
exasperated oh my gosh I'm on Hikaru
it's most mate and it's a draw by
agreement and it's the match he offers a
draw a gentleman's draw and I mean what
a finish it literally comes down to the
last game and look at the smile on even
hikaru's face these guys are just two
Titans two Champions going at one
another you cannot script this any
better before we do anything before we
even congratulate Magnus we have to show
that last chance for Hikaru because he
had Rook A1 which is such a difficult
move to see and this came after this
game after Magnus missed the first
opportunity to sacrifice The Rook so
this is later Queen C2
yeah and if we could pull up pull up the
board here yeah Rook ea8 is what lost
the SEC final I'm on take it away what
would have been truly truly incredible
fashion here Queen C2 gets a double
question mark and fittingly Rook to A2
I'm going to have to award a brilliancy
uh King takes A2 Rook A8 and you clear
the way for the queen to use the A1
square that was what he called an actor
Martin needed to find that was the
difference between us being in a
tiebreaker right now and Magnus Carlson
being the SEC Champion what an
incredible finish I mean you cannot
script this any better I'm speechless
but we got more talking to do and The
Savvy move the game will come in this
last game so keep it pulled up them on
but here is the final score last year it
was a one point victory for Nakamura
this year it's a one point victory for
Magnus Carlson I'm on is there any way
then that stat to symbolize how
incredible these players are every time
they play the same thing happens it's in
insane action from the first minute to
the last
it is like it honestly feels uh right
for this match to be decided by one
point it doesn't even matter in which
direction because it has been you know
uh hikaru's match before it's been
magnus's match and these two are at the
top of chess for a reason certainly at
the top of online speed chess they
always meet in the finals and I mean
Hikaru Nakamura only loses to one person
and that's Magnus Carlson my gosh there
is no Netflix show there is no activity
Iman that I would have rather been doing
the last couple of hours then watch this
insane match we congratulate Magnus
Carlson on his victory and for our
coinbase Savvy move of the day I'm on
let me know if you disagree but I think
we need to go right back to our last
game and I think the Savvy move or shall
I say The Savvy moves have to be
magnus's Rook sacrifices because that is
ultimately what won him the match
totally
um I mean this this game right here was
the entire match just encapsulated into
one game Rook D7 was played by Magnus
he's chasing the king he knows that you
know he's about to lose the game with
Rook A2 coming but instead he comes up
with a very
Savvy set of moves not only one
sacrifice Rook takes C5 seemingly giving
away The Rook for nothing but Rook to C7
check how's that for a Savvy move to
secure an SCC title Daniel using one
Rook to break apart Black's protective
Pawn cover the other Rook to deflect the
king and Magnus realizing that mate is
inevitable offer to draw Hikaru had no
chance no choice but to accept because
the king is cornered and that folks is
how Magnus Carlson won one of the most
epic matches I've ever seen the speed
Chess Championship 2023 belongs to
Magnus Carlson but how many Hoops did he
have to jump through to get the crown
not just icaro but everybody else whom
he had to defeat
amazing stuff I mean I obviously can't
wait to hear from these players but this
was the match that you know it was hyped
up to be it always lives up to the hype
uh I mean I was just most intrigued by
that final shot of both players kind of
giving that champion Smile as they just
I think they're just realizing that
they're the best competitors for one
another and it's such an amazing rivalry
to watch it really is and it seems like
every one of their matches has so many
twists and turns it's never wired to
wire it's never a blowout it's always
one person has the momentum out of the
gates and then another person and the
fact that we had so many different
openings on we had the re Lopez stage
the fact that this match can even be
divided into stages tells us how epic it
is and you know what else is epic it's
the interview that we will have with
Magnus Carlson we will hear the winners
thoughts on this amazing Unforgettable
match and we will set Magnus up folks do
not go anywhere the interview with
Magnus and the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase coming right up
hold on to your Tukes beginning December
9th the Champions chess tour finals are
coming to Toronto Canada Magnus Carlson
Hikaru Nakamura and Notre beca AB de
sotorov have already secured their spots
in the finals thanks to their beauty
victories on the tour so far super GM's
Fabiano caruana Wesley so and alireza
faruja have secured enough points to
clinch spots as well as young Prodigy
Dennis lazovic only one spot remains up
for grabs Lavon aronian currently holds
the last qualifying spot on the
leaderboard but nothing is for sure as
several players remain in contention
including division one participants Jan
napomnishi Anish giri Maxim vashiela
grav and chakra mamadierov players will
have to give her in The Knockout rounds
of the final event the AI cup beginning
on September 25th
[Music]
foreign
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlsen and Michiana
this course is generally about examples
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest level
intuition comes from knowing a lot of
examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but under
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way having debated it so that's more
or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
[Music]
everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games
hey we're trying to have a lesson here
you need to get out of here recently
more kids have been playing chess than
ever in school but sadly we've learned
that they may not always be playing
chess at the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
[Applause]
[Music]
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
foreign
is the 2023 speed chess champion after a
five-year period in which Hikaru
Nakamura instituted hegemony over the
SEC Magnus reprises his victory from
2016 and 2017 and he is the SEC Champion
once more Magnus joins us in the studio
for an interview first question Magnus
when that final game ended I guess two
questions were you aware that that was
going to be the final game of the match
and second what how would you
characterize the emotions that flow
through your mind when the match ended
um
yeah I was just uh
um yeah I realized like towards the end
of the penultimate game that if
um
well that's the the next game would very
likely be the be the last so uh at least
if I if it was not a very short game
uh and um
yeah uh I mean after I blundered
the pawn on A2 after that I couldn't
keep
uh control uh at all and I mean I
thought I was lost uh for sure and then
I just gave a check
uh and I realized only like after giving
the check that well it looks like I have
a Perpetual now or at least a Perpetual
so yeah that was it was a bit lucky like
mentally a few months before I was
thinking that oh this is gonna be uh
we're gonna be here for another
half an hour
um but uh yeah I was just so happy so
relieved that um
that I've found that chart and that I
managed to yeah to finish the matchup
eventually
well Magnus I mean congratulations uh
from me as well what a match I think a
theme that we were noticing throughout
the match I don't know if you felt this
way as well but when Hikaru was just
kind of throwing caution to the wind and
just attacking your king straight up
those were the games that he was finding
a lot of success is that something that
you noticed uh over the match that when
he just sort of went all out for these
crazy attacks that they were just
working
yeah I I actually think Sarah could have
done that even earlier uh because
I was not in good shape today I mean I
could feel it
I could feel it at the start I could
feel it before the start really the
whole day that I was not gonna be
anywhere near the level that I was
against against Wesley
um and I I did feel very lucky
that he wasn't really trying harder to
punish me at at the start and
um
when he eventually started to to win
games then I was just thinking that uh
yeah this is
I mean I I didn't think that I was in
any kind of
uh kind of shape to to withstand the the
pressure and we went into the break in
the three one
uh he just like I think then he just won
that uh Berlin ending where I was much
better than he found some very good
resources to stay afloat and somehow I
managed to lose instead of draw uh
towards the end in general I would say
that I was not like
uh keeping my head calm whatsoever in
scrambles uh which was also which was
also a problem I don't think he was
great in scrambles either uh today but
that's usually a good indication of
whether your brain is working and mine
would just shut off
um during during scrambles while for
instance against Wesley I would still
sort of be thinking and um
um coming up with decent moves
Magnus hearkening back to the moment uh
after you got off to the four and a half
half start in the three plus one you
were down by three going into the break
what specific adjustments did you make
during the break because it it seemed
like your play looked a little bit
different it seemed like you made some
adjustments in order to tie the match
going into the bullet what did you tell
yourself and how did you set yourself up
mentally to make that comeback in the
three plus one segment
yeah I mean I started to check
um
the games a bit that I I'd lost and then
I thought yeah that's in the past uh
that's fine also I I thought that yeah
my mind was heating so I should change
to something a little bit lighter
um I had a banana you know also I think
it's not a carrot this time actually but
uh I just
thought that
even though I mean I was losing games
like he was just
uh he was just completely crushing me at
that point I I did feel that I mean from
last year and from the bullet
Championship this year that
um that I I know that I I could come
back from reasonable deficit so deficit
so I knew that it was all about whether
my brain could start working like if my
brain could start working at some point
I knew I would have I would have some
kind of chance
um
and um
uh yeah I mean I got a much needed win
with uh black the next game I
um
I mean
in terms of whether I changed and
anything like I was messing around with
both like Sicilians and and E5 and I
thought I was getting decent positions
in general so it was just a matter of a
matter of taste really
well Magnus taking a step back and just
thinking about what this result means
overall I mean can you speak about what
it means to you uh you know winning the
SEC and of course doing it against
Hikaru you guys have had such a rivalry
it's literally only been you two that
win the SEC so I mean what does it mean
to you to win the event again and
reclaim that and also against Hikaru is
such a competitor for you
so I I mean my goal
um
for this season also for the last two
seasons has been very clear uh to
sort of in a in a major way sort of
re-establish
the pecking order when it comes to comes
to speed tests and
um and to be honest I've failed
miserably in that like losing to
uh like very um even matches against
Hikaru and and Maxim and uh winning one
by by one point so
um
yeah as I said I didn't feel
good like going into today but still I'm
not at all satisfied with my performance
I feel that I can do
um I can do a lot better and I do feel
that if I played the way that I played
against Wesley then
um you know this wouldn't have been
close so in that sense
you know I'm I'm happy to get the win
but
winning should be like
I should win most of the time so I
um
so yeah obviously like when when you
played such a match it feels so much
better to
to to win than to lose so I'm happy and
relieved about that but I still haven't
managed to
achieve my goal really in the speed test
Championship
um which I did the first two two years
so I think there's still
definite history to be to be written
there
well that history will continue next
year Magnus speaking of History I think
this is a great segue to a few chat
questions before we let you take your
well-deserved rest uh a question from
bobin TV which young player Magnus do
you see becoming as good as your Hikaru
in the SEC in the future keeping in mind
the blitz time controls and keeping in
mind all of the young talents who are
terrorizing the classical Fields these
days
I think it's uh it's I mean the answer
is pretty obvious that it's alireza
ferocia uh he has clearly the highest uh
potential
um
and uh to be honest
I thought at this point that he would be
if not quite at the same level than very
very close and actually
when you mentioned these young players
and I mentioned others my feelings like
today remind me a little bit of
2020 when I lost the banter Blitz Cup
Final to to alresa also in a very even
match
um I did play him like a few weeks later
um in
the
uh in the minus Invitational and rapid
and I won a very very close match there
and that didn't satisfy me at all I had
some of the same feelings still that the
only thing that would sort of count as
revenge for me was a decisive Victory
and I I couldn't get that but uh so uh
no I think all the rest is clearly has
Highest Potential
um Niel is very strong uh I'm sure you
can improve as well
um as for the other kids uh would be
interesting to see in a couple years if
Prague could
could be um could be a contender in this
format of this Photograph as well who
knows but uh
for the moment
um alaresa is a little bit away and the
others are far away
well continuing with the chat questions
Magnus and bringing us back to the match
a little bit I admit I wanted to know
the answer to this as well but we have a
chat question from Robert balazzi who
says uh Magnus was it the change of
shirts that brought you back in the game
because you know whether or not uh it
was intentional you changed your shirt
you came in and won a bunch of games in
a row and got right back in the match
um yeah I mean I I guess it helped that
it cooled me down a little bit just
wearing something lighter as I spoke
about earlier and I I guess I made plus
four with this shirt and minus three
with the other so
the results sort of speaks for itself
well Magnus final question before we let
you go any overall Reflections from this
series SCC and how much are you looking
forward to next year's Edition can we
sign you up preemptively
yeah yeah I can just repeat what I what
I said earlier that um you know I'm
happy to have to win
uh it's better to win than to lose but
I'm I'm not satisfied so I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be back and um
I'm hoping to
um establish
establish the dominance that I I think
I can
well Magnus we always appreciate your
Insight we appreciate the effort and we
definitely appreciated this incredible
match congratulations on the speed Chess
Championship and uh we can't wait to see
what you will bring to the table next
year
congrats thank you guys always
appreciate you as well
thank you very much that was Magnus
Carlson
another Victory among another feather in
his cap he has had a chip on his
shoulder for what seems like the last
year online over the board he's got a
lot of gas left in the tank doesn't he
he really does but I mean just thinking
about what we just witnessed it was uh
down to the actual wire match between
simply to the the greatest players Dania
so as a as a fan I know I'm up here in
the commentary Booth but I just like to
think I have the best seat in the house
because that was pure entertainment we
certainly do and obviously it takes two
to tango it takes two to produce a match
of this level and unfortunately for
Hikaru fans it was not quite able to
come back but he played an epic match we
will have Hikaru for an interview in
just a couple of minutes send over your
chat questions
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
akamura fortunately he came up short in
the SEC final but it was an amazing
performance nonetheless in this match as
well as in the SEC overall hikara we
really appreciate you joining us for an
interview we won't keep you too long
could you start by sharing your overall
Reflections on that final segment of the
match
you mean the OnePlus One or the final
game
the one well perhaps both
oh okay yeah so I mean first things
first you know I think um in the in the
bullet portion it started off quite well
for me I won the first game
um but you know in the next couple of
games I didn't really get positions
where I felt like the flow of the moves
didn't seemed super easy for me and
Magnus used his time extremely well
um so I mean he built this Advantage
then then you know at the end I was able
to win the second to last game
um and this last game unfortunately I I
didn't use my time I had like 30 seconds
I guess at the end but you know we were
both moving so fast there that I wasn't
able to stop myself and um Magnus found
this great double Rook sacrifice
um you know to save the game and uh it's
what it is but it was extremely close
and uh I think considering the start I'm
pretty happy with the match overall
and Hikaru I mean I'm sure that most of
us know the answer to this but this is
obviously just not another match for you
I mean the chance to compete against
Magnus in the SEC finals I think
everyone basically predicted that would
be the case but when you go up against
Magnus in the final like this I mean
what does it mean to you uh competing
against him and obviously a chance to uh
you know change the lifetime uh score
Magnus was speaking about that not sure
if you were listening to interview as
well yeah I mean you know I think um
yeah I think to to look at the match as
a whole is very close or probably two
moments when the match probably could
have gone either way I mean in a big
Direction
um I would say that the start I don't
think either of us were super super
great definitely scrambles we weren't
playing well but Magus did start off
very fast and um there's this critical
game I don't remember what what which
game it was but he was up by two or
three and then he had this mouse slip
then I didn't take the piece then we end
up in this very long working Bishop
versus Brook game and you know I think
if Magnus had saved this game there's a
very good chance it could have gone
completely in his Direction
um and then the other moment was when I
was up by three after the break I
basically just had a sort of I don't
know if you want to call it a brain slip
or a hand slip where I put the bishop on
B5 instead of going to C4 like I've been
doing the whole match after he played
Knight sits on move two and I wasn't
really able to reel it back in that game
and I think if I if in that game I just
played Bishop C4 and what I was playing
throughout the matching it was a very
good chance I could have run away with
it but those are really the only two
moments when I think it could have gone
uh bigly in either direction after that
I think it was just it was a dog fight
and um I mean it was very close so you
know I Think Magna said he wasn't happy
with his play I actually wasn't super
happy with my play throughout the match
either but you know it is what it is
Hikari your rivalry with Magnus Carlson
is now extended to the better part of a
decade if you had to compare the sort of
stereotypical Nakamura Carlson match
from 2016 and take one from 2022 or 2023
how do you feel that you're in magnus's
Styles and approach particularly to
Blitz and bullet have changed over the
years
well I mean first things first for all
for all the morons in Chad who are busy
saying stupid things I'll be happy to
hear me say this but um you know what I
would say first and foremost is that
frankly it was not a rivalry until
probably the pandemic if I'm being
completely honest I'm Magnus had a great
score against me won pretty much every
match I would say that we played like he
won the SEC in 2016 in 2017. um so you
know Magnus just just had a great score
against you so I think saying it's a
rivalry is a little bit sort of
questionable because it was very very
one-sided but certainly since the
pandemic began uh I've done a lot better
overall against him and um so I think
it's fair to say that now it is pretty
close to rivalry because it's like even
today if you were to take this match
after the first few games and go back
five years I would have completely
folded and lost this match um and it
would have been a complete disaster so
you know it's it's I'm really happy with
the way that I played against Magnus uh
obviously today you know he was just
simply a little bit better at the
critical moments but you know I had my
chances and I think when you're playing
against you know whether you want to
call Magnus the greatest or second
graders you know all that for that whole
debate um you know he is one of the two
best players of all time and the fact
that I'm able to compete with him you
know I'm very happy
yeah well uh Hikaru obviously this match
didn't go the way you wanted but I guess
I was just gonna ask you if you had any
final thoughts about uh you know the
match overall or anything else that you
wanted to say uh here because appreciate
you coming on for an interview
yeah I mean the there are a couple
things I mean the the first thing that I
would say is you know all these people
who think they seem to realize that
times don't change people don't change
and um you know like if this had been a
match like maybe like five six years ago
I'd probably be very very upset right
now honestly
um but the fact that it was so close uh
All Things Considered I'm very happy I
guess my only regret is I wish I could
have flipped the bullet Chess
Championship in this event like I would
have preferred to have lost that and won
the SEC rather than the other way around
um but nonetheless you know I'm I'm just
very happy that I'm competitive with
Magnus overall and um you know it's it's
been a lot of fun playing the SEC I mean
I I guess like the the only thing that I
find a little bit just disheartening or
disappointing is it feels like you know
he's the only other player where it's
it's really really close uh it seems
like whenever he or I play other players
in SEC it it turns into these these very
uh ugly one-sided matches um so that's
that's the only thing perhaps I wish
like some other players would would come
up and and be in the matches
um but you know overall like again to
for the match to be so close I'm in
literally one game to be the
differential I could have gone either
when I mean I suspect uh when we have
have some fun matchups coming up in the
near future uh it'll be pretty hyped as
well
well hikara I think I speak for all of
us when I say that you gave us three
hours of Unforgettable entertainment and
obviously a new page and a new chapter
is still remaining to be written in your
uh Affair against Magnus Carlsen we look
forward to that new chapter and we
really really appreciate you coming on
to share your thoughts
no problem you guys have a good one
thanks have a good rest of your stream
and that was Hikaru Nakamura that is all
she wrote Amman he loses by a point last
year he won by a point and I think I can
Echo hikaru's words when I say that
these two players are the only ones who
are able to put together a match against
the other no one else came even close
against either Hikaru or Magnus is it a
surprise that we had a one point match
yeah I think um you know it's always
refreshing to hear both of these players
just pure raw honest thoughts I I
thought both interviews were really
interesting to hear their perspectives
and probably the most interesting things
what Hikaru said at the end just calling
it like it is uh this match is always
close no matter which way Direction it
swings in it's always close but you
don't get that sense of intrigue and
competitiveness necessarily with all the
other players so you know what what can
you say it's like uh
um problems for being that good at the
game Daniel I I can't even imagine the
nerves and the pressure that these
players feel and Magnus Carlson was
world champion for 10 years the neither
of these players is a stranger to high
pressure situations but we've talked
about it players have all talked about
it in the SEC and in these prestigious
online events it's a different kind of
pressure feeling that they're 150 000
Souls watching your every move that
produces an incredible amount of heat on
the players and the way that they handle
this as we look now at the final bracket
very sad I'm on unfortunately all of the
names have been filled out and that
means the SEC has come to a close but
man oh man was it an epic journey to the
top for both of these players in an epic
journey to the throne for Magnus Carlson
yeah barring a last second Hikaru Brook
A2 check and Checkmate combination to
send us into tie breaks it couldn't have
gotten any better than this what a
fitting way to end the SCC uh your
Champion is Grand Master Magnus Carlson
and uh you got the final that I think
everyone was hoping for and I think you
said it best just at the end there Dania
there are future chapters to be written
in this storied rivalry and I think we
are fair to call it a rivalry yes
especially now between these two as just
a point has decided things uh between
them and they're just the greatest
competitors for a reason a book will be
written on uh magnus's matches against
ikaranakamura a book can already be
written about the back and forth that we
have seen every time that they play
whether it's in the bullet Chess
Championship and fish are random any
variant choose a Time control it doesn't
matter Hikaru and Magnus always produce
the kind of incredible entertaining
chess that has made NHS a spectator
sport beyond a shadow of doubt we saw
that today not only is it a spectator
sport but it's a sport that can now
support its top earners as we take a
look at the price distribution from the
speed Chess Championship almost 50 000
for Magnus remember this is a composite
of the matches that he won as well as
the points that he has garnered so all
of those blowout victories was not lost
on the bankers hicaro with 30 000 a
pretty handsome prize as well that's a
nice car and we see the other prizes
there everybody gets something but
Magnus Carlson picks up the big pot
indeed and I think uh you know the most
exciting thing for the speed Chess
Championship is you know I liked it you
put Magnus on the spot and said hey will
we see you you know in the SEC again I
think the most exciting thing to hear
from Magnus himself was that uh you know
say what you want but the guy is not
satisfied he thinks and knows that he
can do better so you know until he's
scoring against Hikaru Nakamura which
seems Unthinkable until he's scoring
like he did against Wesley against
Hikaru it seems like he's just he can't
be satiated so from that point of view
it seems like we may write quite a few
chapters of this uh Hikaru and Magnus
match in the future and that is a good
news for the SEC
it is indeed you see this in all the
greatest athletes in the world it
doesn't matter if they've just won
Wimbledon the FIFA World Cup uh the NBA
Championship the first thing they do is
ask where did I go wrong how could I
have been better how do I be better next
time right it's not about celebrating
the victory they drive themselves to
Perfection for their entire chess career
and that is how they come the closest of
anybody to attaining that Perfection
well this match was Perfection and if
you're already experiencing withdrawal I
wanted to remind you that the chess
calendar never sleeps and it will awaken
once again uh this weekend when we head
back to school with the 2023 Collegiate
chess League fall season we return with
Team Blitz matches every Saturday
featuring the top talent in American
college chess and it all kicks off
tomorrow tomorrow Saturday September the
23rd of course there's also bulla brawl
there is plenty of action tune in
wherever you watch chess.com streams and
use x Glam CCL that's exclamation mark
CCL in the chat for everything you need
to know about the season well we know
everything we need to know about the SCC
I'm on for the final time today I will
hand the mic back to you for your
overall thoughts on today's match and
yet another epic season of the speed
Chess Championship
it is I think that CC never disappoints
um and despite having an inkling or
maybe having a a preference for some of
the fans out there they're thinking oh I
just want to see Magnus and Hikaru play
in the final it was never a guarantee
that that they would be there but
they're both on form both completely
deserving uh to be in the final and they
didn't just get to the final and uh and
face off against each other they gave
the fans literally exactly what they
were chomping at the bit for a lead from
both players momentum swings attacks
like crazy car was going after magnus's
King today some really exciting chess
tons of brilliancies and literally down
to the final game Dania I mean not only
could I not think of a better match to
commentate in the in the final but not a
better partner either so happy to have
the call with you Dania oh I'm very
touched I'm on and likewise it takes an
entire Village and first and foremost
I'd like to thank you for your wit and
you're in insight and just being such an
easy partner to work with next I'd like
to thank everybody in the chat we had
over a hundred and twenty five thousand
of you and the great thing about the SEC
everybody comes out with a smile on
their face whether you're a Hikaru fan a
Magnus fan or whether you were hoping
for an outstanding performance by
someone else in the field we all have to
come together for a second and agree
that there was no better way to spend
the previous three hours our production
team worked so hard behind the scenes
our producer holla uh for an incredible
job yet again and everybody else on our
chess.com team for being responsible for
these amazing broadcasts and making our
jobs easy folks the CCL returns this
weekend the SCC returns next year and a
big big thank you once again from
Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky and
Grandmaster Roman Hamilton you were
watching the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase so long
bye guys
Bishop F4 itself was so bad
oh my goodness he drops a minor piece
and Magnus strikes first after that
initial draw wait a minute Rook G8 check
Rook G8 check what a bow wow wow oh
and Rook takes you three blunted his
Queen Magnus blundered his Queen he
can't cover with the Knight and Hikaru
wins unbelievable this game went up in
Flames oh my gosh there's a queen
Sacramento
oh
my goodness that is beautiful wow just
wow oh no oh no oh no oh no
there's only one move in that position
and nobody can
can't believe it Magnus is like how did
this just happen if the King was on D4
different story why did he lose he's got
his King tap six and a human you know
he's lost he has lost a critical game
allowing Magnus to tie the match up to
E4 potentially and Magnus is a gross he
now slipped what was that dad what are
you doing you've got 15 seconds dicaro
doing everything he can to open up
whites King but I think that this has
enough yeah just like that Magnus flips
the script oh my goodness
he missed it oh my gosh I'm on Hikaru
had this space to me and it's a draw by
agreement these guys are just two Titans
two Champions going out one another
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign